hello everyone and welcome to simply
learns youtube channel today we'll be
taking you through the javascript and
jquery full codes
this course is designed in such a way
that it will cover every important
aspect from the basics of both
javascript and jquery to advanced level
topics by the end of this tutorial you
will be able to implement javascript and
jquery in different ways
before getting started with the full
course tutorial let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on multiple
technology videos so if you are a tech
geek in a continuous hunt for the latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and press that bell icon to
never miss any updates from simpler
so without any further delay let's get
started
let's go through the agenda for this
full course tutorial
we'll start this video with an
introduction to javascript and why one
should learn javascript following that
we'll cover basic javascript topics like
areas loops and function in javascript
along with some advanced level topics
like promises in javascript
we have some specific projects waiting
for you guys we'll create some games and
a fully functional ecommerce website to
understand javascript in a better way
upon completing javascript we'll move on
and cover jquery as well
we'll cover everything you need to know
and understand about jquery
and jquery ui we'll see what jquery is
and cover topics like jquery selectors
events and effects callback functions in
jquery and how jquery manipulates the
document object model following that
we'll go through a brief introduction to
jquery ui we'll then cover certain
topics like widgets and interactions in
jquery we'll also see how jquery is used
for theme customization
at the end of this full course tutorial
we'll create some jquery projects like
creating a calculator app a to-do list
and a fully functional website using
html css and jquery
let's start this video with an
introduction to javascript
javascript was developed in the year
by a person named brendan ike
brendan was working for netscape
communications while he developed
javascript in 10 days
there were a few changes in the name of
javascript initially it was moca which
was later changed to live script and
then it finally became javascript
the start of javascript wasn't that good
as so many developers who were using
java at that time
they considered javascript as a language
for designers and non-engineers
no one ever knew that this small side
scripting language would have a great
future today more than 90 percent of the
websites out there they are using
javascript somehow many of you guys gets
confused with java and javascript let me
clear it for you that both java and
javascript they are different languages
they have almost nothing in common
many people say that javascript was
named after java as a part of a
marketing strategy to gain wider
acceptance and recognition in 1995 java
was a buzzword when javascript was
developed that's why they renamed
javascript after java let's move on to
what is javascript
have you guys ever been through a
website where you can see images that
slides automatically one such website is
amazon the home page of amazon where we
can see different types of ongoing sales
is an example of javascript
in layman language javascript is a
lightweight scripting language used to
make web pages more interactive and more
lively earlier when javascript was
developed it was only a side scripting
language to do basic tasks like you can
add pop-ups in your web page or you can
make your web page more interactive
nothing more than that but now the whole
scenario has changed with the help of
javascript we can create applications as
well
if we talk about applications let's take
an example let's suppose we want to
create an app we can create it in
android or in ios but we have to learn
few different languages to create those
apps for android we have to learn java
and xml and swift we have to learn for
ios but with the help of javascript you
can create hybrid applications which can
work on any platform without any problem
tech giants like google paypal amazon
and youtube they are using javascript
these days the evolution of javascript
in the past few years was unbelievable
suppose you want to create a single page
website every one of us is familiar with
gmail let's suppose
so gmail is a single page website which
looks more like a desktop software than
a website so gmail is based on
angular.js it is a popular framework by
google which is free of cost and it is
totally based on javascript now let's go
over some of the features of javascript
these features are actually why it is
considered that using javascript is
advantageous over other languages
so let's start with some of these points
javascript is not a proper programming
language indeed it is a scripting
language
which works in the runtime environment
just like python
so there are few other languages like c
plus plus and java they need a compiler
to work but with javascript you don't
need a compiler once you are done with
the script
it will interpret and show you the
output in the browser directly
next up is lightweighted javascript can
provide programming facility to some
extent in javascript you don't need to
specify any data type or return type
which helps in making development more
quicker that's why it is known as light
weighted
javascript is both client-side as well
as server-side technology client-side
technology runs on the user's computer
whereas the server-side technology runs
on the web browser initially when
javascript was introduced it was
introduced as a client-side technology
but with the introduction of node.js in
2009 one can now work in the backend as
well
there is a way to validate the user's
data before sending it to the web server
and we can do that with the help of
javascript the data will be checked for
correct form and value
all we have to do is start a loop give
it the condition
to check the data javascript is also
platform independent although originally
designed to work on browsers only but
now it is a platform independent
language which means once you are done
with the script you can use it on any
browser or platform without any problem
javascript is an object based scripting
language
although many programmers do not
consider javascript as a true object
oriented programming language due to its
lack of class concept
it does support other features of object
oriented programming like it supports
encapsulation it supports polymorphism
and also it supports prototypal
inheritance
the last but not the least feature of
javascript is case sensitive so when it
comes to keywords identifiers names and
functions javascript differentiates
between capital and lowercase letters we
have to keep this in mind while
programming
now i will quickly go over some of the
javascript applications where javascript
is currently being implemented
first one that comes to every person's
mind is web development it was also the
main motive behind developing javascript
we have technologies like angular we
have node.js we can create beautiful web
pages
also javascript can be used along with
html and css to make those static
looking web pages more engaging if we
talk about other applications of
javascript we can use it in app
development either mobile app or web app
like we took the example before that how
hybrid apps made with the help of
javascript can take over traditional
android and ios app
one of the most important and unique
application of javascript is in
smartwatches the bengal.js is an open
sourced smartwatch powered by javascript
gordon williams the man who is currently
working on this project it is said that
this new open sourced stack built around
javascript will replace the onboard
firmware soon the next application of
javascript is client-side validation as
we discussed earlier javascript is used
to validate the user data whether the
user's input is correct or not by cross
checking it with the given condition
like the user wants to enter in your
website and you want it to be a user
with at the right gmail.com in his email
id so you will give that condition to
javascript and it will cross check it
with the user's information like when
the user will try to enter in your
website it will check that if at the
rate gmail.com is there or not in the
user's email id
so it can validate the user also apart
from that one more application of
javascript is game development
javascript can be used to make fully
fledged 2d or 3d games using different
libraries although most javascript game
development focuses on creating games
used in browsers only
till now we have an idea about what
javascript is its features and its
applications so if you want to learn
javascript you need to do some basic
things to make your learning experience
more smoother let's take a look at the
prerequisites to use javascript the
first one is the basic knowledge of html
and css to use javascript along with
html and css you first need to know how
html and css works see html is used to
create the structure of a web page while
css is used to style that web page in
order to use these two with javascript
you need to have the basic knowledge of
html and css because if you want to
learn a new language first of all you
need to know why to use that technology
and to learn javascript more efficiently
you need to have the basic knowledge of
html and css
it's better to have a web browser that
supports javascript like google chrome
or mozilla firefox or you can use safari
as well if you are using a macbook you
will need an operating system like
windows linux or mac operating system to
learn javascript a computer with minimum
512 mb of ram would be enough for you to
start learning javascript but i will
recommend you a computer with 1gb of ram
or 4gb of ram for a better experience
you can use any text editor you have
notepad which is free and is already
available for windows
if you don't want to use notepad you can
use other free softwares like sublime or
you can use visual code in this
particular course we will be using
visual code and i'll tell you how to
install visual code and what are the
features of visual code also suppose you
do not have any prior knowledge about
javascript don't worry about it we will
take you through the whole course and we
will ensure that you can understand
javascript let's start this video with
some facts about javascript
javascript is the only programming
language that a browser can understand
25 years ago when developers were
thinking about a language that a browser
can understand
there were a few languages that were
present in the market at that time just
like java still there were some problems
with these languages
that these languages need a server to
work with the browser javascript on the
other hand can work directly with the
browser you write the code in the editor
the browser will go through it it will
interpret it and then runs the program
the popularity of javascript increased
with time
being a language which can do so many
tasks whether it be designing a
website's front end or going through any
website's backend javascript can do
anything by the end of 2018 over 95
percent of the internet was powered by
javascript means almost every website
out there is using javascript in some
way or another
do you guys know about stack overflow a
website for every programmer don't worry
you will get to know about it once you
start with the programming part stack
overflow states that javascript is the
most popular programming language used
by the developers
let me quickly run you through the
reasons why one should learn javascript
and then we'll briefly elaborate each of
these reasons
javascript has the most powerful
frameworks
javascript is constantly growing and is
a well-paid job javascript is beginner
friendly and it has the largest
community
javascript provides wide range of usage
as well
let's move on further and see
why each of these reason is important
javascript has the most powerful
frameworks for every task a user wants
to do like for designing a single page
website like you want to
design a website like gmail you can use
angular.js if you want to design ui
components or user interfaces for single
page application you have react.js you
want to develop a mobile or a desktop
application let's suppose you have
view.js for that as well basically you
can do anything with powerful javascript
frameworks
next up is constant truth one of the
main reasons behind one should learn
javascript javascript is one of the
fastest growing languages and stands
among the top 10 languages used by the
developers with so much increase in
mobile market mobile web development has
seen an immense rise in need of
interactivity
which is possible only with the help of
javascript
that's why javascript is continuously
growing and there is no way that
javascript will go down shortly
the developers working in javascript are
well paid across the world anyone who
wants to be a web designer or a web
developer needs to learn javascript it
is a must have skill for being a good
web developer we will discuss it in
javascript jobs section
javascript is an easy to learn language
compared to many other programming
languages
like java python and php javascript
provides easy entry points to the world
of programming the best thing about
javascript is that it comes
pre-installed on almost every web
browser so you don't need to set up any
environment to start development in
javascript which means you can start
coding right away
javascript has the largest community
among all the programming languages out
there
community size does matter when it comes
to programming language because the
larger the community size sizes
the more help you would be likely to get
currently javascript has the biggest
stack overflow community it has
overtaken java in terms of community
size and is still growing at a rapid
pace wide range of usage in my opinion
one of the most important reasons why
one should learn javascript by knowing
javascript you can build an entire
website from its backend to the front
apart from that you can also build a
full flash mobile application for the
back end you don't need to learn other
programming languages node.js is enough
with a bit of knowledge about database
and apis there is nothing you can't do
with javascript when it comes to website
development
let's move on and discuss few jobs you
can take up after learning javascript
and we'll also discuss their average
salaries in usa and in india
so the first one is a full stack
developer a full stack developer is one
of the highest paid jobs in web
development sector a full stack
developer is equally proficient in
client side as well as server side
development a full stack developer earns
around 9 lakh per annum which is quite a
decent amount of money for a person
living in india but if you are a full
stack developer in u.s you can earn up
to hundred thousand dollars per annum
which is a huge amount
a front-end developer is the one who
deals with the front end of any website
or application it's obvious that a
front-end developer will not earn as
much as a full stack developer
but the amount of money a front-end
developer earns in a year is decent a
javascript developer works on the
front-end and sometimes back and also
a javascript developer may be
responsible for the whole website or
just a few aspects or pages of different
websites they earn quite well when it
comes to salary a js developer in us
earns around 75 000 per annum which when
converted to indian rupees sums around
55 lakhs approx which is a huge amount
designing a ui is an interesting job as
it needs creativity along with skills
it's always fun to design interfaces to
attract users one should need a lot of
creativity for this job the amount of
money a ui ux designer earns in india is
around 7 lakh per annum but it can go up
as much as 20 lakh per annum depends
upon the skills possessed and creativity
of the designer so choose your career
wisely let's start this video with the
introduction to dom
dom stands for document object model it
is an api for html and xml documents
which helps javascript to understand
what is there written inside the html
document
api stands for application programming
interface to understand api better let's
take an example of a restaurant
imagine yourself in the restaurant you
are sitting at the table with the menu
the chef in the kitchen is also part of
the system the waiter here works as a
messenger between you and the chef
that's what api does it works as a
moderator between javascript and the
html document
dom defines the whole html document in a
hierarchical form to make it
understandable for javascript so that
other javascript functions can work over
it it represents the entire document in
the form of object and nodes
whether it be elements or text or
anything stored in the document the
entire page content can be accessed or
manipulated by javascript
dom is not used with javascript only
other languages like python also uses
dom dom was designed to be used
independently to begin with dom there is
nothing special you have to do different
browsers have different implementation
of the document object model
every browser uses dom to make the web
page of the document accessible by
javascript let's move on and see what is
document object model with the help of
an example
i believe you guys have the basic
knowledge of html and css a prerequisite
for this course let's start things off
with a basic html example here we have a
code that consists tags like html head
body heading tag etc we have the html
tag here the opening html tag and the
closing html tag inside the html tag we
have the head tag which contains the
document's header part inside the head
tag there is a title tag that contains
the title of the web page then comes the
body tag which contains a heading tag
and two div tags with ids as div 1 and
div 2. a div tag defines a particular
section in the html document the id used
within the div tag it is an attribute
basically that has to be unique within
the document to make the element unique
from other elements next up we have a
paragraph tag with a class attribute
within it css and javascript uses
classes to select and access specific
element don't worry guys if you have no
idea about it let us first see the
output of this code before going to the
document object model
of this whole document so guys this is
the output of the previous code we just
came through here we can see the title
of the webpage as well as heading after
it there were two different div tags
used in the code here is the output of
both the div text the question here is
where are those id and class attributes
seen in the output the answer to this
question is there is nothing on this web
page that can show both of them we can
use them in our css file or through
javascript to specify the containers in
which they are used so we have concluded
how a normal document works and how the
browser interprets the html code but how
javascript uses this code is a bit
different that's where dom comes into
play when the actual html document is
loaded in the browser another
representation of that document is
created known as document object model
here's the model you can see on your
screen
each of the tags used in html document
is correspondingly represented as object
in the dom
like starting from the html tag and
covering all the other tags like head
title body and few more
the same hierarchy as there was in the
html document goes with the document
object model also
document object model is simply the same
html document with different
representation
the reason behind this different
representation is that it's easy for
javascript to interpret this format
javascript can't understand tags but it
can understand these objects javascript
can easily manipulate these objects
using different functions which we will
see in future while working on these
functions for example if you want to
access the text present inside the
heading tag you can do it by accessing
the heading tag with javascript
you can also work on the style of this
text with the help of javascript as well
javascript uses the concept of nodes it
can access nodes of the document object
model there are many types of nodes
present in the dom the basic three types
are element node attribute node and text
mode the element node consists of all
the tags used in html document like the
head tag and the body tag the attribute
node contains the attributes used in
html document by now i hope you have
understood the concept of attributes so
javascript can access these attributes
as well and the user can work upon them
as per requirements
the text here in the html document that
is simply
it can also be accessed with the help of
javascript it is the value of that
particular element before installing vs
code let's discuss a few things about
what is an ide
so ide stands for integrated development
environment it is a software application
basically it comprehends facilities to a
programmer for software development just
like photoshop makes it easier for us to
edit photos in the same way ide makes it
easier for a programmer to write code if
you want to write code ide will help you
write that and it will help you in
software development
there are a number of ides present in
the market today we have sublime we have
pycharm we have comodo we have notepad
and notepad plus plus as well but in
this particular course we will be using
visual studio code or vs code we can say
so let me run you through some of the
advantages that why we are using vs code
for this course so first of all vs code
is free to use as it is an open source
software so you can use it without any
cost it supports multiple programming
languages there is nothing like you need
any web support or work on different
editors for different programming you
can use vs code for different languages
extensions are also one of the main
reasons behind using vs code see you
want to work on a programming language
it does not support all you have to do
is add an extension search for it and
you are good to go it will also not
affect the speed of the editor as it
runs as a different process
it can also detect code snippet whether
it is complete or not like you are using
a variable in your program and you
forgot to declare it
vs code will do it for you this property
is known as intellisense
besides all these properties one main
key feature behind using vs code is it
is cross platform it is available for
mac it is available for linux and
windows as well i think there are enough
features we have discussed till now
there are many more features we will
discuss them while installing or while
working in vs code so for now let's move
on to the installation process the
installation process for vs code is
pretty simple just go to google and
search for vs code
the next page which will open here you
can see that the first link available is
from the official website click on that
and you will go to their official
website here in the front you can see
the download this you can download the
stable version from here only
or if you want to download it for you
according to your pc's specifications
you can click on the download button
present at the top right corner of your
screen here you can see that vs code is
available for different platforms it is
available for windows for linux and for
mac as well you can download it from
here as well so if you want to download
this for windows you can click here
it will take you to another page and it
will start downloading vs once the
download completes open the setup file
from your downloads and it will take you
to the license agreement page you have
to agree with all the terms and
conditions you can go through the full
license but then it will take a lot of
time to go through all this once you
click on it
this window will open where you have to
select the location you want your vs
code to locate
any id you install the default location
for all the editors is the same you can
click on browse and select any other
location if you want
but for now i'll be leaving it as it is
and i'll click on next now this will
open and you will click next from here
now it will ask you some questions like
if you want to create a desktop icon or
not select all of them and click on next
now click on install and it will install
vs code for you sit back and relax it
will take time so once you are done with
the installation process click on finish
and the visual studio code will start
automatically
so here we are you can see that we are
on the welcome page so let's start with
these icon present on the left side of
the editor this icon here is explorer so
vs code works with the folders in your
system click on open folder
and just search any folder or you can
take any folder of your choice
so here in my pc i'll go to work and
i'll
take javascript as my folder i'll select
it and see it will open the folder and i
already have a few programs written over
here like this
and i have a few more programs like this
and this
you can open any program from that
folder by using this explorer option you
can open any program present in that
folder so basically what it does any
program you make in visual studio code
you will save it in this folder only so
it will be easy for you
to open any program anytime next up we
have the search button
to find any keyword or word present in
your code whatever you write here it
will show you where it is present in
your code or in your document
so let's suppose i write here simply
learn see it will show you simply learn
in your main screen so you have a
shortcut key for this also press control
plus f from your keyboard and write
anything here like it's written simply
linear press enter and it'll show you
the result the third option here is for
version control if you want to use any
version control like you want to use git
vs code has very good integration with
kit the next button here is for debug or
it will run your program once you are
done with writing the code click here
and run and debug just open it with
chrome you have a shortcut for this as
well press f5 from your keyboard and it
will do the same the next button here is
for extensions here you can find many
extensions given by the vs code
community
they are free to use
for now
we will use these three extensions the
first one is html css support just click
on the search button write html css
support the first option click on that
and install that extension similarly you
have to install few more you have to
install javascript and type script
nightly
and you have to install live server in
the same way i'll tell you the use of
live server in the next video when we
will be writing our first hello world
program let me end this video by giving
you a shortcut let's create a new file
here click here create a new file
just
close it create a new file we will name
it as
new
dot html
so it's new.html here one thing you have
to keep in mind
while saving a file make sure to save
that file with dot html extension here
we are about to start writing our first
program so just write
exclamation mark and press enter
it will do this see it will write the
basic html code which you will need in
almost every program from now on so you
don't have to write this code every time
just do it this way and start writing
main program we are using vs code studio
as a text editor to write the script
here we have already discussed the
benefits as well as the features of vs
code in the previous video so as i have
already mentioned you must have a web
browser with javascript enabled in it so
if you are using google chrome it's
quite easy to enable javascript let me
take you through it open google chrome
go to settings and just write javascript
in the search option go to site settings
and scroll down you will find here
javascript allow it if it's not allowed
in my case it's already allowed so i'm
good to go
once you have downloaded the editor and
you are done with the environment setup
and all you can start writing the
program so let's go
to escort we will open a new file here
and save it with the name let's open a
new file and we will save it with name
first dot html make sure to save your
file with dot html extension as it will
make it easy for the computer to
understand that this particular file is
an html file so
in the last video we installed an
extension named live server let me tell
you how to use it and what are the
benefits of using live server
so let's write a basic html program or
just press the exclamation key and press
enter here we are with the basic html
program
we have not done anything yet just edit
it a little bit we will add a heading
tag and inside the heading tag we will
write a heading let's suppose we are
writing
hello
so now right click on your desktop and
click on open with live server
what this will do it will open your
program in the browser see it's the
basic thing so let me tell you what its
benefits are it will open your program
in the browser and whatever changes you
are making in the programs will be
directly shown in the browser the moment
you save them see just use google chrome
or whatever browser you are using
and in the vs code side by side we will
be using it side by side now
let's suppose we'll change something
here let's add a word here hello
world and the moment we save it it will
be reflected in your browser as well so
that's the benefit of using live server
we will be using it during our whole
code so now we are done with that let's
start with the program so here we are
with our basic html code which has only
tags in it it'll print that thing if i
remove this heading tag let me remove it
and movement i save it it will print
nothing
so guys let me give you a brief
introduction to these tags these html
tags are used to render html files
properties so that the browser can
differentiate between simple text and
html tags
you can use as many tags according to
your requirements in our first program
we will write a single line statement
over the browser for that we will need
the script tag don't worry if you don't
know much about script tech
let me tell you briefly about this text
functionality it is used to embed a
client-side script language remember
guys script tag is used to embed
javascript with html this is where html
and javascript comes together
it may contain the scripting statements
or point towards the external script
through the src attribute we will see
the src attribute as well we'll use the
script tag inside the body tag or we can
use it wherever we want to use it like
it's not necessary to use it inside the
body tag only we can use it anywhere in
our program so let's start with this
first let's start the script ad
we are done with it now the script tag
we have to type an attribute
the attribute is the type is it's a text
file
we are done with our script tag to write
on the web page we use a very basic
command the document.write
it is a javascript method using which
you can print anything on the browser
let's see what document.write can do
let's write here something
document.write
and any text you want to write inside it
let's suppose hello world
welcome to
simply code
so guys we are done with this we have
written a text over here hello world
welcome to simply code let's see what
will happen when we save it
press ctrl
s and the moment you save it here it
will be reflected on your browser here
you can see in our browser it's written
over here hello world welcome to
simplico we can define javascript in an
external file as well let's see how we
can do this how this script tag will
point towards an external javascript
file here what you have to do you have
written script just before type use an
attribute src
and give it the source of the file but
till now we don't have any javascript
file so let's create a file first name
it as
script.js remember you have to save it
with dot js extension we are done with
it and we are good to go so here we will
write document
dot right
and any text you want to write here
hello world welcome to
simply learn
we will save it the moment we will save
it here
there's something wrong i guess
okay we have not given the source code
of that javascript so here we will have
to give the name of that file it was
script dot js
moment we will save it see the text has
changed here
initially it was hello world welcome to
simply code but now it is hello world
welcome to simply learn
this document.write is not interpreted
by the browser that's because this
script tag is now pointing towards an
external javascript file anything you
will write inside this script tag will
not be considered now so we are done
with this script tag here we now have an
idea of how to embed javascript with
html and now let's see some of the
features of document.write
so let's suppose you are you have
written this text here let's erase it
and see what else it can do let's give
it a task to add two numbers let's
suppose we have given here nine plus
three let's see if it works
see
it will give you the output directly
here document don't write nine plus
three it will give you the output as 12.
similarly you will do
any mathematical task any calculation
you want to do
let's suppose
multiplied by
8.
see
you can see here 12 56 square let's
give it another one nine multiply five
minus let's suppose three and save it
three nine into five is 45 and if you
minus 3 from 45 you'll get 42. here is
the answer for s 42
56 is for 7 into 8 7 multiplied by 8 and
12 is for 9 plus 3
so with that we are done with how to
embed with
javascript with html let's move on to
another concept in javascript that is
console.log console.log is a function in
javascript that works the same as
document.write
but it will not print anything in the
browser let's give it a try
let's
clear this and suppose we write here
console.log
and give it a command
save it and see there is nothing printed
on the browser let's write something in
the body tag we'll use a heading tag and
write something here let's go again and
go to body tag we'll use a heading tag
here as well
and write something here let's suppose
we write
code
save it see this is printed on the
browser to open your browser's console
go to browser right click here and go to
inspect element or you can use control
plus shift plus i which i normally do
here you can see the console option see
it has many options like elements
consoles sources network and many more
but for now let's focus on console here
you can see the text printed here so
what's the point of doing this whenever
we write a code we usually have many
variables and functions and a lot of
these kinds of things
we don't always know what to expect as
the output maybe we expect a particular
result but we might get something else
one way of debugging our code is that we
can pass a value to this function here
only and we can check the result of that
value out of the code let's add two
numbers here so if you don't understand
it basically what we are doing for now
we are writing a small piece of code
like the program is not that big but
later on when we are good with
javascript and we will use javascript as
a primary language the
size of the program will go longer and
longer so not every time you are
supposed to
check the output of your code by doing
that only so if you are using any
variables or you are using any functions
you can check the output here only if
you have to use that variable in that
way or you have to change something so
you will get it here only that's the use
of console.log
let's add two numbers
and remove it a is equal to five and let
these value is eight
suppose
okay we are done with these two numbers
and we will what we will do we will
write
console.log
we have given it the command to add a
and b
let's see if it works here
see the value of a plus b is 13 you can
see it here in console the value is 13
you can see it here so here we can see
that the output is 13 you can do any
complex calculation here in the console
it will give you the correct answer you
can see here script dot js colon 4 the
number after the column is the line in
script.js here in our file we can see
that the console.log command is in line
number four so here it is written that
it is line number four here so if you
click on this
you can see
the script.js opened in a very small
window and you can edit it from here as
well so this is not a random line number
to prove this let's go on to a program
and let's move this to another line see
now the console.log is in line 11.
save it and here you can see this also
changed to 11 so let's make this more
complex add another variable c we'll add
another variable here let suppose we had
c here we'll give it a more complex
equation let's suppose
let c equals to
the moment we save it it will give it
the answer
oh no we are done with the equation
let's change it here also the value of
c is
let's see if it works or not press
control plus s it's saved and the value
of c is 7 let's see if this value is
correct or not the value of a was 5
5 into 3 is 15
15 plus 8 is 23 23 plus 4 is 27
plus
a minus 25 value of a is 5 minus 25 is
minus 20
27 minus 20 the value of c is 7 c it's
correct
check it yourself if you can do
something more interesting with this
console.log or you can do something more
interesting with document.write
so console.log allows us to debug our
code and we can use it if we are not
sure about the output in a lengthy
program variables are named storage that
a program can manipulate as the name
suggests a variable is a value that can
change according to conditions variables
refers to those memory blocks inside the
computer where we can store information
let's suppose you want to store any
value inside your computer so variable
will represent the location of that
value
in simple terms variables are cups with
stuff inside them and you can use that
stuff later again and again according to
the way you want to before the
introduction of es6 or ecmascript we can
frequency which is the updated version
of javascript variables were declared
using a single keyword only which is
where we'll try to declare a few
variables here we'll see how where
keyword works
so let's comment this thing first
so let's declare a few variables let's
suppose where a equals to
15 will declare
where b and the value of b will be six
we will declare where
c and the value of c would be
a plus b so here we have defined three
variables a b and c
a is a variable with value 15 stored
inside it and so is b the value of b is
six
but c is a variable that will contain
the value of a plus b let's try to print
this on browser
document.write
and we will print the value of c
save it and here you can see the value
of c is 21
that's the correct answer so similarly
you can also print a and b as well let's
print a and b as well here what we will
do we will copy this line
we will paste it for
a and
we will update this here as well
so it won't create any confusion
so here you can see the value of c is 21
the value of a is 15 and the value of b
is 6. it shows the value of all the
three variables we declared but with the
introduction of es6 or ecmascript in
two more ways were introduced to declare
a variable these are let and const we
shall discuss these two terms in the
later part of this session let me show
you how to declare a variable there are
a few things you have to keep in mind
while declaring a variable name here we
have seen we use three variables a b and
c
that was an easy task to do but giving a
variable any name like something other
than a single alphabet so you have to
keep a few things in mind while naming
them start them with a letter underscore
or a dollar sign
you can't use any sign except underscore
or dollar
so if you are
giving a variable name
you can't use any other sign except the
underscore or the dollar sign
you can use these two signs only you
can't use any other sign
you can't use a number in the starting
apart from that let's suppose you want
to give it a name as 9be you can't do
that in javascript javascript won't
allow you this if you try to save it it
will throw you an error invalid or
unexpected token so you can't do this in
javascript there is no limit for the
length of the variable name
but you can't use reserved keywords in a
variable name like let's try to create a
variable with name as class class is a
reserved keyword in javascript
we'll save it and see here it throws an
error unexpected token class
but
you can use a class with capital c
let's save it and here it will work fine
why it works because javascript
variables are case sensitive if we try
to create a variable with same name
let's see we try to create a variable
with where girl and another variable
will be where girl with capital g this
time javascript will treat these two
variables differently these two are
different variables for javascript as
javascript is case sensitive when it
comes to variables
let's declare a few more variables let's
remove it we'll declare a few more
variables let's comment this part as
well
it will declare a few more variables
suppose we declare a variable with
keyword where and we will name this
variable as bikening where
bike name
and press enter
if we leave this variable without
assigning it any value the by default
value will be undefined let's try to
print the value of this variable
right we will try to print the value of
byte name
save it here you can see the value it
shows is undefined so the by default
value of a variable if you do not assign
it any value will be undefined
let's try to give it a value let's
suppose we
try to give bike name we use equals to
operator to assign it a value to assign
let's suppose we'll assign it
yamaha
semicolon and press ctrl plus s to save
this and here you can see the output as
yamaha you can also assign a value to
the variable during declaration as we
have done in the previous examples here
we have assigned the variables value at
the time of declaration only let's move
on to let and const
so we will discuss let and cons but
first we will compare let with where let
is also used to declare a variable just
like where is used but there is a
limitation to use let
let is not accessible outside the block
in which it is declared
so we will use let here only let bike
name equals and we will change this
value as well we will change it to hero
let's say save it and here you can see
the output as hero but if we try to put
this code inside a block
let's suppose we put this code inside
this block a pair of curly braces
and we will again try to access
dot right we will try to access bike
name again from here from outside the
block we try to access this save it and
here you can see by name is not defined
it is an error in line 18. so what's
happening here basically you can't
access a let variable outside the scope
you can't access it from here but it
will work with where we try to replace
that with where and save it here you can
see it says hero and hero
because first it will interpret this
method and then it will interpret this
as well in case of where due to its
limited scope let variables are used
when there is limited use only like in
for loop or in while loop we will learn
these loop in future let will not allow
you to re-declare any variable let's
understand this with an example here is
the code as well we have declared
where bike name and we'll remove this
and first we'll try to do this with
where let's suppose where bike name
equals to
tvs control plus s it says hero and tvs
so the variable name the bike name is
same in both cases here and here as well
these are same but with where keyword
you can do that let will not allow you
to do this if we use let here in place
of
where we'll write let here as well and
we'll change the value as well we will
give it as
kawasaki
and
let's suppose suzuki here
save it
see bike name has already been declared
so that's what let won't allow you to do
you can repeat the same let variable in
different scope it won't create any
problem but it will not allow you to
redeclare any declared variable so let's
move on to const we use const when there
are values we don't want to change or
that will never change basically so the
keyword constant is little misleading as
it defines a constant reference to a
value not the constant value we can't
change the primitive value but we can
change the properties of constant
objects
let's write another piece of code for
const keyword
so let's declare a
variable const x
is equal to
comma y is equal to
7 let's say once
so here what we have done we declared a
variable x and a variable y with value
as 5 and 7 we declared this time with
const keyword and variable z which is x
plus y
we printed z on the browser and it shows
the value as 12 which is x plus y 7 plus
5 is equal to 12
now what we will do
const will let you do this but if you
try to update the value of x let's
suppose we try to
update the value of x as x equals to x
plus 10
we'll print
x this time
document.write
x let's save this it will throw an error
assignment to a constant variable in
line 24. so here you want to update the
value of x you can't do this with const
keyword you can do this with let and
where as well but you can't do this with
const
also const won't allow you to redeclare
any variable just like let so if you try
to use const x again
is equal to 10 save it
so here it says identifier x has already
been declared this thing you can do with
cons the scope of const is the same as
let it can be used within the block
where it is declared data types is an
essential concept in every programming
language to work on any variable you
should know its type
it refers to the kind of data which is
being stored inside a variable
the type of variable is holding
basically
every programming language has its own
set of data types which is unique in its
own way
we discussed earlier that javascript is
a lightweight scripting language
because we don't need to specify any
data type in javascript after all all
the variables in javascript are loosely
packed or we can say javascript is a
dynamically typed scripting language we
shall discuss these properties later in
this video for now let me tell you about
different data types present in
javascript
so javascript data types are divided
into two categories primitive data types
and non-primitive data types primitive
data types are stored in stack whereas
non-primitive data types they are stored
in heap i don't want you to go deep in
these two terms as if you are new to
programming so we'll leave it just keep
one thing in mind that primitive data
types are base data types whereas
non-primitive data types are objects or
we can say they are derived
primitive data types they are further
divided into five categories they are
divided as numbers strings boolean
undefined null non-primitive data types
or complex data types we can say on the
other hand they are divided into two
parts arrays and objects we'll have
separate videos on these topics for now
let's discuss primitive data types to
understand primitive data types much
better
let's declare a few variable here
let's say we declare where x and give it
the value as 16
we'll declare where y
and we'll give it value
hello wool we'll declare one more let's
say where
flag
and the value will be true
here we can talk about those properties
of javascript which i mentioned earlier
javascript variables are loosely packed
and javascript is a dynamically typed
scripting language these two points
refer to the same thing here you can see
we have defined three variables
x we have defined variable x we have
defined variable y and flag as well
the values for all three variables is
different from one another
see variable x is holding a value that
is 16 variable y
is holding a value hello world which is
a string so 16 is a number hello world
is a string and variable flag is holding
a value that refers to a boolean value
in place of true we can also write false
here
so
what's happening here here you can see
there is no data type if you are coming
from a c plus background or a java
background
this will be a little bit weird for you
guys because in c plus and java we used
to do it like we will define an integer
let let me show you
so how we will define integer in c plus
plus or what we'll say we'll use int x
equals to five
or something like that we already had a
data type for string as well we have
carrying c plus plus but here in
javascript we have no data type we are
only using the where keyword that's what
we call as loosely typed
this line means that you don't have to
define the data type of the variable
what happens in javascript is whatever
the type of value you will pass to the
variable the data type will change
accordingly
so you don't need to worry about if you
are passing a number or if you are
passing in string
just relax just when you pass the value
to the variable it will be determined
automatically so these are the three
basic primitive data types present in
javascript
which are number
boolean value and string
so let's move on to the next one which
is undefined we'll define a variable p
and we'll leave it as it is so this
variable p has an undefined data type it
means that any variable which is already
declared but has no value inside it it
has an undefined data type
i'll tell you a basic operator the type
of operator
will go through the operators in later
videos but just try to understand the
basic need and use it with me for now
this operator will help you know the
type of value a variable is holding see
let's use it here we have declared a
variable p
will check the type of p
so to use this operator you have to use
it with document dot right now
so we'll do document.write and we'll use
two brackets
and inside it will write
type of and whatever like if you want to
know the type of variable x let's
suppose we'll write here x
semicolon save it and you can see here
it says number this means that this
variable has a value which is a number
similarly we will check for all the
variables present here we'll check for
every variable we'll check for y will
check for flag and we'll check for p as
well let's copy this and
paste it three times and let's change
the value here
from x to y in this line
and from x to flag here
and here we'll change it to p
so we have done it we'll save it and see
here it says number first variable y it
says it's a string because you know
hello world is a string it's a sequence
of character
for
variable flag it says boolean so it's
defined as true or false and
for variable p it's written here
undefined with this we are left with
only one primitive data type the null
data type there is a difference between
a null value and an undefined value
undefined means lack of value whereas
null means the absence of any value
suppose you are using null as the value
for any variable the type of operator
will return this variable as an object
but if you are not giving any value to
this variable you are leaving it after
declaration the type of operator will
return undefined here is an example for
this c
we'll declare one more variable here
we'll declare where
num let's name this variable num and we
will give it the value as null
we'll use document.write
type of and we will check with the help
of type of operator that what type of
value the variable num is holding so
let's give here
number we are good to go press control
plus s and c
here it says it's an object
so a null value will always be shown as
an object
we'll talk about the complex types or
composite types in further videos we'll
have separate videos for each of these
types don't worry about it in any
programming language an operator is a
symbol that makes the computer
understand that it needs to do some
specific task
like if we want to perform an addition
between two numbers let's say we want to
perform addition between 4 and 5
so guys
if you see
the plus sign here this is known as the
operator and the two terms which are
four and five these two numbers these
are known as the operands
we have different operators for
different purposes like we have plus for
addition we have minus for subtraction
we have star or asterisk we can say for
multiplication and many more other
operators as well
so there are many more operators present
in almost every programming language
which is present out there like it
operators are present in java they are
present in c plus plus in c almost every
programming language out there has the
concept of operators it's essential for
you to know how and where to use any
operator despite of the language you are
working on one needs to understand which
operators are available right so in this
particular video i'll take you through
the basic types of operator present in
javascript i'll let you know the types
and we'll learn about how to use them
and of course i'll take you through the
different categories of operators
present in javascript so in javascript
there are basically eight categories
into which operators are divided
which are we have arithmetic operators
we have assignment we have string we
have conditional we have logical bitwise
comparison and type of operator
we'll discuss the first three types in
this video that is we'll discuss the
arithmetic operators we'll discuss the
assignment and the string operators
rest we'll talk about in the following
video
first up here is the arithmetic operator
hope you all are aware of the term
arithmetic
right few operators you can see on your
screen the plus operator minus asterisk
division we have modulus we have
increments we have decrement so these
are the basic arithmetic operator
we'll see each of these operator with an
example so let's move on to the
programming part first
so guys i want to mention one more thing
here i want all of you to make a
separate file for each topic we'll be
covering from now on like for operators
will create a separate file will create
a separate one for
control statements and other topics will
cover in future from today so i want you
to create a separate file because you
know in future if you want to access
these topics it will be easy for you to
access those files instead if you are
using a single file for all the topics
it will be
quite confusing so let's start with the
arithmetic operators first let's take
two variables we are in the javascript
file let's take two variables let's say
where
x equals to six
and we'll take another variable let's
say where y equals to
four
now we will perform some arithmetic
operations on these two variables we
have already seen the arithmetic
operators present like we have plus
minus we have increment decrement we
have multiplication division so we'll go
through all of these right so let's
start with it here we are done with our
basic three operators which is addition
subtraction and multiplication i have
commented the division because i have
something to tell you about the division
so let's check the output here first
let's save it and see the output is
addition 10 subtraction 2 and
multiplication 24. for addition it added
the two numbers it's 6 plus 4 similarly
for subtraction and multiplication it is
6 minus 4 and it's 6 multiplied by 4.
for division i have left division
because i hope you guys know the
difference between division and the
modulus operator let's try to use the
modulus operator along with the division
so what we'll do we'll commend these
three and let's remove it from here and
what we'll do we'll
paste this here and we'll use the
modulus here so
now let's check the output what it says
for division and modulus
see
we have divided 6 by 4
division it says it's 1.5
6 divided by 4 that is 1.5 it will show
the quotient here for modulus it's
saying 2
because in modulus it gives you the
remainder and in
division it gives you the quotient as
the answer so keep this thing in mind
guys keep this in mind always take a
note of it so we are done with division
and modulus next up we have the
increment and the decrement operators
let me show them to you real quick
so what we'll do we'll declare another
variable let's say where z equals to 5
and
we'll use the increment operator here
we'll use again document.write
and here we'll let's say we write
increment how to use increment operator
for increment operator you have to use
plus
plus whatever variable you have used so
we'll use plus plus z
and similarly we'll copy this
paste it here and here we'll use
minus minus for decrement
and change here as well
so let's see what happens
let me give
some space in between them so that you
won't get confused
let's save it and check the output here
increment is it says 6 and decrement it
is 5.
so you can see here the functioning of
decrement and increment operator the
increment operator will increase the
value of z by 1 and the decrement
operator will do the opposite of this it
will decrease the value by 1. so we are
done with the arithmetic operators next
up we have the assignment operators
assignment operators are used to assign
values to different javascript variables
let's see the types first and then we'll
see how to use them so we have these
assignment operators here here we have
equals to plus equals to minus equals to
and we have
multiplied equals to we have divide
equals to modulus equals two and a few
more
so let's see each of them with example
maybe not each of them but we'll try to
cover almost every
single operator out there which is
present in your screen so let's move on
and see let's move on to the programming
part so here we are guys let's declare a
few variables let's say we are declaring
a variable a
and we are giving it the value as
10 suppose
and we'll declare another one let's say
where b and give it the value
5.
so for assignment operators what
assignment operator
mean
we have used here the equal to sign
right we have used a equals to 10. this
means whatever value present on the
right side of the operator like here it
is 10 it will be assigned to the
variable a
i hope you guys are getting this keep
this in mind
so we have the value 10 and we are
assigning this value to the variable a
it says let's try to check the output of
a let's try to print a on the screen
okay
document
see here you can see that the value of a
it says 10
and similarly the value of b is 5. so
let's do one more thing we'll assign the
value of a to b how to do this let's
change the value here only let's suppose
we are using the value of where a s13
okay and the value of where we will be
providing as let's say a
so
now let's try to print the value of b
here will change
will print the value of b only
let's save it and see the output see it
says the value of b is 13
because we have assigned b the value
present at variable a which is 13 that's
why it is showing the value of b as 13.
this is what assignment operator is
let's try other assignment operators as
well
let's take another variable
so let's say where
even
equals to let's say 51
so the next operator we will be using is
let's update the value of a1 first so
how to do this let's say a1 equals to
no it's a 1 plus equals to 9
and
we'll print the value
let's check the output now
see it says the value of a1 is 60 here
we have given that a1 plus equals to 9.
see a 1 plus equals to 9 is the same as
if you don't want to write here a 1 plus
equals to 9 you can also write it as a 1
equals to
a 1
plus 9
both of these lines are same both these
statements means the same they are
performing the same task
so a 1 equals to a 1 plus 9 is same as a
1 plus equals to 9
that's what i want you to understand
with assignment operators
similarly if you want to perform a 1
minus equals to you can do it as well
so let's say even minus is equal to 5
and we'll copy this line from here paste
it here again and save it now let's see
the output here what it says some of you
guys may get confused that here it shows
the value of then after that one more
statement this statement is also
performed and the value updated to 69
it's 51 plus 9 plus 9 and the value we
have here is 69. now what happens if we
are using the minus equals 2 operator
what it will do it will
decrease the value of a1 by 5 it means
that
a1 equals to a1 minus 5 the value of a1
is 69 and it will subtract 5 from 69 so
here it says the value of a1 is 64.
hope you guys are getting this
so we have so many operators we have so
many of them like let's try a few more
so we have multiply equals to we have
division equals to we have modulus
equals to so i'll write these and then
we'll see the output
so we are done with it let's check the
output here for a3 a4 and a5 you can see
for a3 we have used multiply equals to
for a4 we have used divide equals to and
for a5 we have used modulus equals 2.
let's check the output here
save it and see
it says the value of a3 50
it here we have taken a3 s5 it's 10 into
5 because a3 equals to a3 into 5 so it's
10 into 5 it shows the value as 50.
similarly
here it says the value of a4 is 3.75
because we have used here 4. so instead
of 4 let's try to use 3 and save it see
here you can see it divides it and gives
you the quotient and the value of a4
divided by 3 is 5.
so
similarly for a5 it shows the value of
a5 is 6
because we have used the modulus
operator here and 20 divided by 7 we
have 6 as remainder
so
i hope you guys are pretty clear with
assignment operators now next up we have
string operators the plus operator which
we used as the arithmetic operators
earlier right it also operates as a
string operator so we can use it to
concatenate two strings that mean we can
add two strings as well in javascript it
is possible with the help of string
operator similarly we have plus equals
to operator for strings as well like we
have plus equal to for assignment it has
the same functioning for string as well
let's take the example for these two
operators let's move on to the
programming part so here you can see we
have two variables where str1 and where
str2 the value of where str1 is hello
and the value of where str2 is volt so
what we'll do we will add str1 and str2
so let's check the output here save it
and see here you can see the output as
hello world
but there is no space between hello and
world keep this point in mind guys so if
you are adding two strings just like
this there will be no space between the
two string so if you want to add any
space between these two what you have to
do you have to mention it here
separately
and this this is the syntax if you want
to add space between your strings
so let's save it now and see here you
can see there is a space between hello
and world
so this is the use of plus operator in
strings so the next one we have plus
equals to let's take another string
let's take it as whereas tr3 and we'll
give it the value as
welcome
so what we'll do
we'll use the plus equal to operator
here str3 plus equals to
let's say
to
simply code
and
what we'll do we'll print the value of
str3 here
so save it now
so here you can see the value of str3 if
we remove this this line
let's see what happens now
and we'll give it a space here
save it now
see here you can see it says hello world
for the first str1 plus str2 it says
hello world for str3 it says welcome to
simply code see here the space is
already given so it will show this in
the output but between welcome and 2 if
you want to add space you have to
do the same what you have done for str1
and str2 so let's do it here as well
plus sign yes
save it now and see here you can see
it says welcome to simply code with
proper space now we will cover the rest
of the operators now we are left with
five more these are the first three
operators now we are left with
conditional operators logical operators
we have bitwise operator and we have
comparison and finally we have the type
of operator so these are the five
operators we are going to cover today
before we start with the operators let
us first discuss associativity
talking about associativity
it refers to the direction in which the
entire expression is evaluated for
example if you have any expression let's
say you have a plus b
so the direction in which this
expression will be evaluated either it
will be from left to right or from right
to left so this is known as
associativity let's understand it with
the help of an example
so here you can see i have taken three
variables i have taken variable a
and i have assigned it value as 12. i
have taken variable b
and the value assigned to b is 8 and
finally i have a variable result which
stores the value of a plus b
lastly what i am doing is i am printing
out the result variable inside the h1
tag here you can see i have used the h1
tags
and
i have used the plus operator to
concatenate the strings right i have
concatenated these two strings along
with the result along with the answer of
result
so the plus operator here is doing two
different tasks right
here you can see it is performing the
addition of two numbers right and here
you can see it is used to concatenate
two strings so now let's talk about
associativity because i guess you guys
are clear with string operator till now
we have discussed them in the previous
video right
so let's talk about associativity now so
certain operators have right to left
associativity and certain operators have
left to right associativity
so when i say right to left
associativity in this case the value
present at the right side of the
operator see if you are using any
operator for example here you we have
used the assignment operator right we
have discussed the assignment operator
earlier so here you can see the value
present at the right hand side of the
operator will be assigned to the
variable which is present at the left
hand side of the operator so
it's going this way like first the
computer will check the for the value
present at the right it's going from
right towards the left
this is what we are known as right to
left associativity and assignment
operators like equals to this have right
to left associativity
let's add here one more variable let's
say we are adding a variable variable c
and we are giving it the value as
five and what we will do we will update
result as well let me first show you the
output of this particular program see
the output will be value of result is 20
and high there high there is
concatenated with
the string value of result is and 20 is
the actual answer the 20 is the value of
result
so let's add one more variable here
let's say we are adding a variable c and
the value of c will be 5.
what we will do now we will update
result as well here you can see i have
done a plus b plus c
so
save it and here you can see the value
updated
to 25 the value of result is updated
right
so the plus operator has associativity
from left to right till now we have
talked about right to left as for
assignment operators but for plus
operators the associativity is from left
to right it means it will first perform
a plus b
and then the value of c will be added to
that of a plus b first it will perform
12 plus 8 and then finally it will add 5
to that value so it will be 20 plus 5
and that's why the output here is 25 we
know that javascript is a loosely typed
programming language right
which means that we don't have to
specify data types every time
like we are using if we are using any
data type we don't need to specify it
every time like let's do one thing let's
add a string here so what we'll do we'll
add a string let's suppose i'm adding
hello
so practically the answer would be hello
plus
25 or hello 25 it should be the answer
but let's check the output now save it
and here you can see the output is hello
one two eight five what happened here is
the associativity of the plus operator
is from left to right we know this so it
will start from the left and it will see
that okay the first thing to add is a
string so it will assume that everything
ahead of this will be a string that's
why we have the output as
hello
12 8 and 5 so 12 8 and 5 all are acting
as string here
let me clear this one for you with a
little bit of modification now what
we'll do
we'll
remove this string from here and we'll
add it somewhere else let's say we are
adding it here
so
let's add one more variable to make it
more clear let's say we are using
variable d and the value will be 10
and what we will do we will perform a
plus b before the string and then we'll
perform c plus d
right so here you can see when you save
it
it says 20 hello five one zero so when
it reached out the first variable it
finds out that the first variable is a
number so it added the first two numbers
right it added 12 and 8 the answer is 20
then it came across this string hello
and then finally it assumed that
everything ahead of this will be a
string so that's the output 20 is the
addition of a plus b and then the string
hello and finally we have the value of c
and d as string so we have the value 5
and 10 not 15 right i hope you guys get
this
so
let's move on to conditional operators
the conditional operators assign a value
to a variable based on a certain
condition like it contains a condition
and you know for every condition like
there exists only two possibilities
either it can be true or it can be false
there is nothing else you can do with a
conditional operator so it works the
same as if else statements which we'll
cover in further videos the only
difference between if else and
conditional operators that it takes less
time or we can say its usage is pretty
easy
so here is the syntax for conditional
operators
so it seems pretty straight forward
right so here you can see we have a
variable name we have a condition
depending upon the condition we have two
values
here is the example as well
c
you can see we have a variable voter
next up we have a condition if h is less
than 18 so it will check for the
condition that if the value of age is
actually less than 18 let's suppose the
value of age is 15
so it will check if 15 is less than 18
it's true then it will print 2m or if
the value of h is greater than 18 then
it will print false or you can say it
will print old enough here
so let's move on to the programming part
so here you can see i have taken a
variable x and the value assigned to x
is 30. what we'll do in variable y i
have given it a condition so it will
check for x which is 30 if 30 is greater
than or equals to 50.
so if it's true if 30 is actually
greater than 50 then it will print true
else it will print false so we'll check
the output once let's save it and see
here you can see the output as false so
if we update the value of axial let's
suppose we are updating the value of x
let's suppose it's
60 save it now and see the output has
changed to true because 60 is greater
than 50 right
also if you want to write a message here
only you can do it write it here as
so we'll copy it from here we'll copy
document.write
and we'll paste it here
just remove this document.right and we
what we'll do we'll
use this bracket
here
and if any message you want to write
like you want to write
value of
so
and now what we'll do we'll
save it
see it says value of true so
or you can write any other message here
as well you can write value of x is
greater than or you can write whatever
so if you want to update it like value
is
and here we will update true
with
greater
and here we will use
smaller
save it now see here it says value is
greater value of x is greater than y
so that's all for conditional operators
also one more thing and conditional
operators has three different parts
right
and that's why it is also known as
ternary operator three different parts
as in it has a
condition like here it is it's it has a
condition and it has two values right it
has true or false so that's why it is
also known as ternary operator
next up we have the logical operators
so logical operators are used to
determine the logic between two
variables
or values we can say we use logical
operators to check whether multiple
conditions are true or false
here on your screen you can see the
three different types of logical
operators present in javascript along
with the syntax and example
so the end or not are the three
operators present in javascript
the end operator here you can see
it it is holding two values right it
it has x less than 10 and y greater than
one
so the end operator will return true
only if both the conditions are true
like x has to be less than 10 and y has
to be
greater than 1 so here you can see we
have taken x equals to 7 and y equals to
4 so both the conditions are satisfying
here so that's why
the output of the and operator will be
true
for our operator the case is a bit
different so if any one of these two
conditions like we have two conditions
if any one of these two is true then the
output will be true and if both are
false then only the output will be false
the north operator on the other hand
will check if x is equals to y if the
value x is holding is equals to that of
y
if the value is not equal then it will
return true
i hope you are getting this that's a
little bit
confusing but if the value x and y
holding
if they are not equal then it will
return true if they are equal then it
will return false
right
we'll understand the programming concept
of logical operators in further videos
when we learn about control statements
we primarily use logical operators with
the if statement through which we'll
come across in the following video in
the next video we will go through the
control statements so we'll understand
the programming part of logical operator
there only
next up we have the comparison operators
so comparison operators are similar to
logical operators in some way
they are also used to check for true and
false as the name suggests we use
comparison operator to compare two
values or we can say to compare two
variables using different operators
so here you can see on your screen
these are the different types of
comparison operators present in
javascript we have equals 2 we have not
equals 2 we have equal value and data
type we have greater than less than and
we have a few more so
i hope you guys must remember from the
previous video that a single equals 2
operator is an assignment operator so if
we are using a single equals 2 then it
will be considered as an assignment
operator for comparison we have to use
double equal to keep this thing in mind
whenever you are using any operator in
javascript or especially the equals 2
operator so if you want to compare two
values you have to use double equals to
because single equals two is used to
assign values this is an assignment
operator so let's move on to the
programming part now
so guys here you can see i have taken a
variable x and the value assigned to x
is 10.
this code seems a little bit longer to
you but that's a simple piece of code
like i have used almost every comparison
operator we came across in the previous
slide i have used each one of them and i
have used the document.write after every
comparison operator to put some spaces
in between so that you guys don't
confuse between them
so let's check the output now see as you
can see i have used the double equals to
the triple equals to i have used x not
equals to it so let's check the output
save it and see here it says false false
true true true false true false so for x
equals to equals to it it compared the
value 10 with 8
and 10 and 8 are not equals to so the
output will be false as similar for 10
and we have used the triple equals 2
operator which means equal value and
data type so
both 10 and 8 have equal data type they
both have the same data type that is
number but the values are different so
it will print false
for x not equals to it it says 10 is not
equals to it yeah 10 is not equals to it
actually so it will print true similarly
for x
naught equals to equals to it it will
check that
both the values are not equal but the
data types are equal right so it will
print true for this as well
for x greater than 8 yeah 10 is greater
than 8 so it will print true
similarly for it will check for x
smaller than 8 and it will check for x
greater than equals to it and also for x
less than equals to it
so
by now you have understood how
comparison operators work so comparison
operators are the easiest to use in
programming
and that's all for comparison operators
let's move on to the next one we have
the next type of operator we have is the
type of operator you guys have an idea
about the type of operators right as we
have discussed it earlier in case you
haven't watched the previous videos let
me give you a brief introduction about
this type of operator
so the type of operator is used to
provide you with the type of whatever
value you put to the right of it like
if you are using any data type and you
want to know about the data type of a
particular variable let's say
so you can use the type of operator it
will tell you the actual data type of
any variable so
in javascript as we have discussed
earlier in the video where we have
particularly discussed about the data
types so there are five different types
of primitive data types right we have
the numbers we have strings we have
boolean we have null and undefined
so let's try to use type of operator
so here you can see i have used four
different variables which are i've used
variable x
variable y
and variable flag and variable p so the
values are different the x is holding 17
y is holding hey there and flag has the
value as false and i have defined p but
i have not assigned it any value till
now so what i'll do i have used the type
of operator to find out the type of
every variable like here i have used it
for x for y for flag and for p
let's
check the output now
save it and see it says number string
boolean and undefined
see here we have given x the value as 17
so 17 is a number then it says it is a
number
for haiti it says it is a string for
false it says it is a boolean value like
in boolean value we have only two values
like false and true
so for variable p it says undefined
you know there is a difference between
undefined and null data types undefined
means lack of value whereas null means
this absence of value that there is no
value at all
so suppose you are using null as the
value for any variable right the type of
operator will return
object
but if you are not giving any value to
any variable like you are using the
variable as it is like here we have not
given it any value so if you are doing
this the type of operator will return
undefined so let's take an example of
null as well
let's declare another variable let's say
where abc
and we'll give it the value as
null
so and finally what we'll do we'll
use type of operator
save it and see here it says the type of
variable abc is an object
so remember this thing guys
and now we are done with almost seven
operators we had and we are left with
one operator only
so let's move on to our last operator
which is the bitwise operator this
operator doesn't have that much of
practical usage in the real world they
are not definitely useless but this is
something like we are not going to use
on a daily basis so in computers
if you know the numbers are stored in
binary format
bitwise operators work on 32 bit numbers
and we have decimal numbers like we
understand decimal numbers computer
works on binary numbers right so when
bitwise operators are used any operand
present in the operation
is first converted to a binary number
and then converted back to a javascript
number
so
here you can see on your screen
we have four different
bitwise operators we have the and
operator we have or we have not and we
have
zor or we can say exclusive or
the result and the answers are also here
it's pretty simple see
we have used the and operator before as
well while we were in logical operators
but the syntax was different and
here you can see we have a single
ampersand sign to use bitwise and
operator
so here you can see
how the decimal number first changes to
a binary number suppose we have x as 5
here you can see access first changed to
a binary number this is the binary
equivalent of 5 and one is also changed
to a binary number and finally the
result whatever result we get it is
changed to a decimal number so that's
how bitwise operators work
let's take an example of bitwise
operators
so here you can see i have taken two
variables i have taken variable x and
the value of variable x is 5 and another
variable is y and the value of y is 1
and then i have used
all the four bitwise operators like i
have used x and y i have used x or y
i have used not x and i have used the
xor operator between x and y so let's
check the output now
here you can see
if we talk about the output
see here it says 1 5 minus 6 and 4 so
for x and y see the value of x is 0 1 0
1 and for end operators
it will return 1 if both the values are
1 if any one of the two values are 0
then it will return 0 so what it will
return here it will return 0 for 0 0 for
1 0 it will also return 0 similarly for
0 0 it will also return 0 and for 1
month it will return 1 which is the
binary equivalent of one so the answer
here is one
for x or y it will return one if any one
of the two values are one
see if both are zero it will return zero
if any one of the two values is one it
will return one
it will return zero again and finally it
has two ones so it will return one
and zero one zero one is the binary
equivalent of five that's why the output
here is five
for not operator it works a little bit
different it gives you the output which
is same as minus x minus 1 so minus x
minus 1 will be
see minus x minus 1 will be minus 5
minus 1 which is minus 6 so this is a
bit different here the not operator here
is a bit different
for
xor operator or we can say exclusive or
it will return four
why it will return four it will return
one
when
any one of the two values is one if both
are one then also it will return false
it will return one only in one condition
if any one of the two values is one then
only it will return one that's why the
output here
the output here will be zero one zero
zero that's why it's written as four
which is the binary equivalent of zero
one zero zero the term control statement
is pretty self-explanatory and
straightforward right we came across
javascript statements in previous videos
javascript statements are the
instructions that tells the browser to
perform specific actions
control statements are also instructions
and they govern the flow of control in a
program
so let's take a look at control
statements with the help of an example
let's suppose we have a piece of code
that has n number of statements here
let's say we have this code and so the
conventional workflow will be it will
first execute the first statement then
second then third and so on till
statement n right
so this is the basic flow right from
statement one till statement n and it
will execute each statement in between
however in real world the scenario is
different
like we don't write the code in same
menu every time
for example let's suppose
you are in line 5
and you want to print this line 10 times
so what should you do you can write this
line 10 times or
you can copy paste it right okay let's
forget about 10 times let's suppose you
have to use this code or we can say
let's suppose you have to print this
statement 100 times doing this like copy
pasting it for 100 times or writing this
statement 400 times that's useless and
unnecessary right so that's where
control statements comes into picture
we'll discuss them in a while let's
assume another situation
this time you want to make a choice
based on certain conditions you can use
conditional operators but then it has
limitations right to tackle this problem
we have control statements in javascript
so these are the very basic reasons why
we need control statements for
performing a certain activity
like if we want to perform a certain
activity n number of times or if you
want to make a certain decision making
kind of scenarios in your program that's
where we need control statements in
javascript
in javascript we have two different
types of control statements depending
upon what action we are performing so we
have the conditional control statements
and we have the iterative or we can say
looping control statements
talking about conditional statements as
the name suggests
we use conditional statements when we
have to make decisions based on
conditions when we have two choices or
when we can say when we have two
different conditions and we want to make
choices accordingly so that's where we
use conditional statements we have two
different types of conditional
statements the if else statements and
the switch case
talking about the iterative statements
as the name suggests if you want to
perform any action more than once or
maybe n number of times
instead of writing them again and again
we use loops so loops are basically
statements
we use loops to perform any activity n
number of times with specific conditions
so in javascript we have four different
type of loops we have for loop while
loop do while loop and foreign loop
so the for loop while loop and do while
loop you might have heard about them
earlier because they are also present in
other programming languages
but this foreign loop this is a new type
of loop present in javascript we use
foreign loop with objects we'll go
through objects in
upcoming videos and of course we'll be
looking at each of these control
statements in detail will have a
particular video for each of these topic
now let me introduce to you the break
and the continue statement
they are not the types of control
statements but they do assist in other
control statements
the break is used to exit a switch
statement or loop like when used in a
loop
it breaks the loop and continues
executing the code after it
and
on the other hand the continue statement
breaks a single iteration when used in a
loop when we use continuous statement in
a loop it breaks a single iteration and
it breaks the iteration only if the
specified condition occurs and then it
will continue with the next iteration in
the loop
so the if else conditional statement is
used whenever we work with condition
it can be either a single condition or
maybe more than one condition or
multiple conditions we can work with
so let's try to write a basic
program with a single condition
so then we'll
move on to multiple conditions using the
else if statement so we'll create a new
file today so i hope you guys know the
importance of creating a separate file
for every topic you know it will be easy
for you to work or to find out that
separate file later if you want to
revise that topic
so here is the program where we have
taken a variable x and the value of x is
10 so what we are doing in this program
is we are checking if the value the
variable x is holding that is the value
and if the value is less than
10 or if the value is
greater than 10 so we have only two
conditions either the value can be less
than 10 or the value can be greater than
10 or equals to 10 as
so here in this program what we'll do
will
first we'll update this value as 8 so
the variable x is holding the value 8
so to check the output let's save it and
here you can see it says the value of x
is less than 10 of course the value 8 is
always less than 10 right so
for it that's fine it will say the value
is less than 10 and similarly if we do
the same for let's say 11 save it now
and see it says the value of x is
greater than 10
so that's quite simple right but what if
we are giving the value as 10
we know 10 is equals to 10 so save it
now and see here you can see
it says the value of x is greater than
this is happening because what we did we
as we told the interpreter to check the
value if the value of x is less than 10.
we didn't mention that if what to do if
the value is equals to 10 so it will
check for only x is less than 10 not for
equals to 10 or greater than 10 so here
what it is doing it is checking if the
value is less than 10 so that it says
okay let's print this statement if the
value is less than 10 or
if the value is not less than 10 or if
the value is equals to or greater than
10 it will print the value of x is
greater than 10.
to avoid this type of misunderstanding
we use an elsif statement so the concept
of elsif statement is the same as if
statement what we are doing we are using
multiple conditions right we are giving
it more than one condition so how to use
elsif it's quite easy
and the syntax is also similar to
the if statement the only difference is
that it contains an else before if so
it's an elsif so what we are doing is
we are giving it a condition that else
if x equals to 10. so now what it will
do it will check for two conditions that
if the value x is holding is less than
10 or equals to 10
and what we'll do will update it is
let's check the output now
save and see here it says the value of x
is equals to 10 right so i hope you guys
are getting this
the execution flow for this program will
be like it will check for the first
condition if x is less than 10 if yes it
will print the value of x is less than
10. if no it will move on the to the
following condition like under the else
if statement it finds a condition that
if x is equals to 10 it will check for
it if yes if x is equals to 10 then it
will print the value of x is equals to
or if not then otherwise it will move to
else statement and print the value of x
is greater than 10. we don't need to
specify any particular condition for
this you know because we have already
specified the two conditions that
if x is less than 10 or if x is equals
to 10 now we'll take a look at some
basic programs other than this one we'll
take a look at a few more basic programs
so here is the another program
what we are doing here is we are taking
a variable x and the value of x is 5
so what we are doing is we are checking
if the number is an even number or an
odd number the thing you have to keep in
mind is the logic to find whether a
number is even or an odd number so to
check
whether a number is even you what we do
will divide that number with 2 right but
basically we want is we want
the remainder as 0 when we use the
modulus operator so what we'll do here
we have written x mod 2 equals to equals
to 0. so if the remainder is 0
then the number will be an even number
because it is divisible by 2 else it
will be an odd number so that's quite
simple right let's save it and check the
output for 5 it says odd number yeah 5
is of course an odd number right so
that's for even an ordinal
so here we are with another program
here it says we have a variable y and
the value of y is
let's say
and
what we are doing here is we are
checking if a number is positive or
negative or zero
so we have three different conditions
either number can be positive or it can
be a negative number any number greater
than zero is a positive number right and
any number less than 0 is a negative
number and the third one is
a number 0 it's neither positive nor
negative
so let's check for the number 8 save it
and see here you can see it is a
positive number let's see for
minus 2 save it now it says a negative
number for 0 it will say 0
so these two programs are quite simple
guys right the conditions are pretty
simple we use
modulus operator we used greater than or
less than sign and
that's quite easy to use right so let's
move on to the next program which is a
bit tricky than these two
so what we'll do in our next program is
we'll check if a number is positive or
negative
and at the same time we'll check for
even and odd also
if we are giving any number as input
like let's suppose we are using 5 we'll
check if the number is positive or
negative and odd or even so we'll do
this simultaneously let's move on to
this program so there are two ways to
check whether the number is
positive or negative and
order even so the two methods we will
discuss them one by one the first one
here is
to use nested if and another one is when
we use logical operators along with the
if else if statement
so this one here you can see right in
front of your screen is
the
nested if method so here you can see we
have used the if statement we have given
one more condition inside another if
statement so first it will check whether
a number is positive or not for x
greater than 0 it will check if the
number x is greater than 0 then if yes
if it will find it that yes this number
is greater than 0 then it will move on
to the
nested if and it will check for odd or
even
for odd number and even number it will
check if it finds that the number is
even it will print that the number
is positive and even
if the number is not even it will print
the number is positive and odd so
here you can see the difference what the
interpreter is doing is it will check
for the number as positive and if the
number is positive then it will move on
to the nested if and check for the even
or odd so if it finds that the number is
even it will print positive and even
otherwise it will print positive and odd
then it will move on to the next
condition which is for negative number
if x is less than 0 then it will again
move to the nested if and it will check
for even and odd
so if it finds that the number is even
it will print negative and even
otherwise it will print negative and odd
and the last condition is for the number
let's
try to find out the output of this and
what we'll do we'll update the value of
x as
8.
so save it now here it says then
positive and even so 8 is a positive
number and even as well
let's update the value of x as minus
save it now it says negative and odd
number minus 5 is a negative odd number
right so that's how it will check for
positive
or negative and odd or even so we are
doing both the things simultaneously in
a program
we have an alternate method as well here
you can see on your screen we have
written a program and here we have taken
a variable x the functioning of both the
programs is same
both of these program will check for
positive or negative and
order even
so here you can see i have taken a
variable x let's say the value of x is
it will check for
x greater than 0 and x
mod 2 is equals to equals to 0. so we
have 4 different conditions right a
number is
greater than zero that means a number is
positive and even a number is positive
end odd a number is negative and even a
number is negative and odd and the final
one is a number is zero
okay we have five conditions and we have
to specify these four conditions
so here we you can see we are using the
logical and operator this means it will
print this statement let's suppose for
this statement it will print this only
if both the conditions are true
right if the number if the value x is
holding is both greater than 0 and an
even number
so if you try to
find out the output now save it and see
here it says number is positive and odd
so the number 7 is greater than 0
but the number 7 is not an even number
that's why this line is not there on the
browser it will print this line because
the number is
positive and odd
right
the switch case is another conditional
control statement and just like the if
else control statement there is a
difference between the usage of if else
and switch case statement
now both if cells and switch case works
with conditions and we have to choose
when to use switch case
over if else
switch case is generally preferred over
the if else when there is n number of
test cases present or we can say when we
are working with a lot of conditions
let's say we are working on a program
and you ask the user
for an input between 50 and 100 a
numeric input basically
and in the output we have to print the
textual form of that number suppose if
the user enters 75 right the output will
be like this
so what we are doing we we are taking a
number from the user as an input and we
are printing the textual form of that
number right
so we can use the if else
or we can say elsif control statement
but the program will be so lengthy and
not so clean
also switch case is much more efficient
than if else when it comes to execution
time like if we have n number of
conditions then using switch case is a
better option we'll get to know why in a
bit
so let's move on to the programming part
and today
we'll write a program where we have to
find the month in a year by accepting
its number so we have 12 months in a
year for example if we enter 4 then the
output will be april and if we enter 8
then the output will be august because
august is the 8th month of the year
right so i hope you guys are clear with
the question of course we can do this
program with the help of if else
statement but we discussed earlier that
using if else in such cases is not
efficient right we can use switch case
in this scenario
so let's create a variable first let's
say we are creating a variable where
month and
you can give any value to this variable
from 1 to 12 you can provide it with any
initial value
so let's create a variable first let's
say we are creating a variable where
month
and
the value we are providing it one as the
hardcore initial value for simplicity
again we are not taking the input from
the user or from the browser to do so we
have to first go through the dom
manipulations and we'll go through it in
later videos so let's start with the
switch case now
the syntax for switch case is quite
simple just write down
switch and
pass the variable month
so we have to check in this round
bracket for the variable month because
you know any value you are providing to
month the switch will check the program
accordingly so for now we have taken the
value as 1 for month we can take any
value like we can take 3 we can take 11
12 or any value other than 1 to 12 as
well so whatever value you are providing
to the variable you can provide the
variable to the switch statement right
so
next up we have an open and curly braces
for the body of the switch case we have
to test for 12 different conditions
inside this
starting from 1 to 12 right so the
syntax goes like this you have to write
case
and then the value month variable might
hold like 1 2 3 and so on followed by a
colon right so we have to write the
value 1 and
a colon not a semicolon but a colon keep
this thing in mind guys
and below that we are going to write
what we want when the value is one like
what the output we want when the value
is one so we have to write document
dot write
and
whatever you want as the output like for
one the first month is january so we are
writing here
january
and a semicolon
so if the value of the month is one you
will get the output as january save it
and here you can see the output is
january
let me increase the font size for this
as well
so here you can see the output is
january
right next we'll use a break statement
if you guys remember we discussed the
break statement in the control
statements video right the break
statement is not actually a type of
control statement but it assists other
control statements or we can say it
helps us manage the control statements
right what this statement does is
once we are done with our output we get
our output right once we are done with
case 1 we get our output as january this
break statement helps us to come out of
the switch case so to understand this
much better let's write here one more
case so let's say we are writing here
one more case as
case 2
and the output will be
document
dot write
the second month is february right
and
february you can write so
will include one break here like will
come in the first case and include a
break statement so here's how you can
write a break statement how you can
include a break statement in your code
so let's check the output now so for now
it says january
so if we don't include this break
statement here when the interpreter will
execute this code
and it will see that the case is one
right so it will print january
but
it will print other statements as well
so for example if we remove this break
statement and save it now see you can
see here the output as january and
february january and february both are
getting printed on the output so we need
a break statement to break it here
see the value is 1 and if we include
break statement here
the moment the interpreter finds the
answer the correct answer as january it
will come out of the switch case
so i hope you guys are getting this
similarly we'll write all the cases for
all the months let me show you all the
cases
so here you can see on your screen
that we have 12 different cases from 1
to 12. one for each month depending on
the value the variable month is holding
right
the output will be june if the value is
6 and if we say 10 the output will be
october and so on and so forth
now the question here is what if we try
to write a random value for the variable
month
by random value we mean that
if we try to write any value other than
these 12 values from 1 to 12 if if we
leave these values then if we try to
write another value like if we write
here 13
so what will be the output now let's
save it and see
there is no output and there might be no
error for this as well so if you try to
check for an error go to inspect and
check out
see there's no error right so in that
case we have one more case like we have
default case
so let me show you how to include
default in your program what you have to
do is write here
default
with a colon and write
document
dot right and let's suppose we are
writing here
wrong input
what is happening is let's try to run
this program first
press ctrl s and now you can see it says
raw input for value 13.
so what is happening is the switch case
will first check these 12 cases and any
value other than 1 to 12 will get the
output as wrong input it works the same
as the else statement right
in else statement we don't need to
specify any particular condition any
condition other than the if condition or
else if condition will fall inside the
else statement it's not necessary to add
default in your program it's just if you
want to give the user a prompt that he
has entered a wrong value
so
you must include this default case in
your program every time by using switch
here because it's quite useful you know
okay so this is the complete program to
find out
the month by accepting its number
if you try
and save it now it will say june if you
try 10 save it it will say october if we
try 12 save it it will say december so i
hope this is clear to you guys
next up let's discuss about switch case
in detail because
the switch case in javascript works
differently from other languages like
switch case is also present in c plus
and java but in javascript it is a bit
different so in javascript
switch case can accept numbers it can
accept strings and boolean values as
well now let's have a look at how the
switch case works with string values
so here is an example of string values
you can see the value variable month is
holding is june right and you can see
use this string in case as well so here
you have to give the case as a string
value right because we are using switch
case statement with
strings
so the first case here is when the value
will be june the output should be sixth
month and when the value is july the
output will be seventh month so let's
check it out if this is working or not
let's save this program and see for june
it says sixth month and similarly we can
check it for july as well let's check
for july
save it and see it says seventh month
you can include the default case as well
if you want to
it will be similar like there is no
difference for default case let me show
you how
we'll write here wrong input
and save it and now let's try to change
the value here let's say we are using
may
save it and see it says wrong input but
if we use a numerical value here let's
try to use two save it now it says wrong
input for 2 as well
it will give you the output when the
value is either june or july
so any other value you try to use here
it will give the output as wrong input
in the same way it works for boolean
values as well let me show you how it
works for boolean values
so what you have to do instead of 2 you
have to give here a boolean value let's
suppose you are writing here true
and for true you have to change the case
as well for true
you have to change the output as
let's say for true it the output will be
one
okay and similarly for false
the output should be
zero
and the output should be wrong input for
any other case right so save it now
and see here for true it says one the
output you can see here is one
and if you try to do the same for false
like let's write here false
and now try to check the output see here
it says
zero
you can see the output is correct right
the typical definition of function
states that to work in a proper or in a
particular way
similarly functions in javascript are
block of code that is used to perform a
specific task
in this particular video we will go
through the syntax and usage of
functions
so a function has a particular name and
we can reuse that block of code again
and again in our entire program
for example
let's suppose that we have to add two
numbers in a program that's a basic
program right sum of two numbers so
let's write the code first so we are
going to take a variable x and the value
of x will be 10
then again we are going to take a
variable y and the value of y will be 5.
lastly we are going to take a variable
total and the value of total will be
x plus y
so the last thing
we are going to do is we are going to
print this on a browser
so here we are we are done with our
program we are done with adding two
numbers so lets save it and check the
output see the output here says 15
so what is happening is
the value of x plus y which is 10 plus 5
is stored in the variable total and we
are displaying total on a browser
so that's a very basic program right
now consider a scenario where we have to
do this addition for n number of times
at different intervals so we have to
perform the same task of addition at
different intervals so in that case what
we can do is we can copy paste this same
code repeatedly but the length of the
program will increase because of that
right and it doesn't make any sense to
copy paste the same code again and again
so this is where functions come into
play with the help of functions we can
create a separate function to do this
particular task and we can call that
function again and again i'll take you
through it so basically a function has
three parts we'll go through each of
them a function has function declaration
then it has function definition and then
finally it has function calling
so we'll perform this same program of
adding two numbers we'll add two numbers
but this time we'll use the concept of
functions
so we'll use this whole code
we are going to use it inside the
function so let's move on and see how
the function looks like how the syntax
of function looks like
so we use the keyword function
and then we have the function name
so let's suppose here we are naming the
function as sum
then we have the opening and closing
round brackets which denotes that this
is a function
this is the way to write a function
next up we have a pair of curly braces
for the body of the function so this is
the basic syntax of how a function looks
like
the naming convention for functions is
the same as we had for variables in
javascript if you guys remember we have
already discussed this naming convention
of variables
so this is the basic structure of a
function
so now we'll cut this whole code
and we'll
paste it here inside the function
right so we are done with it we are done
with our functions first part first we
declared a function with name sum then
we are done with the definition of
function
now what if we try to run this program
let's save this program and see it is
not printing anything on screen but if
you try to check out for any errors it
won't show any errors see there is no
error in this program this is happening
because we haven't called the function
yet right so to call the function we
have to write a single word just write
sum
with
opening and closing
round brackets and save it now now you
can see the output here is 15 so this is
known as function calling the program
already knows that there is a function
by the name sum
it will go and check for the same if the
function is there or not if the program
finds it it will execute the function
next up a function can also have
parameters what do i mean by parameters
is
we don't have to declare these variables
variable x and variable y here
instead of declaring them here we can
pass these values to the function let's
say we are passing x and y here or we
can pass a and b any variable you want
to pass
you can pass it here
now we can remove this
variable x and variable y
we have to write here where because we
still need the variable total and next
up we have to pass the value for these
variables when we call the function so
we have to pass the values here let's
say we are passing the values as
and
three
so
let's try to run this program now and
see if it works let's save it and see
you can see here the output is seven
we can also pass strings over here so
instead of four if we try to pass any
string let's say we are passing
welcome to
and instead of three
will pass
simply code right now let's save this
program and see the output it says
welcome to simply code we don't have to
worry about the data type we'll use here
because javascript is a loosely typed
language right so the function will
automatically adapt to the data type
according to the value we will pass
during the function call
here in this code
variable x holds the value welcome to
and the variable y is having simply code
allocated to them dynamically so this is
what is known as
parameter passing in functions
let's move on and discuss the return
types in functions
so a function can also return a value
right now
we can see that a function is doing the
printing task what if we remove this
document.right from here and we'll paste
it somewhere else on the program outside
the function so we'll paste it here
right now the function will perform
addition only it won't print anything it
will just perform the addition let's
save this and see there is nothing so if
we try to check for error it says total
is not defined because total is defined
inside the function this is because of
the concept of local and global variable
we will discuss this concept in upcoming
video
so here you can see it says total is not
defined
right
so now what we have to do is we have to
write here
return
total
so now the function will return the
value of total outside
what this return statement does is
whenever we call the function as you can
see here we are calling the function
from outside and we are passing the
parameters as welcome to and simply code
right
so these parameters will go as x and y
and we are getting the concatenation of
welcome to simply code
right so when this return statement
comes into function
the value of this total variable will be
given out of the function
so there has to be a particular variable
to hold the value returned by the
function
will
use a variable here let's say we are
using the variable output
and in the rhs we are calling the
function so we have an equals to between
the lhs and rhs that's because when we
are calling the function it will return
a value and the assignment is done from
right to left in the case of an
assignment operator if you guys remember
we came across this
that whenever we are using an assignment
operator the assignment will be done
from right towards the left
so whatever value the function will
return upon calling will be assigned to
the variable output
in this program we are passing welcome
to and simply code right so let's change
these two values now we'll change them
to a numerical value let's say we are
using here
and instead of simply code we'll use a
15 and we are going to print here output
on the browser because the variable
output is holding the value returned by
the function right so let's save it now
and see the output is 50.
okay guys so this was the syntax
demonstration of functions in javascript
with a quick small program we already
know that javascript is a loosely typed
scripting language right that means we
don't need to specify the data types
every time
so a variable is basically a container
that can store data values those values
can be changed
whenever needed in this particular video
we are going to discuss the scope of
variables in javascript so what does
this scope mean in variables so scope
refers to the life of a variable in a
program
there are basically two types of
variables present in javascript local
variables and global variables
depending upon where we are creating a
variable variable may have two different
types of scope so let's have a look at
these two different types of variables
with the help of examples
let's say we are creating a variable
here let's say we are creating a
variable
where a and the value of a will be 5. so
we have created a variable here and
let's print the value of this variable
in the browser so what we'll do we'll
print this value in the
browser
so let's print the value of this
variable on the browser so here we have
printed the value of variable a so here
you can see the value is 5.
so we can print the value of this
variable anytime and anywhere in our
program right so if we try to copy this
line from here and we'll paste it
somewhere else in a program let's say we
are pasting it here so if we try to save
it now see here you can see that we have
two values of a because we have printed
a twice here right once we have used
this a here then we have used this a
here so here you can see we have two
values of a five and five so this
variable a is a global variable which
means its life is available throughout
the entire program or the entire script
we can see
and when we declare a variable inside a
function that variable is known as a
local variable for that function so
let's try to do it as well we already
know what functions are as we saw in the
previous video right so what we'll do
we'll make a function here let's say we
are creating a function
function
my function
opening and closing round bracket and
the body of the function right so let's
declare a variable here let's say we are
using a variable where x and the value
of x will be 10 right let's try to print
this value
so we have created a function here now
we are left with the function call only
so let's call the function here
but we'll do we'll call my function
right
save it and now here you can see the
output is 10 5 and 5. so if we comment
these three lines
if we remove these three lines and we'll
save it now so here you can see we have
the output as 10 only so this variable x
which is declared inside a function so
why it is a local variable because if we
try to access this variable from outside
the function it is not possible so let's
cut this line from here and let's try to
paste it here so now what we are doing
is we are trying to access this variable
from outside the function let's save it
now
let's save this program now and see the
there is no output in the browser
because a local variable can be accessed
only in that function we can't access it
from outside of the function so this is
happening because as soon as the
function is executed the variable gets
destroyed means there is no variable
present in the memory now
the same thing applies to the memory
whenever we run a javascript program the
whole browser is present in the ram
or we can say in the memory so these
local variables are created only till
the function is executing once the
function is done running the same
function wipes out of the memory
whereas the case is different for global
variables so global variables are
available throughout the script they
have a global lifetime which means that
they will exist throughout the programs
running
or we can say until the tab is open the
next exciting thing about global
variables is
that we can access global variables from
inside the function so what we'll do
let's
cut this line from here
and we'll paste it here
so now what we'll do we'll declare a
variable here let's say we are declaring
a variable where y and the value of y
will be
15.
so
copy this line
paste it again now what we will do we
will try to access y from inside the
function
so let's save the program and see the
output here is 10 and 15 10 is the value
of x and x is a local variable for
function my function because we have
declared x inside the function whereas
variable y is a global variable we have
declared it outside the function and we
tried to access it from inside of the
function right so we tried to access y
here and we can see the value of y is 15
which is printed on the browser this is
what global variables are one more
exciting thing i want to mention at the
end of this video is if we declare any
variable in javascript without using the
where keyword so if we try to declare a
variable here let's say we are declaring
var1 okay we have not used any var
keyword so what we are doing is we are
declaring a variable and the value of
where one is 15 so we don't need the
where keyword separately when we are
declaring a variable however some of the
newer versions of web browser have some
sort of issue if we try to declare a
variable inside this function without
using the var keyword
so let's try to access this variable
let's try to access let's declare it
inside the function
okay what we'll do is we'll
declare this variable inside the
function
and we'll comment this line and what
we'll do is we'll try to access it from
outside the function right
what we'll do is
we'll write here
var1
save this
and see if
you don't understand it let me change
the value of where one let's change this
value to 20 save it now and see the
output here is 10 and 20. so where one
is a variable which is declared without
using the wire keyword right so we can
access this variable from outside the
function as well any variable which is
declared without using where keyword is
a global variable keep this thing in
mind guys
we came across the different types of
data types present in javascript
in the previous video where we came
across the types of primitive data types
in javascript we discussed number string
and we had boolean null and undefined
right so these are the five types of
primitive data types present in
javascript
we know that strings in any programming
language are used to store and
manipulate textual value a string
contains a sequence of characters
written inside double quotes
so let's declare a basic string here
let's say we have a variable
and we have a variable as where x and
the value of x will be a basic string
let's say we have hi there as the value
okay
next thing we'll print this on a browser
document.write and we'll print x on a
browser
so this here is a string that holds a
textual value right suppose we try to
find the type of the variable x so
i hope you guys are aware of that if
you're not then please go through the
previous video on data types in
javascript let's print this value on
browser first
so here you can see it says hi there so
this is a string and let's try to
determine the type of variable x and
we'll see if it returns a string or
something else we'll do it with the help
of type of operator right i hope you
guys remember that so let's try to use
type of operator here
and
here we'll use
type of
x
so let's
save it
and see
here you can see we have a string as the
type of variable x so strings are
helpful
for holding data that can be represented
in textual form so let's move on to a
first topic for today and
that is escape sequence in javascript so
if you guys ever noticed that in the
previous few videos we use a lot of html
tags in javascript right for example we
use the heading tag so often
like when we are using the
document.write
to print anything on the browser we use
heading tag quite a lot right so the
thing to notice here is that these tags
behaves as html tags right we use them
inside the double inverted commas just
like strings but they still act like
html tags so let's understand this with
the help of an example
what we'll do is we'll remove this code
we'll print a simple
statement in our tml tag we are going to
use
let's say we are using the break tag i
hope you all are aware of the break tag
so the next sentence will be
so here in this example we try to print
a sentence and we are using the br tag
right so let's print it on the browser
so we are using the break tag in between
the sentences we have hi there and we
have welcome to simply code
so
we use this break tag
in a string right so the output
what we were expecting was hi there and
the br should be written in
string but there's a difference in the
output right the br tag is actually
functioning as an html tag so here the
break tag works the same as it did for
html so with this we can conclude that
if we try to infuse any html tag inside
the javascript statement it will act as
that tag only
so let's move on and we'll look at some
other types of escape characters present
in javascript
so
let's say we want to print this line
okay we'll edit this one only so what we
will do is we will remove this break
type and
suppose we want to print this on screen
so we want this on our screen and we
want the welcome to be inside the double
inverted comma in output as well
so if we try to run this program now
there will be nothing
in the browser let's try to check if
it gets any error so here it says uncut
syntax error it says missing
after the argument list
so how to print this on the browser we
want to highlight the word welcome
so if we try to run this program as it
is it's not working right
to do this type of task we have the
backslash escape character
to print the double quotes inside a
string we use a single backslash with a
double inverted comma in the syntaxes we
have to use this backslash before the
double inverted comma so now if we try
to print this on browser here you can
see it says hi there and welcome is
written within double inverted commas
right so that's how you can print this
on a screen next up if we want to use a
single inverted comma we have to use a
single backslash with a single inverted
comma so just like we did here with the
double inverted comma similarly we can
do it for single inverted comma as well
what we'll do is we'll copy this
document dot right and we'll print it
here
so here what we will print is
we will print here it's all right okay
so we are using here a backslash with a
single inverted comma now we will write
s
the output will be it's all right
so
we have to use them because
we need them in a program at times right
so to avoid any confusion one must know
how to use this sequence character in
javascript let's save this and see
if we try to comment this line
let me comment this to make it more
easier for you to understand let's save
it now and see it says it's all right
you can't print it's in similar way
without using the backslash escape
character
lastly if we want to put a backslash in
our string if we want to put a backslash
we want to show it in the browser so the
syntax for that will go like
we have the document.right right so here
we will write
the character
and we'll use
two backslashes
is called
backslash
so let's try to print this
so here one thing you can notice
only a single
is printed on the browser the first one
is used as a backslash escape character
and the second one which we have used
will be printed on the browser
we have a few more escape sequence
present in javascript like the backslash
n or we can say newline
we don't use them quite often i'll let
you know if we use them in future so for
now it's enough for escape sequences
present in javascript we discussed data
type in previous videos right so data
types in javascript are of two kinds we
discussed the primitive data types and
the other type is non-primitive or we
can say complex or composite data types
right so an array comes under the
category of composite data types or
non-primitive we can say
so
the basic definition of array states
that an array is a collection of
elements stored in contiguous memory
locations so array is a list of similar
type of elements or in javascript array
acts a bit different from other
programming languages we can discuss it
later so let's understand the concept of
arrays with the help of an example we'll
move to the programming part directly
let's consider a scenario
where we have a collection of similar
types of variables suppose we have a
list of cars
let's create a small list here for a few
different car companies let's say we
have a variable where carbon
and the value of carbon will be
let's say
honda
okay and then we have another variable
let's say car 2 and the value of car 2
will be kia
and finally we have a variable let's say
where
car 3
and the value of car 3 will be let's say
4 so here we have taken three different
car manufacturers we have honda we have
kia and we have four and we have three
different variables right so if we want
to print all three of them what we have
to do is we have to use the
document.write method right so we have
to use the document.write again and
again so we can do it for this small
piece of code right let's print the
value of all three variables here let's
say we are using document
dot right and we will print the value of
all three variables
so here we have printed the value of all
three variables right we have carbon the
value was honda we have honda here we
have kia and we have ford as well
so
this task is a bit simple for this small
piece of code right now imagine if we
have hundred values here instead of just
three values or maybe we can say we have
thousand values in a list we can't
follow the same procedure in that case
right
that's where errors come into play what
we can do is we can use a single
variable and we can store as many values
as we want inside a single variable by
doing this we don't have to access each
and every variable separately while
printing them the data types of those
values present inside the array does not
matter at all so we can save either
numbers or strings or a value with any
data type we'll discuss it in a moment
let's try to define an array here first
so the syntax for array goes like this
we have to take a variable let's say
we'll declare an array here
let's say we are taking a variable where
car
and these opening and closing square
brackets represent the array it means
that it is an array if we are using them
in a variable inside this we can use
double quotes with the value we want to
insert it will go like this let's
suppose we have three values here right
we'll use these three values only we'll
use honda kia and food so to insert
these three values we have to follow
this syntax
so let's say we have the first
manufacturer as honda the next one we
have is
kia
and the last one we have is
ford right so we have all the three
values here present inside a single
variable so we have a single variable
where car and we have all the three
values we have honda we have kia and we
have four so
we can insert as many values as we want
like if we have a list of hundred car
manufacturers we can insert them in this
array now let's print the output of this
area so the output will go like we will
copy document dot right from here
paste it here
and the output will go like this
so we don't need this piece of code
right now so we'll comment this
so that we can understand the difference
between these two codes
and now let's save this program
and see here you can see we have all the
three elements of the array we have
honda we have kia and we have ford as
well
so an array is a non-primitive data type
or composite data type
with one single name and can hold
multiple values here the array name is
car and it stores three similar values
right here we have three string values
we have honda kia and food so this array
can store any number of values we want
to store in that array
so what if we want to print a single
value from these three values we have we
have honda here and 4 right so if we
want to print kia let's suppose so it's
easy to print this on a browser all we
need to know is the index number of that
value
so the index number in the case of
arrays starts from zero and
goes further
so we have three values here
as we can see so the index value
for these variables will be so for honda
the index value will be 0 and for kia
the index value will be 1 and for 4 the
index value will be 2.
so the index value starts from 0 and
goes on further so one thing to keep in
mind guys whatever number of values an
array is holding the last index value
will always be one less than the number
of values so as here you can see we have
three values right so the index number
of the last value will be one less than
three
it means the index number will be two
because the index number starts from
zero
let's try to access the element present
at index one
so we have kia here right all we have to
do is we have to put square brackets
here in the document.right here we have
to put square brackets
and we have to write the index value
inside of these square brackets so if we
write here 1 and if we save this program
now so here you can see we have kia only
it will print
the element present at index number one
so here in this particular case it is
kia
we can also loop through this array
using the index values let's say we want
to print each element on a separate line
every time right so we can use the loop
here i hope you guys are aware of the
for loop by now we'll write here so
we'll
we have declared an array so we will use
the for loop here and we will print here
for will take a variable i
and the value of i will be initial value
will be 0 and then we'll give the
condition the condition will be i less
than 3 because we know there are three
values only and it will go till 2 only
because it's going for the index value
and the final condition will be i
plus plus
so here we'll
use the curly braces because this is the
syntax for for loop and the i value will
iterate through the array and print all
the values present at indexes till the
index 2.
so the same thing goes for 100 elements
as well we can use the for loop to
access all the 100 elements in separate
lines
so guys if we save this and here you can
see okay
it is printing kia kia and kia because
we have
particularly mentioned here cars present
at index one so we have to remove one
here and we'll save it now
so the document.write syntax will be
changed a bit we will write here i
and
if we save it now so we have all the
three values here you can see guys the i
value here will iterate through the
array and print all the values present
at indexes till the index 2 so the same
thing goes for hundred elements as well
we can use the for loop to access all
the hundred elements present in the
array
we can use the same iteration concept
for doing so
so guys there's another way to represent
an array in javascript it goes like this
we have a let's say we have a variable
this time we'll take the variable as
well fruits
so the syntax will be like new we have
to use the new keyword and then we will
use
new array
and we have to give a space here and the
elements we want to store inside the
array so we'll use a apple then we have
let's say
banana and finally we have let's say
mango
okay
and we can access the elements of these
array with the help of a for loop we can
use the similar for loop here so if we
copy this for loop from here
and we'll paste it here
instead of cars
we'll use a
fruits
right and we'll give the value as i
because we want to
iterate the variable i through each
index so we have once again the index
value as 0 for apple one for banana and
two for mango
let's comment this program as well so
that it will be easy for you guys to
understand
let's save this program now
and see we have the list of all the
elements present at array fruits so we
have apple we have banana and we have
mango printed on our browser
so this way of array representation or
declaration is less recommended because
the other way which we discussed earlier
like when we discuss the car
manufacturers so that way is a bit
easier to use
so i'll recommend that way only because
this way is a bit tricky as well
so let's move on to our next topic of
discussion so if you know guys errors in
javascript work differently when
compared to other programming languages
like java and c plus plus so errors in
javascript have dynamic nature which
means we can add or remove elements from
an array at runtime
just like we saw the string methods in
the previous video for arrays also we
have a few methods like if we want to
add elements into an array or if we want
to delete an element from an array we
have the push and pop methods available
to do such tasks
to add an element into an array we use
the push method and the syntax for
pushing elements into an array goes like
so we'll
remove this piece of code
and we'll use the first one only the car
manufacturer
so if we want to push
something inside the array
right
we'll write here the variable name dot
we use the push method and we'll push
whatever value we want to push let's say
we are adding another car manufacturer
let's say we are adding nissan
we have to change the value here as well
because what will happen we have used
the condition i less than 3 so it will
check for indexes still index 2 only it
won't check for index 3 so if we write
here i less than 4 it will check for
nissan now let's save this and see a new
value is pushed into the array which is
nissan
so let's move on and discuss the pop
method so the pop method in array
removes the last present element from
the array if we use this pop method here
it will remove nissan in this case so
now you can see we have four car
manufacturers present in a area so if we
use the
pop option now if we use car.pop and
let's run this program
and see it says undefined this is
happening because as you can see we have
pushed the value nissan into our array
so an
address in the memory location was
reserved for that particular
element now if we pop out that
particular element so if we try to use
cars cars.pop once again let's save it
now and see it removed the
element ford as well so
let's try to push one more
value in this particular scenario let's
say we are pushing a value as
hyundai
and now let's run this so you can see
here it has inserted hyundai in place of
food because we have used the pop
method to put food out of our array
so i hope you guys understood this so
these are the different methods for
areas in javascript which are already
predefined to do some specific tasks
like this sort method if we write here
card dot so here are all the methods
here are all the array methods present
in javascript so if we use this sort
method what it will do it will sort the
array in ascending order
the array.length property so just like
we had the length property in strings so
we have the property in arrays as well
the array.length property is used to
find the length of the array so if we
use it in a for loop in place of this i
less than 4 so
here you can see we have used i less
than 4 now if we write here
array dot length so if we write here
car
dot
length so now we don't have to change
this value again and again so if we are
inserting any value or if we are
removing any value from this for loop so
if we are removing any value from this
array so we don't have to write here 3
or we don't have to change it to 4 every
time we insert an element we don't have
to change that value basically what will
happen it will check for the length of
the array so the length here is
let's say we have the length here 3
right so it will check for the length
and it will be 1 less than the length of
the array so if we run this program now
it will work fine i hope you guys
understood the concept of array methods
present in javascript the other main
difference
array has in javascript which makes it
different from c plus or java is we can
add elements with other data types in
javascript we try to use the push method
to insert a numeric value here in this
car's array so we'll push another value
let's say we are pushing car dot
push and this time we will push
a numeric value let's say we are pushing
here 20.
so let's save it and here you can see
the value 20 is inserted inside the
array car
so we can
use
any data type inside a array in
javascript
objects are the most powerful and the
most used data types in javascript so
far we have seen that we can use a
single variable to store a value the
value can be a string or a number or any
other type of variable
after that we have seen arrays in which
we can store multiple values like we can
store list in arrays
so let's take a scenario here
and let's say we have a piece of code we
are taking a variable let's say where
car manufacturer
and the value of this car manufacturer
will be rd a string right
next up we have another variable let's
say we have a variable car model
and the value of this will be let's say
car from od is q7
then we have another variable let's say
where price of this car
and the price will be
let's say
50 000 us dollars all right next up we
have a function
let's say we are using a function
that is all wheel drive
so we are having a function all wheel
drive
the opening and closing curly braces for
the body of the function and inside this
all wheel drive function we are using
document.write
and here what we will write
will write let's suppose
this car comes
with
quattro all-wheel drive quattro i hope
you guys are aware of this word quattro
it means that four wheel drive
next up we will call this all-wheel
drive function here
so here is the data about a particular
car from a particular brand od right so
the car model is q7 and the price of
this car is 50 000 us dollars so these
are the three different things we are
storing for a car of a particular brand
next up we have a function which states
the capability of the car the function
here is the all-wheel drive which means
that this car comes with four wheel
drive instead of general front wheel
drive or rear wheel drive
so this function is the behavior of the
car right
it shows that the car is four wheel
drive things are pretty sorted here
right we have the data about the car and
a function associated with it so let's
save this and we can see the output here
the car comes with quattro all wheel
drive so this is a basic piece of code
right
we have been through functions we know
how to use functions we know how to call
them so that's quite easy for now right
the problem occurs when we have a list
of cars let's say that we have to
maintain 100 different cars with all the
data of car manufacturer we have car
model price and then we have different
behaviors for different cars not all
cars have the all-wheel drive property
so
what we will do in such a case where we
have to use the same property again and
again for 100 different cars or 100
different entities we can copy paste
this same piece of code repeatedly and
we have to change the value every time
we copy paste it so we have to change
the variable name the car manufacturer
the car model and the price as well
imagine we are doing this for a list of
cars then it goes on and on so this is
the most inefficient way of tackling
this problem right
this is where the concept of objects
come into play
these objects help us to bundle all
these properties and attributes about
one particular entity if we talk about
this particular example of a car we can
put all these properties and many other
properties like car weight we have car
color and so on
together under
one name and make it an object
let's move on to the syntax for objects
in javascript we'll do it for this same
program we'll use
objects now let's go ahead and have a
look at the syntax for objects
so before we start
there are few ways in which we can
create objects in javascript we are
going to discuss two different ways of
doing so the first one is the literal
way also known as the literal object way
so the syntax for literal object way
goes like this
let's say we are declaring a variable
where car and
curly braces so these curly braces
represent that this car variable is
actually an object
inside this
we will define all the cars properties
that is whatever data we want to store
about the car like car manufacturer car
model and price in this particular
scenario so let's
use them here so we have
car manufacturer
and the car manufacturer is od
right
next up we have car model
car model is
q7
finally we have the price which is
50 000
dollars
so you can identify the difference here
inside the object right when we declare
a variable we usually use the equals to
sign for assignment but here in objects
we use the column and we are using
commas here because we have some more
properties so these three are the
properties for this object car we have
three properties associated with it we
can also add this all wheel drive
function inside the object and when we
use this function inside the object it
will be called a method whenever we use
a function inside a class or an object
so it is known as a method keep this
thing in mind guys so that syntax is
also a bit different when it comes to
methods inside an object the syntax for
that will be
we have to write here all wheel drive
and we'll use the colon then it is a
function so we will write here function
with opening and closing round brackets
and the body of the function
so what we want to write here is we want
to we want this function to return the
value right we want this function to
return this value so we'll copy it from
here
and we'll paste it here
so we want this function to return this
value so we'll write here return instead
of
document.write now this function will
return this string that this cars comes
with a quattro all wheel drive so if you
want to change this string a little bit
you can change because we have already
used this string in the previous program
we did so let's suppose
we'll write here
four wheel drive now this will be easier
for you to understand this
so this is what an object looks like our
object is entirely ready what we did
here is we bundled all these things and
coupled them we bundled all these things
we bundled all the three variables we
bundled this function we bundled all of
them together inside a single variable
and now this particular variable car is
an object now if we want to access these
properties of the object like car
manufacturer car model etc whatever
properties we have here so what we have
to do is we have to
use document.write so it is quite simple
so after this object we'll write here
document
dot write
and to access this object what we have
to do is we have to use the
object name with the dot operator and
the property name so if we want to let's
suppose
we'll use here
car dot and property name will be car
underscore
manufacturer
so here is the syntax the syntax is
quite easy you can see here we have used
the car object with the dot operator and
then we have the property name whatever
property we want to access
so let's save this program now and see
here it says od
by using this dot operator we can access
any property of the car not just a
property we can access the method as
well so if we want to access the method
like if we want to access this all wheel
drive function
we can do it simply by writing here car
dot and we'll write here instead of this
we'll write here all wheel drive and
we are good to go so if we save this now
so here you can see it says this car
comes with four wheel drive so it is
quite easy to access these properties of
an object so we can do it by using this
now suppose we call this function
normally with the document.write inside
the function in place of return so if we
write here
document.write
it's normal like how we normally call a
function so if we write here
document.write inside this function and
we can call this function by the normal
method like if you are calling this
function from outside what we will do we
will write here car dot
and the function name
so if we save this now here you can see
the string is printed on the browser
this car comes with four wheel drive and
you can see here we didn't used any h1
tag or h2 tag so you can spot the
difference right
so that's how you can call the method of
an object from outside this is the
normal way
so now you guys might be wondering what
if we want to add more cars into this we
can copy paste it again to do so and
change the value of properties again it
is the same thing we can do with the
variables so this is where the following
way of creating objects come into the
picture
in which we use something different
known as object constructor that's a bit
different from other object programming
languages so don't worry if you don't
know about it also in the newer versions
javascript supports the concept of
classes and object
so what we used to say earlier is
javascript is an object oriented
scripting language because it does not
supports the concept of classes and
objects fully but now the scenario has
changed javascript do support the
concept of classes and objects but we'll
keep it a bit simple so let's comment
this code as well
and we'll use this code for reference
so we'll comment this that's why we are
not removing it
but we can remove this piece of code
so let's remove it
and let's
move on to user second way of creating
an object
now we will create multiple objects
using a single template which is known
as a constructor function
let's have a look at the syntax for this
method so we'll write the function
keyword and we have named this function
as cars and in parenthesis we will
provide the
properties as parameters so these are
the properties we have car manufacturer
we have car model and we have car price
so these are the properties which we
used in the previous code as well so
here we have also used these properties
so we'll keep it that way only
now inside a function these parameters
are known as arguments so if we talk
about the naming convention so these
parameters are known as arguments
so let's move on to the body of the
function and inside the body we will use
this keyword here
this keyword refers to the object it
belongs to so here in this program this
will refer to the object basically
so what we are doing here is whenever we
are creating any object using this
constructor function we will pass
specific values like the car
manufacturer car model and the price all
of these values so all these values will
be present at the rhs so let me write
this first let's say we are using this
dot and the property name car
manufacturer
will write here
car manufacturer
so all these values will be present at
the rhs and the actual property of the
object will be this dot car manufacturer
so
this is the actual property of this
method you will understand it much
better when we create the object for now
let's mention here the other two
properties and method as well so
let's
use the other two properties which were
this dot
car model
and
we'll write your car model the last one
was this dot
price
we'll write here price
let's add the method here as well inside
the constructor function we'll use this
keyword again to add the method the
syntax will go like this
we'll use this
dot all wheel drive
and this is a
function so we'll write here function
with the opening and closing round
brackets and then we have the body of
the function
inside the body of this function we will
write
whatever we have written in the previous
program so we'll copy it from here
and we'll paste it here
right so this is a complete constructor
function now using this constructor
function we can create multiple objects
of this car type so this constructor
function works like a template or like
the classes work in other languages like
c plus plus and java
so let's create an object here
so we'll create a variable here let's
say we are creating a variable c1 now
will use the new keyword
and along with the
constructor function so we'll use your
cards and we'll pass the values for all
the three properties so here you can say
we have
the car manufacturer is rd and next up
we have the
model as
q7 and the price is
50 000.
okay so we have created a variable we
have passed the
values for the properties
and now
if you want to access this function if
we want to access this all-wheel drive
function we can access this as well we
have to write here c1 dot all wheel
drive and
this is how you can call a function
if we save this program see here it says
this car comes with four wheel drive so
if you change anything here let's
suppose we are using here h2tech
if we save this program now see you can
see the change here so we are calling
this function here and this will be
printed on the browser so this string
will be printed on the browser
let's create another variable here let's
say we are using where c2 and the syntax
will be same for this as well we'll
write here new cars and we'll pass the
values here so let's say we are using
bmw
and next up we have the model as
x7
and the price of this car is let's say
40 000 okay 40 000 usd
so
if we want to access any particular
property of any object like if we want
to access the car model or if we want to
access the car manufacturer so we can do
it the same way as we did previously as
we did in the literal object way so
to do so we have to write here
document.write
and
it was quite simple so we have to write
here the object name dot
and whatever we want to print let's say
we are printing here car model so if we
save this now you can see here x7 is
printed on the browser because x7 is the
value of object c2 and let's suppose if
we want to
print here car manufacturer save it and
see here you can see we have bmw as the
output on a browser similarly we can
access the price as well let's save it
now and see here it says 40 000 so this
is how we can create multiple objects in
javascript we'll continue with the
previous program we made so
today we will use the literal object way
because this method of creating objects
is a bit easier than the other one we
discussed which was the constructor
function method so here we created the
car object which has three properties
car manufacturer car model and the price
of the car we have a method here as all
wheel drive when we use this method here
we use this method with the dot operator
and we
call that function we call that method
with the help of the object
so the output was this car comes with
four wheel drive so this was something
we did in the previous video
if we talk about objects in javascript a
lot of things we know about in
javascript
are basically objects like the boolean
values numbers strings and a few more so
many of these things can be objects if
we define them with the new keyword
basically any of the data type other
than the null and undefined can be
converted to objects or they have their
equivalent object forms if we define
them with the new keyword
so we have a few predefined objects as
well we have the math object the date
object and the regular expression are
also considered objects in javascript a
lot of things are objects in javascript
we'll use objects in dom manipulation
which we will go through in further
videos so that's why it is pretty
essential to understand the whole
concept of objects right so next up
let's look at how we can use different
data types as objects in javascript
so the syntax for using the basic data
types as objects in javascript goes like
this we'll declare a variable first we
have a variable str1 and next up we'll
write here the new keyword and the data
type so stringer is a data type which we
will be using as objects for now so this
is the complete syntax of how to use a
data type as an object in javascript if
we'll write here str
one and we'll use the dot operator so
here we can see we have the object
methods as well right
so i hope you guys are aware of the
methods present in javascript like we
had the string and array methods right
we have methods for object as well like
the index of method we have seen the use
of index of method when we went through
the string methods in javascript so
similarly we have the font color and the
length property for object as well so
length here is the property and other
which we can see are the methods for
objects in javascript so here this str1
becomes the object by default when we
use the new keyword with the string
while declaring
so there are few ways to determine if a
variable is an object or a primary data
type
so the easiest way to do so is to use
the type of operator
so let's use it here and check the type
of variable str1 will write here
document.write
and we'll print the type of this
variable
so we'll use the type of operator and
the type of variable str1
so let me put it inside the h1 tag
so here we have written a type of
operator so let's print this value on
the browser if we save it see here you
can see it says object
if we write a string here in place of
this new string so if we
write here any string let's suppose we
are using a string here let's say we are
using
hello
okay let's save it now and here you can
see the type of this variable str1
changed from object to string so this is
the difference between
a primitive data type it was a string
earlier but when we use it with the new
keyword along with
the string
and
this is the basic syntax of how to
define a primitive data type as an
object so if we save it now here you can
see it is converted to object
similarly we can use the other basic
data types as well and
the other predefined objects we talked
about like the date object and the math
object will go through each of them in
separate videos so moving on let's go
back to our car object after we declared
the whole object we defined all the
three properties and the method also
somewhere in the program we realized
that we had missed a particular property
and we realized it after we have written
150 lines of code after this car object
so here you can see we have written here
150 line of code so
i'm not writing 150 lines but let's do
it this way so we realized it after 150
lines
in javascript
we can add a particular property to an
object outside the definition also we
can add a property to an object anywhere
in a program the syntax for that goes
like this
we'll write the
object name
with the property name along with the
dot operator so we'll write here one
more property let's say we are using
car color
and the value of this
property will be let's say
black
right what this line will do is it will
add one more property inside this
existing car object so initially we had
three properties now this line will add
one more property to this car object we
are using the same name that is the
object's name having three properties
over here we are using the same object
name here you can see here the object
name is car and here we have also used
the car object name now we have added
one more property to this object car we
can check it let's print it out on the
browser
so what we will do we will write here
document
dot write
so here you can see we have used the
document.write method to print this car
color on our browser so we have used
here car dot car color let's save this
program now and see
here you can see the output is black so
this is the property of the object car
now and if we comment this line let's
say if we are commenting this line
let's save this now and see here you can
see
it says undefined we can add more
properties similarly like if we want to
add another property here we can go like
car dot and the property name whatever
property we want to add let's say we
want to add fuel type
so it can be a petrol car or a diesel
car or an electric car it doesn't matter
so we can add properties as well in fact
we can add methods as well so the syntax
to add method goes like we can add a
method here we'll
see it will go like car dot let's say we
are adding a new function
let's say we are adding the function nu1
equals to and here we will write
function
so the
body of the function now whatever we
want to write inside the function let's
say this function return function
successfully
added
so if we try to call this function from
outside we can do it so let's try to
check out the output for this function
let's say we want to access this
particular function so save it now and
here you can see it says function
successfully added so the new method we
added is the new fun and we added this
method to our pre-existing object which
was the car object so i hope you guys
are aware of how to add a new property
or a new method to an existing object by
now what if we want to delete a
particular object
so it's pretty easy to do so in
javascript we can use the delete keyword
object name and the property name after
the dot operator let's suppose we want
to delete car model here we want to
delete this particular property of the
object car so what we'll do we'll delete
this car model
so the syntax for it is quite simple so
we'll remove this for now and we'll
delete a property let's say we are using
the delete keyword with
the object name dot method name or the
property name so we'll delete here
car model right
let's save it now
so this particular line will delete the
car model attribute of this car object
let's check it out and we will print
here the car model so
we'll write here car dot
car underscore model
and
save it now so here you can see it says
undefined and if we try to comment this
line and now if we try to save this
program so here you can see the car
model is q7
so this is how we can delete a
particular property or a particular
method from an object one more thing
before we wrap up this video is as we
all know javascript is a loosely typed
language right so we can change the data
type of these properties on the fly now
we will change the data type of this
property we had the price property right
so we'll change the data type of this
particular property now
we know that the value of the price
property is a number let's change this
number to a string data type what we
have to do is we have to write
so we have to write here car dot
price
and
update the value here let's say we are
using 70 000 and we have to put a
semicolon it's the same thing we do to
update the value of a particular
variable right so if we try to print the
value of price now we'll get the output
as 70 000. let's try to print it on the
browser so we'll cut it from here
we'll paste it here and we'll print
car price
save it now see here you can see it says
70 000.
if we want to check the type of this
property
what we can do is
we can use the type of operator so we'll
use the type of operator
so this is the syntax of how we can use
the type of operator let's save this now
and see here it says string
earlier it was a number but now it is a
string so all these things can be done
dynamically in a program wherever we
want to do them so that's the benefit of
having objects in javascript in
javascript we can use constructor in two
different ways we will be discussing
both of them the first one we will
discuss is the object constructor method
and other way of doing so is by using
the constructor function we have already
discussed the constructor function in
the previous video wherein we took the
example of a car
but we'll go through it once again so
that there will be no confusion between
all the methods of creating an object in
javascript
so let's move ahead and we'll go through
the object constructor method now
so the syntax for creating an empty
object using the object constructor
method goes like this we'll write the
where keyword followed by the object
name
then we have the equals to sign and
the equals to sign is followed by the
new keyword and object with a capital u
so this is the syntax of creating an
empty object by using the object
constructor method
so you guys have to remember this syntax
and it will remain the same every time
we use the object constructor method
so this object here so this object is
the constructor what this will do is it
will create an instance for this object
and assign it to the object name so
whatever object we are creating here it
will assign it to this object through
which we can write and access other
properties of the object let's move on
and we'll create an object first let's
say we are creating the same program we
did in the previous tutorial wherein we
printed the area and the perimeter of a
rectangle so we'll use the same program
so that there will be no confusion let's
move ahead and create an empty object
now so the syntax will be like we'll
write the
object name as
let's say rack2 and then we have the new
keyword along with the
object and opening and closing round
brackets so this is an empty object so
this statement is the same as
like if you remember in the last video
when we
created an object using the object
lateral method so we created it like we
wrote
where keyword along with the
object name
and then we have a pair of curly braces
so both these statements are same
what we did is we created an empty
object in both the cases so after
creating an empty object the next thing
we'll do is we'll add properties and
behaviors to that object so let's move
on and we'll add two properties which
are length and the width of a rectangle
and then we'll add methods as well so
how to add properties to an object we'll
write here the object name dot property
name so the object name here is rect2
and the property name will be
length equals to the value of length
will be let's say 5
and the second property we have is the
width
and we'll write here rect 2 dot
width and the value for this will be
let's say 10 so we are done with the
properties here next up we'll add the
methods as well so let's add the two
methods as well in this object uh two
methods are the get area and get
parameter method the syntax for adding
methods to an object goes like this
we are adding a method get area right so
we'll write here the object name
dot
method name so let's save
our method name is get area
followed by an equals to sign in
we'll write your function and then the
body of the method so this get area
method will return the area of a
rectangle right so we'll use this
keyword again as we did in the last
video by now i hope you guys are aware
of this keyword so we'll write here
return this dot
length
into
this dot
width so this method will return the
area of rectangle next up we have
another method which is
we'll write here rect2 dot
get parameter
for printing the perimeter of a
rectangle
so we'll again write here function and
then we have the body of the function so
this
method will return the parameter so the
perimeter of rectangle goes like
2 into length
plus
2 into
width
so here we are done with the object next
up we'll print these values on the
browser so
we'll use the same code for printing
which we used in the previous video
so we'll copy it from here and we'll
paste it here so what we have to change
here is we have to change the name of
our object so we'll write here rect 2 in
place of rect 1 and we are good to go
let's save this so here you can see we
have made a mistake here so
you can see that it is not printing the
parameter of a rectangle right so the
mistake here is we forgot to mention the
this keyword here
so we'll write here this dot length and
this dot width so let's save this now
and
see we have the length width area and
perimeter of the rectangle so the area
is 10 into 5 which is 50 and the
perimeter is 2 into 10 plus 2 into 5
so 20 plus 10 equals to 30 so we have
the parameter here as well
and if you guys remember we had the same
output in the previous video as well so
the difference between the object
constructor method and the object
literal method is almost negligible
right the main difference is at the
initial part of the code so the main
difference lies here the syntax is bit
different in the object literal method
we used curly braces and in the
object constructor method we use the
parentheses of course there are some
more minor differences but the code
looks almost the same in the end so the
advantage of the literal object method
over the object constructor method is it
is easy to use syntax wise also it
executes faster than this method because
we define all the properties and methods
at a single place while defining the
object right
so
this is the difference between the
object literal method and the
object constructor method so we'll
commend this program now and let's move
ahead and discuss another way of
creating an object which is the
constructor function method this way of
creating an object is a bit different
from the other two ways which we
discussed till now
it is used when we work with multiple
instances of an object it works like we
have a template and we can access that
template using
multiple objects so if we want to make
more than one object and
we don't want to write the code again
and again for each object we can use
this method when we have more than one
object if you guys remember like in the
previous video where we took the example
of a car we created an object car and
then we created multiple instances
wherein we use those instances for
different car manufacturers
let's take a look at this method first
and then we'll discuss the advantages of
using this method as well
so as the name suggests the method
starts with
functions and then we'll write the name
of the function let's say we have rect
and then inside the opening and closing
round brackets we'll pass the properties
as parameters so let's take a look
we'll write here length
comma width so we have these two
properties only and then we have the
body of the function
so inside the function's body we'll
write the properties and we'll use this
keyword here what we'll do is we'll use
this dot property name equals to
property name
so
we'll write here
this
dot
length
equals to
so this is the syntax for adding any
property to a function what we just did
is whenever we are going to create an
object using this constructor function
method will pass certain values will
pass the length and the width right so
all these values will be present at the
rhs so all these values will be present
here and this dot length will be the
actual property of the object
so let's move ahead and add the second
property as well
we'll write here
this
dot
width
equals to
so we had two methods as well right
let's add them here inside the
constructor function
we'll use this keyword again
we'll write here
this dot
get area
and
we'll write your function
with opening and closing round brackets
and the body of the function so this
method will again return the area of a
rectangle so we'll write here return
length
into
width
so there's a difference in these two
methods so here we use the this keyword
here and in the previous method we used
this keyword inside the
method right so there's a difference in
these two methods so
now what we'll do we'll add another
method so the next method is this dot
get parameter
and the syntax will be the same we'll
write a function
then the body of the function
will write return
2 into length
plus
2 into width
so here we are done with the constructor
function now all we have to do is we
have to create an object and we'll pass
the parameters as well so let's say we
are creating an object here
for that we have to write here where and
the object name so let's say the object
name is r1
and after the equals 2 we have to write
the new keyword and the
name of the
function so we'll write here rack 3 and
we'll pass the
parameters so let's say the parameters
are 5 and 10 because we use these
parameters in other two videos as well
so we'll write here
5 and 10. let's suppose we want to print
the area and parameter so here we are
done with the printing part so what we
are printing is we are printing the area
of the rectangle and the parameter of
the rectangle so we have called these
two methods using the
object name so we have written here
r1.getarea and
r1.getparameter similarly if we want to
print the length and width we can do
that as well what we have to do is we
have to write
document
dot
and let's say we are printing them
simply we'll write here
r1 dot
length
and then we'll copy this
write here bit so here we are done with
the total process and now we will save
this program
and see we have the values here the
value of length is 5 because we have
passed the parameter s5 and then we have
the value of width which is 10
and this is also because of the
parameter
then we have the area of rectangle which
is 10 into 5
so it is 50 and then we have the
perimeter as 30 so the advantage of
using this method is we can create more
objects if we want to add one more
object here let's say we are using where
r2 and we want
to print let's say the parameters are
different here let's say we are giving
as 4 and 10 or let's say we are giving
in four and eight
so what we have to do is we have to copy
all this and we have to change the value
here as instead of r1 we'll
use r2 here again we'll
use r2
and then we have to update the value of
r2 here and we are good to go now so
let's save this program and see we have
the
values for other object as well so here
we have 4 as length and then we have 8
as width and the area is 8 into 4 which
is 32 and the parameter is 2 into 8
which is 16 and 2 into 4 which is 8 so
16 plus 8 is 24. till now we came across
several different ways of creating an
object in javascript right we can create
an object using the object literal
method or we can do it with the help of
the constructor function so by now i
hope you guys are aware of how to create
an object and how to add properties and
methods to an object like we can create
methods that perform several specific
tasks if we talk about a method in
particular if you guys remember in the
previous video we created a program for
the area and parameter of a rectangle so
in that program we created a method get
area which returns the area of the
rectangle right so we had to call that
method and we can sit back and relax
because we know that it will print the
area of the rectangle right
so let's move ahead and today we will
discuss a completely new topic which is
prototypes in javascript so for this
video we are going to use console for
printing that's because it will be easy
for you guys to understand the concept
of prototypes if we use the console
instead of using a normal document.write
method
so let me do one thing guys we'll print
a statement on the console
so
we'll write here
console.log
and we'll print
let's say
welcome to simply code
so let's save this and if we open
console here in our browser
we have to go to inspect and then we
have to go to console and here you can
see we have welcome to simply code
written over here
so in the last video we talked about
creating an object with the help of
object literal method right so let's
suppose we are creating an object here
with the help of
same object literal method so what we
have to do
we have to create an empty object first
so let's say our object name is abc
and we'll use the curly braces here so
what we have to do is we have to pass
the properties here so let's suppose our
properties are name and the value of
name let's say
caution followed by a comma and then we
have
let's say subject value of subject will
be
let's say javascript
and then finally we have the
address
so let's say the value of address is
bang lock right
this is a basic object we made right if
we write here console.log abc so if we
want to print this object on the console
so what we'll do here we'll write
console.log and then we'll use
abc so let's save this now and here you
can see on the console that we have our
object here so we have our object with
all the three properties we have address
is bangalore we have name as caution and
subject as javascript
so if you guys look here carefully you
will notice that we have one more entity
here that is we have underscore
underscore pro 2.
so what is this underscore underscore
pro 2
so all right we mentioned all the other
three properties in our object but we
didn't do anything for this underscore
underscore proto so let's discuss this
now let's take a scenario wherein
someone told us to create a website like
let's suppose we have to make a travel
website through which people can book
their travel destinations
now do we have to start creating the
website from scratch no that's because
we have some of the necessary conditions
already fulfilled like we have chrome we
already have bootstrap for styling and
all and we can use bootstrap to design a
website right so we have certain things
already present and we have to work over
them to create our website
similarly prototype refers to the
destination from where we started to
create an object like we have methods
for arrays we have objects and strings
as well so all these methods are being
inherited from somewhere so whenever we
create an object using the object
literal method then it will start
creating the object from the object dot
prototype so if we click here on the
underscore underscore proto
we have access to a list of methods
already present within the object dot
prototype so and all of them are
predefined we can use any of them we
didn't define them they are already
present we define only these three
properties like we defined address name
and subject only
in simple words all javascript objects
inherits properties and methods from a
prototype date objects inherit from date
dot prototype and similarly when we use
array objects they inherit from
array.prototype so the object dot
prototype is on the top of the prototype
inheritance chain so
date objects array objects and person
objects all these
objects inherit their properties from
object dot prototype so moving on now
let's create another object
so we talked about the object literal
method so here we don't have too much to
do so let's move ahead and we'll create
another object this time we'll create it
with the help of a constructor function
so let's create a function here first
let's say we have a function named as
function xyz
so then we have the parameters as name
and then we have we'll take all these
three properties we'll take name subject
and
let's say
address
so then we have the body of the function
inside which will use the this keyword
we'll write here this dot name equals to
name
similarly this dot
address equals to
address
and finally we have this dot
subject equals to subject
so we'll create an instance now let's
say
we are creating an object let's say our
object name is where
x1 and we'll write here new
and then we'll write xyz and we'll pass
the values so let's say the name is
caution and we have
subject as let's change the subject
we'll write here java and we have
finally have the address let's say the
address is earth
okay so the values are different from
the previous example we took
what we'll do now we'll write here
console.log and we'll print
x1 now
so we are done creating an object and
here we have a constructor function
named xyz and then we have few
properties which are the same as we used
in the previous example so then we have
an object named x1 which holds the
values for all three properties and
lastly we printed the object on the
console so let's save it now and we can
see here in console we have the object
with all the properties there is almost
no difference here from the object
literal method right but
when we click here on the pro 2. here we
can encounter the difference now you can
see here we have one more entity here
named as the constructor so this
constructor here has its own prototype
so this constructor here has its own
prototype if we use a constructor in a
program it always has its own prototype
this might seem a bit difficult to you
guys but don't worry it will be apparent
to you guys once we move on to the usage
and modifications of prototype
so here we are with the two examples in
the first one we created an object
with the help of object literal method
there we saw that it has only a single
prototype
that is the object prototype later when
we moved on to the constructor function
method we realized that there are two
different prototypes present one is the
prototype which is available every time
that is the object dot prototype and the
other one is the constructor's own
prototype it might sound a little hard
to you guys but prototype is nothing but
it refers to the point from where it all
started from where we have inherited all
the properties
so we can make changes to the prototype
of our own object like if we want to add
something to a prototype we can do it we
have a method for that in javascript
we'll do it
later in this video we can't make
changes to the object prototype remember
this thing guys i'll suggest you not to
edit the object dot prototype because
it's not a good practice to make changes
in that if we want to edit any prototype
then we have to make sure that we are
making changes in our own prototype that
we made with the help of constructors
the prototype made by us is also
inherited from the object dot prototype
if we want to make another prototype
here we can do it like if we are going
to add utility functions to our program
but at the same time we don't want to do
anything with the properties of our
constructor function we can make another
prototype for that we can create a
prototype for separate method so if we
want to add a method in this
constructor function we can do it we can
add it separately with the help of
prototypes so for that we have to follow
a syntax a particular syntax we can do
it this way like we have to write here
xyz
dot prototype and then we have to write
the method name let's say we are
writing here
get name
fine we'll write here function
and then we have the body of the
function so let's suppose this method
returns the name
so we'll write here
return
this
dot name so if we try to run this
program now we can see there is no
difference
from the previous one but if we check
the prototypes now so here you can see
we have another prototype named as get
name so this is how we can edit the
prototype of our object now if we try to
access this get name method with the
help of x1 object so we can do it so
let's try to do it on console we'll
write here
x1 dot get name
and
see here we have the output as caution
similarly let's create one more
prototype here to remove any sort of
confusion so what we'll do we'll create
another
prototype so let's say we are creating a
prototype for
address now so what we'll do we'll write
here
xyz dot
prototype
dot
get
address
so
it will be a method so we'll write here
function
we don't have to pass any parameters
here
so let's suppose it returns
the
value of address
so we'll write here this dot address and
we are good to go so let's save it now
and if we go to pro underscore
underscore proto we can see we have one
more prototype here named as get address
so what we have to do now is
we'll make another object let's say we
are copying this from here
we'll paste it here
so let's change the values let's say we
write here mars and then we have let's
change the subject basically because we
are
looking for the subject so let's change
this value as well
let's say we have here
simply code
and we'll change the name of the object
let's say we have x2 now save it and if
we write here
x2 dot
let's say get name
so here you can see the output has
simply got similarly if we write here
instead of get name we write here get
address
so here you can see the output as mars
because the value we passed while
creating the object is mars here so we
can
access this value directly using the
prototype method so if we use the object
constructor function if you guys
remember we cannot add a new property to
an existing object for example if we try
to add a property here let's say if we
try to add a property to this existing
function what we can write here is
xyz dot
grades
let's say the grade is
a
so if we save this now
here you can see there's nothing changed
here so we don't have any change in the
prototypes or we don't have any changes
in the properties as well so we simply
can't add a property to an existing
function like this but we have a method
for this also
so to add a new property to a
constructor we must add it to the
constructor function or we can use the
prototype property here as well so the
javascript prototype property allows us
to add new properties to a object
constructor
just like we added the methods to a
constructor function previously
similarly we can add properties as well
so we have to write here
so we'll remove this line
we have to write here xyz dot
prototype
and then we have to write the property
name here let's say we are writing here
grades and then we'll pass the value
let's say the grade is a
so if we save this now and if we go back
here and if we check the
underscore underscore proto so here you
can see we have a property here named as
grades and the value is
a
so if we try to print x1 dot grade in
our console so the output will be
a
so let's try to do it here
we'll write here
x2 dot
grids
and here you can see the value is a here
so we can add a property to an existing
constructor function with the help of
prototype methods so this is the basic
usage of prototypes in javascript we can
use prototypes to add a property or a
method to an already existing
constructor function so guys inheritance
is an essential concept in any
object-oriented programming language
inheritance refers to the procedure
through which one class or one
constructor inherits the properties and
methods of another constructor in simple
terms let's suppose we have a
constructor named as vehicle and we know
we have different types of vehicles
present like we have cars and we have
bikes as well so all these types share a
few things in common right
now if we want to create a constructor
let us say we want to create a
constructor bike and we want it to have
a few of the same properties and methods
as of the vehicles constructor
so in that case we are left with two
option
either we can copy the properties from
vehicle constructor and paste them
inside the bike constructor or we can
simply use inheritance to inherit those
properties from the vehicle constructor
to the bike constructor in this case the
vehicle class will be known as a base
class and the bike constructor or class
will be known as derived constructor
because we derived a few properties from
the vehicle constructor right
don't worry guys i know the concept of
classes might be new for you and the
concept of inheritance might seem a bit
different from other languages like if
you are coming from a c plus plus
background you may notice that there we
use classes for the concept of
inheritance but in javascript before the
introduction of es6 that is ecmascript
6. the concept of inheritance was based
on constructors and prototypes so with
the introduction of ecmascript 6 the
idea of classes was also introduced in
javascript and the usage of inheritance
was also changed we will discuss classes
and inheritance in the next video
today we are going to discuss the
traditional way of using prototypes for
inheritance so don't be stressed guys if
you are not clear with the syntax of
inheritance by the end of this video in
the next video you will understand the
concept and syntax of inheritance
without any confusion
so we'll now talk about a few things so
let's start with the programming part if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
so guys whenever we create an object
with a method like we can create an
object with the help of object literal
method or we can do the same with the
help of constructor function method as
well right
then we have a prototype every time you
might have noticed it we have been
through it in the past few videos so
every time we create an object we notice
that it has a prototype now what we will
do here is we'll create a prototype
so the syntax will be like so we'll
write here const we are using const in
place of variable i hope you guys are
aware of
const where and let keywords so today we
are using here const so let's say the
prototype name is
employee
we'll write a equals to and then we have
the body of the prototype let's do one
thing now we'll use a method let's say
the method name is
post post of the employee
and we'll write here
function and then we have the body of
the function so let's say this function
returns a string so we'll write here
return and let's say the function
returns a
software developer and then we have
another function named as change name
and we'll write your function
will pass a parameter
and then we have the body of this method
so we'll write here this dot name
is equal to name and we are good to go
right
so what we did here is we created a
prototype of the name employee and it
has two functions one is the employees
post and the other one is to change the
name
so let's save this program and check it
in the console if it has any errors so
let's save it now and we'll go here and
check on the console
so here you can see
everything is fine so till now we
created a prototype now let's create an
object as well so what we'll do
we'll create an object here we'll write
here let's say where and let's say the
object name is even
so we'll
create an object with the help of
object dot create method
okay so we have to write here dot
so we have to
pass
the prototype name so we'll write here
employee and then what we'll do we'll
print this on our console so we'll write
here console.log
and we'll write here even let's say so
we created an object even with the help
of object.create method let's save it
and check it on the console if we see
here we don't have anything else other
than a single prototype
right we have a single prototype here we
have no method mentioned so if we open
it we have the two methods of course we
have post and we have change name but if
we write here let's say we are writing
here even dot name and then value of
name will be let's say
caution
and then we'll assign a role as well
let's see these are the two new
properties
we'll write here even dot rule and let's
say the role of caution is
writer
fine and if we save it and check it
again on the console
now what we did is we changed the name
and rule right so these are the two
properties we have both name as caution
and rule as writer
now let's see if we can use the methods
here as well
so we'll write here let's say we are
using the method even dot
change name what we'll do here is we'll
change the name from caution to
something else
let's say we are going to change the
name as
ram
so if we save this now
so here you can see the name is changed
to ram
initially the name was caution and when
we use the change name method now you
can see here the name is changed to ram
so this means that the methods we
defined inside the prototype are working
right now let's say we want to create
another object here we created an object
even till now we assigned some
properties to it and we changed the name
and printed it on the console
now let me tell you guys an alternate
way to do so
so what we'll do is we'll copy this line
from here because the syntax of that
method also looks a bit same
so the syntax will remain the same till
here so we'll paste it here what we'll
do next is
we'll pass a few arguments here
so let's pass the arguments first then
i'll explain it to you guys so what we
are going to do is we are going to use
curly braces for arguments
and we are going to write here
it's a name and the value of name will
be we are going to write here
value
and we'll pass the value as let's say
caution2
right
so we'll use a comma here then we'll use
role and
will pass the value of role as well so
let's say the value of rule is
programmer now
right put a comma here
now i know the syntax is a bit
complicated but this is the reason why
classes were introduced in es6 so this
is the reason we will be using classes
in future but going through this syntax
will make the next one easier for you
guys so we have created an object here
with the object.create method and we
passed few arguments here so we have
name and the value of name we want it to
be cautional too and the value of role
we want it to be program so if we copy
this from here or let's say if we copy
these two lines from here if we cut
these two lines from here and we'll
paste it here
so if you see here we have two objects
of the same name we have where even and
here also we have variable now both
these syntaxes are doing the same thing
that is creating an object of the same
name
suppose if we comment this first object
let's say we are commenting this one and
we'll also comment this line
if we save this now and if we see on our
console so here you can see we have the
name as caution2 and rule as programmer
so
these two syntaxes are doing exactly the
same thing
the only thing to notice here is if we
use this line with this syntax if we use
even dot change name
and if we save this now you can see it
is not working in this case right so if
we want to do it we have to write
some more code so what we have to do is
we have to write here
writeable
and we have to
pass the value as true
so what we are doing is we are allowing
this method to change the name from
caution to to ram so if we save it now
here you can see the name is ram now
earlier it was caution too and
now this is working totally fine right
so both the syntaxes are doing the same
things as we can see here the reason
behind going through this is we need the
syntax of creating objects later in this
video so i hope you guys understood it
now moving ahead let's take a look at
prototypal inheritance so what we are
going to do is we are going to comment
this
code
so we are going to comment all this and
we are going to write a new one for
prototypal inheritance
lets say we have a constructor function
so lets create a constructor function
first so what we are going to do is we
are going to
write here let's say we are going to
create the same function we will take
the same example of employee right so we
will write here function employee and
will pass
the properties here let's say we are
writing a name and another one is id and
the last property is
salary of the employee right so next up
we have the
body of the constructor so we'll write
inside here
this dot name
is equal to name
then we have this dot
id equals to id then we have
this dot
salary equals to
salary
right
so we know this already right
we'll now add a method to the prototype
of the employee so we'll write here
we'll write outside this constructor
will write here
employ
dot prototype dot
post let's say the name of the method is
post so what we are going to do is we
are going to write a function
and then we have the body of the
function so let's say this returns the
post of the employee what we'll do is
we'll write here return
and
it will return the name plus post of the
employee right so we'll write here this
dot name
plus
bit of space
and then again
we'll write here
is a content creator let's say right so
we are done with the method here
as you can see what we did here is we
created a constructor employee and added
a function that returns this string upon
calling
so we haven't done anything extra till
now let's create an object now so we'll
write here let's say we are creating an
object
where caution and what we'll do is we'll
write a new underscore employee
and we'll pass the values here so let's
say the values are
caution and the id is for like let's say
this is the id 3 4
3 2 or whatever it is
and the salary let's say is 10 000 okay
so the next thing is we'll write here
console.log
and we'll print the value of caution on
a console
so let's save it now and here you can
see we have all the properties here we
have ids three four three two name as
caution and salary is ten thousand here
if you see inside proto you can see here
we have a method here name is post and
we have constructor as employee and then
we have object as well now if we call
the prototype post with this object so
what we have to do is we have to write
here in console
we'll write here caution dot post
and here you can see we have the output
as caution is a content creator
till now it's fine right we did small
things which we learned in the previous
few videos so
let's suppose we have another employee
named arun and let's assume he's also a
content creator but he's a master in
javascript as well so we want to mention
it here along with all these properties
we have name id and salary which we will
inherit from this
employee constructor and apart from that
we'll add another property which is the
subject or which is the language
property
so we have to create a new constructor
here for it so what we'll do is we'll
write here
function
and then we'll write the name of
this constructor so let's say
the name is function programmer
so
we'll write here name
will pass all the properties we'll write
a name id salary
and finally we have the language right
then we have the body of the constructor
the first three properties will remain
the same right only subject or language
we have added language here so only
language will be added now we'll inherit
these properties from employ before the
concept of class was introduced
inheritance was based on prototypes only
so we'll see the concept of classes in
the upcoming video so
here what we are going to do is we are
going to call this employee
constructor so we will write here
employee
dot
call and we'll pass the properties which
we want to inherit so we'll write here
first this and
first we have to write the this keyword
and then we have to write other property
so we'll write a name id
salary what we did is we called the
function employee and asked it to
provide all the three mentioned
properties to the function programmer
we'll set the value of language by
ourselves we'll write
here this
dot language
equals to
language now if we create an object for
the constructor programmer what it will
do is it will take all the properties
from the employee and language will be
added to those properties let's do it
first so we'll
create an object here we'll write here
where let's say the object name is arun
and we'll write a new
programmer
and we'll pass the values let's say the
name is arun
id is
and cell is let's say 12 000
and finally we have to add the subject
here as well or we can say language so
let's say the language is
javascript
next thing we are going to do is we we
are going to print this on console so we
will write a console.log
and we will print around
right lets save it and see here we have
all the properties available with the
provided values we have name as arun we
have ids 4321 salary as 12 000 and
languages javascript so this is how we
can inherit the properties in the
derived constructor from the base
constructor the base constructor is the
employee and the derived is a programmer
so coming back to the console we can see
here we have all the four properties
right
three of them are inherited and the last
one was assigned by us but i don't know
if you guys noticed here that we have
the properties only of the constructor
so we don't have any method here right
so if we see here we don't have any
method of constructor
employee because here you can see we
have a method as post and if we see here
we don't have any method so
if we write here
let's say if we write here in our
console we are writing here let's say
arun dot
post
and we'll
run it so here you can see it says
arun.post is not a function
right this is because the prototype post
is not assigned to the constructor
programmer for that we have to write
some extra code we have to write here
so we have to write here
program dot prototype equals to
object
dot
create and we have to mention the
employee prototype
so we'll write here employee dot
prototype
right so save it now and here you can
see now
if we go to underscore underscore proto
we have
post as a method here
so if we write here
arun dot post
now
so here you can see it says arun is a
content creator so we have to provide
the prototypes manually as well
let me show you guys one more thing now
see here
it is not showing the constructor if we
click here on the proto we don't have
any constructor here named as
programmer
so we have to set the constructor as
well we have to set it manually and to
set the constructor manually we have to
write here after this line we have to
write here programmer dot prototype
dot
constructor
equals to program if we save this
program now and if we go back to our
console and if we check here here you
can see we have a constructor named as
programmer now
so you guys might be thinking that we
have to work a lot for all this
inheritance right the fact is we
actually had to do it before es6 was
introduced now if you want to do the
same with the help of classes the syntax
will be so easy we'll go through it in
the next video so that's all for this
video guys see you in the next one where
we will go through
classes and inheritance in javascript
let's move on and take a look at classes
in javascript
a class is nothing but a template used
for creating objects in javascript
just like the constructor function we
can also use classes for creating object
in javascript we can include properties
and behaviors in a class creating a
class is a pretty easy job to do the
syntax is somewhat the same as that of a
constructor function so let's move on to
the programming part
if you guys are coming from any other
object-oriented programming language
like we have c plus plus java php and
many more object-oriented programming
language right
so you may have an idea about classes
the syntax for classes in javascript is
also not so different from other
languages
don't worry if you are going through
classes for the first time we'll have a
look at classes so let's move on to the
syntax and to declare a class we use the
class keyword followed by the name of
the class and the body of the class so
we'll write here class so this is the
keyword we use for the declaration of a
class then we have the name of the class
so let's say we have the name as student
here
and then we use curly braces for the
body of the class so this is an empty
class
named as student we know that this
student has a name age roll number and
many more properties right
so the next thing we are going to do is
we can define the properties here only
in fact the syntax for defining
properties is also the same as we had in
the constructor function so let's define
the properties first so let's say we
have three properties here name agent
roll number so we'll write here this
dot name
is equals to name
and then we have this dot age is equals
to h
and the last property is this
dot
roll number so let's say we are
writing here role
so
equals to role
so we have all the three properties of
student
we have name age and role number so we
have to create a constructor here which
will be executed while we create an
object or we can say an instance of this
class so the syntax for creating a
constructor will go like we have to
write here constructor
and we have to pass all these three
arguments here we have to pass name
then we have age and then we have
a roll number so all these three
arguments we have to pass here and also
these properties will be kept inside
the body of this constructor
so this is the basic syntax of how we
are going to create a class in
javascript so we have all the three
properties here we have name we have age
and we have roll number if you guys
notice here the syntax for the
constructor function looks a bit similar
to the syntax of the constructor
function method which we came across in
the previous few videos right
so what we are doing is we created a
class first with the name student then
we defined all the properties of this
class inside the constructor
so by now things are going easy right
that's because the syntax for classes is
relatively easy to use compared to other
methods
also we don't have to write code
manually for different things we will
understand it much better while working
on inheritance so let's move on and we
will add some methods to this class now
the syntax for adding a method is super
simple guys we don't have to write here
a function name followed by a colon and
then we have the function keyword no
we'll just write here the function name
and parentheses so to add a method here
we'll write here let's say we are adding
a method organization so let's say we
have a method org okay so we have to
write org and
a pair of round brackets that's all this
is the syntax for defining a method in
classes so let's say we want this
function to return a string along with
the name of the student so let's say we
are writing a return
and let's say we wanted to return
i am dot name from
simply code
okay
so let's say we are passing a value here
as caution and we want this function to
return im caution from simply code
so similarly we will add another
function here
which is for the date of birth of
student so let's see we'll write here
dob
and then we have the body of the
function so we want this function to
return the date of birth of a student
right so let's say we are in the year
2020 what we want to do is we have the
age of student let's say the age is 21
and what we are going to do next is we
are going to subtract the age from
current year so 2020 minus this dot age
will return the date of birth of student
right so we'll write here
return let's say we wanted to return a
string as well let's say the date of
birth
of
this dot name
is 2020
minus
this
dot h
fine so here we are done with a string
so we want it to return the date of
birth of caution is
let's say
1999 if we are providing the value as 21
then it will return 1999 right let's
move ahead and create an object first so
let's say we have an object named as
caution and what we are going to do is
we are going to write here new
and we are going to call the class so we
will write here
student
and then we we'll pass the values here
so let's say the name is caution the age
is 21
and we have
roll number as 45 so we have all the
three properties here right
next up we are going to print this on a
console so we'll write a console.log
and we'll print caution
so let's say if it's working or not save
it and here you can see on our console
we have a student class we have all the
three values we have age is 21 name as
caution and roll number as 45. if we go
inside this underscore underscore pro 2
we can see here we have both the methods
here we have org and dub so let's try to
call these methods first so what we are
going to do is we are going to write on
our console
caution.dub
so here you can see we have the output
as the date of birth of caution is 1999.
similarly if we try to
call function caution dot
org
so you can see here we have the output
as i am caution from simply code right
so here you can see both the methods are
working fine we have both the outputs
here
the first one says the date of birth of
koshel is 1999 and the next one gives us
the
organization name so moving ahead let me
guys tell you about another concept in
classes we'll now discuss static
functions in classes
we have to use the static keyword to
define a static method followed by the
method name so if we want to define a
static method what we have to do is we
have to use the
static keyword so
the static keyword is always followed by
the name of the method so let's say we
are creating a method here let's say for
adding two numbers so we'll write here
the method name is add
and
then we have the body of this method
so what we want to do is we want to add
two numbers right so we have to pass
here two parameters as well we'll write
here a comma b
and then we want it to return the sum
right so we'll write a return
a
plus b
this looks fine right
notice here guys
we don't have to use anything from the
class or the object like in the previous
two methods we used the name and the h
property right so here we used this dot
name and then we used this dot age as
well but here this method is not related
to object at any cost
the best part about the static method is
we can use static methods without
creating the instances of a class so if
we want to access this particular method
here we can do it with the help of class
name followed by the dot operator and
the method name so let's try to access
this method once what we are going to do
is we are going to write console.log
and we are going to access this method
with the class name so we will write
here
student
dot
add and we'll pass the values here so
let's say we are passing 10 and
45 fine
so let's see if it works or not so save
it and here you can see we have the
output as 55.
so this is how we can create or use
static methods in classes
let's move on now and we will discuss
inheritance with the help of classes in
javascript by now we are clear with the
meaning of inheritance right guys
we discussed in the last video that
inheritance is the procedure through
which one class inherits the properties
and methods of another class so today we
are going to see how we can implement
inheritance with classes in javascript
although the concept will remain the
same we will create another class here
and we'll inherit the properties of this
existing class with some more properties
of the derived class i hope you guys
know the difference between base class
and derived class
so the class we are going to create now
will be the derived class so let's move
ahead and create a class
let's say we are creating a class here
so let's say
for creating a class we have to write
class let's say the class name is
student
and if we want to inherit the properties
of the above class which is student1 we
have to
use a particular syntax so we have to
write the
extents keyword here so this is a
keyword extends is a keyword which is
used for inheritance and then we will
write the name of the class which we
want to inherit so we'll write here
student
and then we have the body of the class
here we have a class student1 that
inherits the properties of class student
next up we'll create a constructor
function here and we'll pass all the
properties we want
to be there for the class student1 so
we'll pass the constructor function
similarly like we did in the previous
class so we'll write here constructor
and we'll pass all the properties we
want to be there for class student one
so we
have the first three properties are name
which we are going to inherit from the
above class
then we have h and then we have
roll number right so
let's add two more properties here let's
say the true properties are
language and then we have
section as well fine
so then we have the body of the
constructor
so you can see here we have five
properties three of these five are
inherited from class
student and the rest two are those
properties that we want to add for class
student one exclusively the syntax for
inheritance in classes is not a tough
one though still we have to keep a few
things in mind
mainly the next statement we are going
to write here is an important one it
goes like we use the super keyword
and then we'll
pass all the properties which we want to
inherit from the class in this
particular case we want to inherit these
three properties here right so we'll
copy this from here and we'll paste it
here remember one thing guys we'll write
only those properties which we want to
inherit from other class
actually this super keyword we used here
refers to the parent class we use it to
call the parent classes constructor or
we can also call particular properties
and methods with the help of super
keyword
next up we'll define the two new
properties the language and the section
now
so the syntax will remain the same we'll
write here
this dot language is equals to language
and then we'll write this dot
section
is equal to section
we are good to go now
we'll create an object for this class as
well
which is student1 so let's say we are
creating an object again
let's say the name of this object is
let's remove it first
so let's say we are creating an object
for this class now let's say the name of
this object is
arun and
we are going to write here new then we
have the class name which is
student1
and then we'll pass the values here so
let's say the name is arun
then we have the age is 35 and then we
have roll number as three or two
and then we have the language so let's
say the language is javascript and then
we finally have the section as well so
let's say the section is
a
fine so we have all the five values here
we have around 35 to javascript and a
right so let's print this on our console
we'll write here console.log and we'll
print arun
let's save it now and here you can see
we have
a student one with all the properties
and values we have ages 35 language
javascript name is arun roll number s2
and section is e if we click here on
underscore underscore proto
you can see here we have a constructor
student when along with that we have all
the methods of the previous class of the
base class we have org we have dob as
well right
so this is how inheritance work in
javascript the key benefit of using
inheritance with classes is that if we
remember from the previous video if you
want to access any base class method
then traditionally we had to manually
provide the constructor right
but in classes we don't have to do any
such thing once we are done with
inheriting the properties and all we can
directly access the methods as well
let's try to do it here on our console
so we'll write here
arun
dot
let's suppose we are using org
so we'll write arun dot org and here you
can see we have the output as i am arun
from simply code
next up let's use the other method as
well so we'll write here
arun and then we'll use
dob
so here you can see we have the date of
birth of arun is 1985 because we have
provided the value as 35 so
2020 minus 35 is 1985.
here we have the output as expected now
let's see if we can access the static
method or not by using the derived class
so we'll try to access the static method
with the help of student one so let's
try to do it we'll write here
console.log and then we'll write here
student
one dot add and we'll pass the values
let's say the values are
65 and 8
right
so we want the output as
73 now so let's see if it's working or
not so we'll save it and here you can
see we have the output is 73 so this is
a basic example of how inheritance works
with classes in javascript hope you guys
got it we have been using the
document.getelementbyid method for the
past few videos right
we know it is used to access an html
element with the help of an id which is
uniquely provided to each element
so we use that method with text boxes
then with radio buttons and then we
select boxes as well
so today we are going to use a method
that is somewhat similar to
document.getelementbyid method
so we'll be using the
document.getelementsbytagname method in
javascript
as the name suggests this method is used
to access a bunch of similar elements
with the same tag so we have tag name in
our method right so we can access a
bunch of tags with similar name like if
we have a few div tags present in our
program and we want to change each div
text style
we can do it with the help of this
method
so we'll look at the syntax first and
then we'll move on to the difference
between id and tag name method
so let's move on to the programming part
directly what we'll do is we'll create a
few div tags first and then we'll change
the style of these div tags with
specific styling properties we are not
going to use css for that but in
javascript we have other styling
properties as well so we'll be using
those styling properties so let's create
the div text first
we'll write here div
and then let's say we are
writing it this is section
one so we'll copy this line
and we'll create four similar div tags
right
we have section one two three and
four
save it and you can see over here we
have four different sections present
now this is a very basic example and
here we have different sections present
right next up we'll try to access these
div tags with the help of tag name
method so let's add a button over here
and then we'll move on to the javascript
part
so we'll
write here
let's use the br tag and we'll write
here
input tag again we'll write an input
type is equals to
button and we'll use the on click method
as well so we'll write here on click
and let's say our function name is
fun2
and then we have the
value of this button as let's say submit
close the input tag and save it so here
you can see we have a button over here
submit button and you can see here
nothing is happening on clicking on the
submit button
so next up what we are going to do is we
are going to add functionality to this
submit button for that we have to move
to our javascript file and we have to
create a function over there
so we'll write here
in the javascript file we'll write here
function
fun2 and then we have the body of this
function right so the syntax is a bit
similar to that of the
document.getelementbyid method what
we'll do is we'll take a variable x and
then we'll write here
document dot
get elements by tag name and then we'll
write inside the brackets the name of
tag we want to access right so here we
have added four different div tags so
in this case we'll write here div and we
can similarly access any of the tags
present in a html document we can access
paragraph tags we can access anchor text
and any tag we want to basically
so
save it and here now we have a variable
x that holds an html collection of all
the div text present inside the html
file
this means that we have an array of
references of all the div tags here
inside this variable x
so if we try to make changes in a single
array element just like we did in the
select box example wherein we use the
array index to access a particular
element present at a particular array
index right so we can do the same here
we'll write here x and then we'll write
the
index number so this particular
statement will access the element
present at number one
or this particular syntax will access
the
first div tag of html document because
we know arrays start from 0
and at 0 the first element will be
present so this div tag will be present
at number 0
and then we are going to use the style
property so we know that
x here is not a variable only actually x
here acts as an object and we know that
different objects have certain
properties in javascript so style is one
of those properties and next up we'll
write here
let's say
font family so what we are doing is we
are doing the css part with properties
present in javascript so let's say we
are changing our font to
courier new
all right so this is a font name
and we can use any font name over here
so save it what will happen now is on
clicking the submit button
the font of this particular section the
font of div 1 will change to courier new
so let's try if it's happening or not on
clicking the submit button you can see
over here the change between this line
and other three div tags clearly the
font has changed the new font is courier
new and what we did here is we changed
the font family of this particular div
tag so similarly we can make more
styling changes to other div tags as
well so let's do it here
and we'll
make changes to each of the div tags we
have in a html file so let's say
here we are using the color property and
we want to change the font color to
blue
fine then we'll do the same for element
present at number three for that we'll
write here x and the index number will
be 2
so then again we'll use the style
property and then
let's say we are writing a
font
style
fine and the font style we want it to be
italic
and then finally we have one more
property
let's say for a
for the repeat so let's say for the last
div tag we are using the background
color
fine and we'll write here the color name
is
red
so we are good to go now save it and we
have four different properties over here
for section four we are changing the
background color so
3 will be the index number of the last
array variable so save it and on
pressing the submit button you can see
the change over here so for section 1
the font is changed to courier new for
section 2 the font color is blue let me
zoom it out a bit to show you guys you
can see over here the color is blue
and then we have italic text in section
3 and finally for section 4 we have the
background color as 4 right so you can
see how we are accessing any particular
element of the array now
why we are using these properties
separately for each array element
so if we try to make changes on each
element of the array we simply can't do
it in javascript at once so if we try to
write here so let's comment this out
first what we'll do is we'll write a x
dot style dot font family so basically
what we want to do is we want to change
the font family for all the div tags
present right because we know the
variable x is holding an array of all
the div text present in our html file
right so we'll save it and you can see
over here if we are clicking on the
submit button you can see nothing is
happening so if we go to our console
and you can see it over here that we
have an error here so it says it cannot
set property font family of undefined so
this is the problem with this get
elements by tag name method
to overcome this problem we have a
solution as well so the solution for
this problem is we have to use the for
loop
so how this for loop works
so we'll write here
and then we'll take a local variable i
and the initial value will be 0
then we'll write a i
less than
x dot length because we want to traverse
the whole array right and then we'll
write here the condition
i plus plus
so we are good to go then we have this
body of for loop and inside here we'll
write x and the index number will be i
because it will keep on changing and we
are in a loop
so
we'll write here dot style and then
let's say the style we want to
do is font
weight and what we want to do is we want
to make our font
bolder
fine
so comment this line as well save it now
and you can see over here everything is
clean now what will happen is on
pressing the submit button the font will
change the font weight will change
basically so let me zoom this
and if we click on this submit button
you can see the font is more bolder
right
so if we are using another property here
let's say the font
we are using here
background color and we want the
background color to be yellow
fine so save it and on clicking the
submit button you can see the background
color for all the div text for all the
four section is changed to yellow fine
so this is how we can access all the
elements of an array at once
now what we did is we started a loop and
traversed every element in the array and
applied the same property to each
element
so this is how we can do it with the
help of
tag name method in javascript now what
if we have hundreds of similar elements
like div tag present in our website and
all of them are present at different
locations so let's try to do it and what
we'll do is we'll insert certain
different elements in between these div
tags
fine so we'll include a form and then
we'll include some radio buttons and
anything we want to do we can do it so
we'll add some more elements in between
these div tags
so here you can see we have inserted two
three more elements in between these div
tags so save it and you can see after
each section we have something else here
we have a form with
two different text boxes we have name
and age and then we have a submit button
as well
then after that we have section two so
this is our section two
then after section two we have radio
button and the value is a then we have
another radio button b
and in between we have all the dev text
present so basically what we want to do
is we want to change the style for each
of the div tags right
so we will change the background color
here so let's say we'll write here red
and what will happen is on clicking the
submit button on clicking this submit
button what will happen is the
background color of each div tag
so the background color for section 1 2
3 and 4 will change to red so let's try
to do it and let's see if it's
working or not so we'll click on the
submit button and you can see it over
here we have all the div tags with
background color as
red so this is working totally fine
one more thing we'll discuss before
wrapping up this video is the uniqueness
of id attribute for each element so we
are saying this for a long time that the
id for each element should be unique why
so although we saw in the past videos
that we can use the same id for two
different elements when we did the same
for accessing a css styling property
using the id attribute but if we try to
do the same thing with javascript we'll
get an error for example if we try to
access the value of any particular
element with the id attribute but we
have two elements in a html file with
the same id so it will throw an error in
that case basically and this is the
reason why we use the tag name method in
javascript so that if we want to access
multiple elements of the same name we
can do it with this method because it's
not possible to use the id method
separately for each element present in
the html document right
because we have certain same html tags
present within an html document like we
have the div tags here similarly a
website is long enough to have multiple
similar elements present within it so
that's why we use the
document.getelementsbytagname method in
javascript so guys in the past few
videos we use two different methods of
accessing an element from an html file
using javascript properties so we know
the difference between the id method and
the tag name method right today we will
use another method to access a
particular element in javascript that is
the class name method or we can say the
get elements by class name method in
javascript so before discussing the
class name method in javascript let's
look at why accessing an element is
important in javascript
so we know that the document object
model is used to change
add or delete html elements we saw
earlier that we could change html
elements or the css style of any element
in the document with the help of
javascript properties
so to make specific changes to those
elements we need to access them using
particular methods so we discussed two
such methods before the id method and
the tag name method right so let's move
ahead and look at the class name method
of accessing an element in javascript as
the name suggests the main attribute in
this method will be the class name so we
know the difference between the class
and the id attribute used in html
we know that id has to be unique for
each element but we know that many
elements in an html document can have
the same class right so we used class to
access specific css properties in the
previous videos
and that is the only benefit of using
classes in javascript so we can say that
used by many elements within an html
document so let's dig a bit deeper into
this concept so let's say we have five
elements present on our website and we
want to make changes in three of these
elements right so let's write the code
here and it will be easier for you guys
to understand so
we'll write here in the html file we'll
add five different
elements
so let's say we are writing here
div and
then inside this div we'll write
this is
section one
we'll copy this
we'll paste it here
so we'll use two div elements and two
paragraph element right so here in this
p tag we'll write
this is
section three
and then we'll copy this line paste it
again copy this one as well and paste it
here
so we have section one section two three
four and
five
so out of these five different elements
we have three div tags and we have two
paragraph text so we'll discuss why we
have taken two paragraph text in between
the
div tags
so we are done with it here you can see
we have five elements present in a html
document three of them are the div text
section one two and five are div text
and two texts in between are the
paragraph tags so now
let's suppose we want to change the
style of three of these elements let's
say one four and five so we can do it in
two ways right either we can use the id
method or we can use the class method
however we can use the tag name method
as well but we have to use two different
variables for that right that will be a
lengthy process why two different
variables because we have two different
tags present here right we have to
create separate variable for the div tag
and separate one for the paragraph text
so that will be a lengthy process so
we'll consider id method and the class
name method for here
so considering the id method the
document.getelementbyid method we have
to provide a unique id to each element
so we have to provide unique id to this
div tag then we have to provide to each
in every element here right because we
need to access
three of these elements so at least we
have to provide the id to those three
elements which we want to access right
so in such cases we can use the class
name method where we want to access more
than one element but not all the
elements in an html file
so we'll use the class attribute in each
element we want to access
so let's say we want to access section 1
2 and five
so we'll write a class let's say the
class name is cls1
we'll copy this paste it here and we are
accessing one two and four because one
two and five are
the div text so we can access these with
the help of tag name method as well so
we'll access
one two and four
fine so we have used the class attribute
here
next up we'll create a button and then
we'll add functionality to a html
document so let's create a button here
we'll again use input type is equals to
button and then we have
on click
and on clicking it will call
funcon
and then we have the value as
submit fine
so save it
and here you can see
in the browser we have five sections
over here we have section one two three
four and five then we have a submit
button which will call the function on
clicking so we haven't added
functionality till now so let's move
ahead to our javascript file and we'll
add functionality to our
html document
so inside this javascript file we'll
write here
function and then we have the function
name is
function
then we have the body of this function
so the syntax remains a bit same
so we'll take a variable first and then
we'll use the document method to take
references of all the elements from a
html file
so we'll write here
where x is equals to
document dot
get elements by
class name right and then we'll write
the class name here so the class name is
cls1
till now what we did was we took the
references of all the required elements
and stored them inside a variable named
x in the form of an html collection
so now we can make changes to these
elements and what we'll do is we'll
again use the style property to make
styling changes in those three sections
so we have these three sections present
inside an array and we can access any
one or all the three elements right so
we'll write here x and then we'll
provide the index number so let's say we
want to access section one that is the
first div tag so we'll provide the index
number as 0
then we'll write dot
tile
and this style is a property dot
then let's say we want
to
change the font style so we'll write
here
font
style
font style will be
italic
save it so this piece of code will
change the font style of the element
present at index 0. save it and on
clicking the submit button here on the
browser
we can see the change in this section
right so if it's not visible so let me
zoom it a bit for you here you can see
guys the font at section 1 is changed to
italic right
so in this case we have all the three
elements present in a array and we can
make changes to each of these elements
so let's try to do it and we'll use
element present at index 1 now we'll
copy this line and we'll paste it here
again two times because we want to make
changes to all the elements right we'll
write it two and we'll write here one
and let's say
we want to change the font color for
this one and the font color will be blue
for this we'll change the font weight
let's say
and we want to make it
bolder
so we'll write your bolder
save it and on clicking the submit
button you can see we have all the three
sections with some minor changes the
first one is changed and we have italic
over here for the second one we have
blue color as font color and for the
third one which is section four we have
the
font weight as bolder so you can see the
change over here so this is how we can
make change to each element separately
and we can also make changes in all the
elements at once as well so for that we
have to use the for loop
just like we did for the tag name method
right
so for that we'll write here so let's
comment these three statements first
and then we'll write here
for and
we'll take a local variable here we'll
write you where
i is equals to 0 i will start from index
and i will go till
x dot
length
and then we have the condition is i plus
plus
so inside the body of for loop we'll
write here
x and instead of index number we'll
write here i because we want to traverse
the whole array then we'll write here
style
dot
and let's say the style we want is
background color
we want the background color to be let's
say
yellow
fine
so this is how we can use the for loop
save it and we'll see on clicking the
submit button on our browser
the background color for all the three
sections that is 1 2 and 4 is changed to
yellow
this is how we can use the
document.getelementsbyclassname method
to access all the elements present in an
html file with a particular class next
up let's discuss the difference between
the id method tag name method and the
class name method
so we'll discuss when to use which
method so
let's start with the id method so the id
method is used when we want to access a
single element and we have to provide a
unique id to that element in order to
access it so the id method is quite
useful when we want to work on a single
element
apart from that if we want to work on
more than one element we have two other
methods
we can either use the class name method
or the tag name method for more than one
element
so the tag name method is also quite
useful when we want to access elements
with the same tag name
we can access all the similar tags
present within an html document with the
help of tag name method the only problem
is we can access similar types of tags
only at one time we can't access two
different types of tags with this method
so this is where the class name method
comes into play we can access more than
one element with this method and the
elements can be different just like we
did here we had
div tag and paragraph tag right so
the section 1 2 and 5 are from div text
and the section 4 and 3 are from the
paragraph text so we can access two
different tags with same class name with
the help of class name method in
javascript so with this we came to the
conclusion that more than one element in
the html file can have the same class
and can be accessed with the class name
method functions in javascript are a
block of code that is used to perform a
specific task we use functions for
different purposes right whether it be a
button click or we want to zoom out our
image by taking the mouse cursor over it
we use functions for all these tasks
in javascript we can use functions as
objects at the same time we can pass
objects to functions as parameters right
so similarly we can also pass a function
inside another function
if i take you through the programming
part of this concept the syntax will be
like we'll go to a javascript file and
the syntax will be like will
declare a function let's say the
function is function abc then here we'll
pass a parameter let's say we are
passing call as parameter for this
function abc next up what we'll do is
we'll call this function inside this
function abc now what we did here is
really simple we created a function abc
right next up we passed a function
called as a parameter to this function
and then we also called this function
inside the function abc so this syntax
is valid in javascript and also this
particular code here is known as the
callback function in javascript so if we
talk about the definition of callback
function it states that a callback
function is a function that is passed to
another function as an argument
and that particular function will get
executed later in the program
now you guys might have heard in the
previous videos that javascript is a
single threaded language or javascript
works over a single statement at a time
or we can say javascript works in a
particular top to bottom order
so if we talk about the sequence in
which javascript actually works while
coding so let's take an example for this
and we'll see the sequence in which
javascript will work so what we'll do is
we'll comment this code and we'll start
writing our new code here so let's
suppose we have three functions in a
single program so let's say we have a
function as function1
and then we have two more functions so
let's say the second function is
function 2
and then we have
function
3 as well
now if we write something inside these
functions so
we'll execute the program and what will
happen is all the three functions will
be executed sequentially so let's try to
do it first
so what we'll do is we'll
right here inside the body of function
one so let's say we are using console
dot
log and
inside this will print
function one on calling this particular
function
so we'll do the same for other two
functions as well so we'll copy it from
here
we'll paste it here and here as well so
for function 2 it will print function
and for function 3 it will print
function 3.
so let's save it and before checking the
output so what we'll do is we'll call
these functions as well so let's say we
are calling function 1 then function
and then finally function
right everything we have done till now
is quite understandable and we have
three functions here and all the three
functions will get executed in the
sequence in which we call them so here
in this case we have called function
followed by function two and function
three
so let's check the output
save it and we'll open the console in
the browser so we'll right click here go
to inspect elements and here you can see
we have a console here so here you can
see we have the output as function one
function two and function three so we
have the output in sequence we call
function one first so we have the output
as function one but if we call function
three before function two
so we'll cut this from here and we'll
paste function two after function three
save it and here you can see we have the
output as function one then function
three and then function two
so javascript will execute these
functions in the order in which we call
them right now what if we use the
settimeout function with function1 so
let's try to do it first
so instead of calling function1 alone
here we'll write here set
timeout then we have to pass two
parameters here one is the function name
so one is the function name here
and we'll write here the time so time
here will be in milliseconds so 2000
milliseconds here represents two seconds
this means that the function will be
called after two seconds
right
so
this set timeout function will call
function one after a specific period of
time that is in this case two seconds
what will happen is javascript will
start executing all the functions and
the system will find out that there is a
timer with function1 so in this case the
system will leave this particular
function on execution and will move
ahead and execute other function so
function one will be executed
automatically after two seconds
so let's check the output
save it and you can see here we have
function three and two over here and
function one will be executed after some
time so i hope you guys got this and
here we have used the set timeout method
and function one will be executed after
two seconds
now let's consider a scenario where we
have only two functions let's say we
have function one and function two
so let's remove this function 3
and we are left with only 2 functions so
let's say we have function 1 and
function 2 now
now what we want is we want to execute
these two functions but we have certain
conditions
so the first condition is function1 will
use the settimeout method and it will be
executed after 3 seconds
and the second condition is function2
will get executed only after function1
executes so till now what we have seen
is if we are using these two functions
and if we are using the settimeout
method with function1 what is happening
is
javascript will keep this function on
execution and it will execute this
function till then so what we want is we
want to execute function 2 only after
the execution of function 1. this is
where the concept of callback functions
comes into play so we have to ask the
computer to execute function2 only after
function1 is done
so let me write the same code in another
way we'll use the settimeout method
within function1 so what we have to do
is we have to change
it here
to one we'll call function one from here
and inside this function one what we'll
do is we'll write here set
timeout then we'll pass the first
argument as function and then inside the
body of this function we'll write this
console log
fine and we have to pass two parameters
here right so the next parameter will be
in the time so time here will be
3000 seconds so here we are and we are
done with our set timeout function now
this is another way of using the set
timeout method in javascript so what we
did here is we have passed the function
here as an argument and then we have the
body of function1 inside the set timeout
function
what we want to do next is we want to
execute function2 once function1 is
completed so before that let's do one
thing let's check if it is working fine
or not so we'll save it
and here you can see we have function
two executed before function one right
so it's working totally fine now what we
want to do is we want function two to
execute only after function one is done
right so let me tell you a shortcut for
that guys
it's not callback functions but it's
kind of same thing it will do the same
thing as the callback functions but it
is a different concept
so what we have to do is we have to cut
this function 2 from here
and we have to call this function inside
here
inside the set timeout method
so we'll paste it here and we have to
call function2 inside the settimeout
method so save it
and now if we wait for three seconds and
here you can see we have both the
functions function one and two executed
on time so both the functions are
executed after three seconds
and this is not callback functions but
this is a shortcut for that what
happened here is
when function1 is being executed the
system came to know that the function2
is called inside the settimeout method
so what will happen is it will first
execute the set timeout method and then
it will execute the function 2.
so what we did just now is not callback
functions but the functioning of a
callback function is also the same this
is the same thing we will do with
callback functions but the syntax will
be different
now
by the definition of the callback
function that we came across earlier it
states that a callback function is a
function that is passed to another
function as an argument so keep your
focus on this word argument and that
particular function will be executed
later that function which we passed as
argument will be executed later
so here in this definition later means
once the system is done with the first
function or we can say the primary
function
it is now free to perform function 2 or
the secondary function or the callback
function we can say
so we have kept it on hold till now so
let's take an example of that as well
what we'll do is we'll create a function
and we'll pass an argument inside this
function
the value will be provided while calling
the function so
let's do one thing first let's comment
this code
and will write a new code here
so we'll create a function let's say a
function is function
person and we'll pass an argument here
so let's say the argument is friend
fine
next up we'll work on the body of this
function what we'll do is we'll again
use
console.log
and we'll print something so let's say
we'll
write here
my
friend's name is
and then we'll use the plus operator
with the
value of friend
so we'll write your friend
and with this we are done with our
function person next up what we'll do is
we'll write here
function
person
2 and we don't have to pass any argument
here so inside the body of this function
will again use console.log and we'll
write here
my
name is
caution
fine
so
next up what we have to do is we have to
call these functions right so we'll
write a person
and inside this we have to pass the
value so let's say the value here is
simply code that's fine next up we'll
call person2
and will save this program so on saving
this program you can see we have the
output as my friend's name is simply
code so if you want me to zoom it you
can see here now
here it says my friend's name is simply
code and the second function says my
name is caution
right so this program is working totally
fine this is a basic program wherein we
created two function
and now what we want to do is we want
the function person
will get executed after function person
so for that we have to pass function2 as
an argument in the function person
so
we'll change the code
we'll pass this
function person2 as an argument so we'll
write here
person 2. we don't have to use brackets
here so because we are passing it as an
argument
now
we did it we passed this function as an
argument the next step is to tell the
function person about it right
we have to pass another argument in the
function so
we have to tell this first function that
we also have another function which will
get executed after this particular
function
so we'll write here
we can use any name we can use another
name for that or we can use the same
name as of function person2 so we'll
write here
person2
and then what we have to do is we have
to call this person2 function after this
right
now we are done with this code now we
are done with a callback function here
in this case this function person2 is
known as the callback function
so save it now
and
okay
what we have to do is we have to remove
this line from here so save it now here
you can see we have the output totally
correct we have the output as my
friend's name is simply code and my name
is caution
now we are done with almost everything
we are done with the callback functions
but
you might not see any change in the
output right to witness the change what
we have to do is we have to use the set
timeout method again because we want
this function to execute only after
function person so what we have to do is
we have to write here
inside function person we will write
here set
timeout and
then we have
to write your function
and then
inside the body we'll do the same we'll
cut these two brackets from here and
we'll paste them here and inside here we
have to write the time so let's say the
time is
3 000 fine
now what we did is we use the set
timeout method with function person and
inside the body it will print my
friend's name is and the friend's name
is simply good and it will be executed
after three seconds right
so let's save it and we'll count for
three one two and three so here is the
code you can see here the output says my
friend's name is simply code
and my name is caution so
this is working totally fine
so this is how the concept of callback
functions in javascript works the word
promise seems a bit familiar we make
promises regularly right if i say i
promise you that will cover everything
on promises in this video now this
promise that i made can only have two
possible outcomes either the promise
will be fulfilled or resolved or we can
say the promise can be failed or
rejected the promise will be resolved if
we'll cover everything on promises in
this video but if i left out some topic
or there is any subtopic within promises
which we forgot to cover in this video
that will be a failed promise or we can
say a rejected one
now there is another term in between
these terms that is pending pending is
the time in which the system works on
the promise
so just remember these terms as you may
hear them during an interview so let's
move on talking about a proper
definition of promises we can say that a
promise is an object which will produce
value sometimes it either gives us a
value or an error with the proper reason
there is no specific definition for
promises in javascript you will
understand the topic much better while
working on the syntax
so let's move ahead and we'll go through
a simple example first to understand
a promise in javascript
as we mentioned earlier that a promise
is an object so what we have to do first
is to take a variable and declare an
object so for that we'll go to a
javascript file and we'll write here
we'll take a variable let's say a
variable name is prom and we'll write
here new
promise so this statement here is a
promise we have an object named prom
next up this promise will take a
callback function we have already
discussed the concept of callback
functions in the previous video so if
you haven't watched that video yet i
recommend you to watch it so a callback
function is a function passed to another
function as an argument remember so
we'll write here
inside this
object we'll write here
function
and now this callback function here will
have two arguments one to resolve and
another for the reject that's because we
can have only two possibilities in a
promised right either it can be rejected
or it can be resolved so we'll write
here
resolve and then after a comma we'll
write here reject fine then we'll have
the body of this function
so this is how
a promise will look like you can change
the name of these arguments instead of
resolve or reject you can write here
anything but we have kept it simple for
now so that it will be easy to
understand next up let's use a simple
condition here let's take the example of
driving a car fine
what we'll do is we'll take a variable
drive
and will check if the user learned how
to drive a car if yes then the promise
is fulfilled otherwise the promise is
rejected
so let's do it here we'll write here
where
drive and let's set the value of this
drive as true for now let's say the user
learned how to drive a car
so next up what we'll do is we'll use
the if else conditional statement to
call any one of the two functions we can
either call resolve or reject right so
we'll write here if
and the condition will be
drive so if we left it with drive here
it will check for if drive is equals to
true right so we'll call the function
resolve if the condition holds true
and then we'll use the else statement
for else we'll write it else and then
we'll write here
reject
fine
any value other than true will call the
reject function here so what we did here
was an easy task we know that the value
for the variable drive is true so in
this case the resolve function will be
called if we set this value of variable
drive to false then the function reject
will be called
the next part of the program is to
execute this promise so this will be the
longer part as we have to use two
methods here so for that the syntax will
start with the promise name and then
we'll use the dot operator so let me do
it here we'll write here
prompt and then we'll use the dot
operator
next up we'll use the then keyword so
this then keyword or it is a method
actually
it is called when the method is resolved
or when the promise is resolved so we
have another method for the rejection of
promises that we'll discuss afterwards
so we'll write here
prompt dot then
now this is a method so we will use
brackets here
when this method is called it means that
the promise is resolved we'll use a
callback function within this method so
we'll write here
function and
then we'll use
the resolve function here so we'll write
here
resolve fine
and then we'll have the body for resolve
so
this is how the execution will look like
for promises
and on filling the promise there will be
a statement printed on the console
so it will be like we'll write here
console.log and we'll write here
something so let's say we are writing
here
resolve
and
let's say
the user
knows how to
drive fine so we'll write here this
now we are done with the part in which
the promise will be fulfilled one thing
i forgot to mention here is we have to
pass
this resolve here so whatever value
we'll write here will be shown in
console so let's say we are writing here
for true value we'll write here yes
fine now if we save this program and
check for the output we'll get the
output as yes the user knows how to
drive we can check it so let's save it
and here you can see in the console we
have the output as yes the user knows
how to type let me put a space here so
let's save it now now it's clearly
visible so it says yes the user knows
how to try
so this is working fine now the next
part will be for the condition if the
promise gets rejected so just like we
had
the then method for resolving the
promise similarly we have one more
method for the rejection part
so for the rejection part we have the
catch method so we have to change this
method here only after the then method
so we'll come here and we'll write dot
catch
and the rest of the syntax will remain
same so we'll write here function
and then we'll
call
reject
then we'll have the body of this reject
part and we'll write here inside this
console.log
and we'll write here reject
plus
the user
does not
know
how
to drive
fine the catch method uses the reject
function and the output will be no the
user does not know how to drive
so before that we'll have to pass an
argument here so we'll write here
no
and save it now so for now it says yes
the user knows how to drive
to check for the reject method we have
to set the value of variable drive as
false so let's change the value here
let's say we are using
false here now save it and you can see
here the output says no the user does
not know how to drive fine so this is
working totally fine now you guys might
be thinking that this program we just
did is so easy we could have done it
with if else conditional statements then
why are we using promises for this the
syntax is extended and we have to
remember a lot of terms and methods for
a promise right
the good part is this was just an
example to make you understand the
syntax of promises in javascript
next up we'll go through an example
wherein we'll discuss the dependency of
promises as well so let's move ahead and
in this example what we'll do is we'll
create three separate functions let's
suppose we want to learn promises in
javascript
but for that we must know about the
concept of functions and callback
functions in javascript then only we can
go through promises so what we'll do is
we'll create three functions in which
the current function will depend upon
the previous function if the user knows
about functions he can go through
callback functions and if the user knows
both functions and callback functions he
is good to go for promises
so let me take you through the code guys
so here is the code we have three
functions the first one is for functions
topic so this functions is the topic
similarly we have callback and promises
as well so the first function is for the
functions topic
and
if the user is done with functions in
javascript then he can move on to
callback functions and then to promises
so we have three different promises for
each function right so each function
here like the first function returns a
promise
right similarly all the three functions
are returning a promise here we are
directly resolving it we don't need to
wait for the user to learn functions
completely otherwise we can use here the
reject function as well for now we are
just resolving it which means that the
user learned functions in javascript
already the same goes for callback
functions and promises as well
next up what we have to do is we have to
execute the promise that once the user
is done with functions he can move on to
callback functions and then to promises
so for that we have to execute promise
like this only
but the syntax will be different so let
me show you guys
so here is the code for that as well
what we did here is we use the first
function here
so functions is our first function and
on resolving we call the function
callback with the result and we did the
same thing again for a callback on
resolving the callback function it will
call the promises function and finally
it will print this good to go message on
the console with the previous messages
returned by the resolve method
so we are basically working on the
dependency of promises in javascript
now let's save this program and we'll
check the output on the console so
save it and here you can see it on the
console it says
good to go and then it says learned
functions learnt callback functions good
to go for promises in javascript
now this same program can be done with
the help of callback functions as well
but the code will be so confusing
because we have to nest all these
functions inside a single function and
then it will be a mess right the code
with promises is clean you can see here
the code is clean all we had to do here
was to create functions then return
promises on call and then we can execute
those promises with their dependency
so this is how promises in javascript
actually works now we have been using
functions in almost every video since we
came across this topic
whether it be
dom manipulation or using an event in
javascript functions are everywhere
right
so this concept of arrow functions
is just a change in the syntax of
declaring and defining a function
so let's go through the concept of
functions in javascript quickly so that
it will be easy to change the syntax
later what we'll do is we'll create a
function with multiple parameters and
then we'll create another function with
no parameter at all
so we know these concepts already so
let's write the code here
so we'll go to a javascript file
and we'll write code here so we'll write
your function
let's say the function name is
function
and then this function have two
parameters a and b
now this function will return something
so we'll write here return
let's say this returns a plus
b
fine now the code we wrote here is to
find the sum of two numbers right we'll
pass the two numbers as arguments while
calling the function so let's check on
the console once if the code is working
fine or not so we'll save it
back to the browser go to inspect
and then we'll go to a console and we'll
write here
function name and then we'll pass
certain parameters right so let's say
the parameters we are passing are 15 and
so the output we are expecting is 40 and
the output is correct we have the output
as 40. you can see here we have the
output as 40 here
so this function is working totally fine
next up we'll create another function
first and then we'll move to the arrow
function syntax so for the second
function we'll write a
function let's say the function name is
funct2
and this function will have no
parameters at all right so let's say
this function prints something on the
console right so we'll write a
console.log and then
let's say this
function prints
welcome
to simply code
we are done with it so let's do one
thing we will call this function here
we'll write a function calling the
function is pretty easy we can do the
same thing here as well
so
let's save it and check the output here
you can see we have the output as
welcome to simply code in our console
so this is how we were using functions
till now the simple syntax for functions
right so let's move on to the concept of
arrow functions
now this function over here has two
parameters right this function has
parameters a
and b
and what we'll do is we'll change the
syntax of this function and the new
syntax will be more simple once you get
used to it so let's write the newer
syntax just below the previous one we
don't need the function keyword with
arrow functions so all we have to do is
we have to take a variable so let's do
it first so let's say we have a variable
where
arrow one fine so this is a variable
this statement is simple we have a
variable named arrow
and this will be the function name so
arrow one will be the function name as
well right when we use the function
keyword in traditional syntax of
functions it automatically creates a
variable with the function name here we
have to declare the variable by
ourselves next up we have two parameters
here a and b as you can see here we have
a and b
we'll write the parameters within
parenthesis now so what we have to do is
we have to write
parameters so let's say the parameters
are a and b for this function as well
so these are the parameters we have to
write them within parenthesis
now we'll use an arrow that actually
makes this variable a function now this
is the main concept to create an arrow
what we have to do is we have to write
equals to and
then we have to write this so this is
the arrow mark which makes this whole
statement a function
and then we'll write the body of the
function so the body of function will
remain same so we'll copy the body from
here
and we'll paste it here so this function
here this function arrow one here is the
same as function func one and the output
will be the same
this arrow function here has only one
line here so the advantage provided by
arrow functions in this case is quite
help
what we can do is we can make this
function up one line if we remove this
return keyword and the curly braces here
so we can remove these curly braces as
well what we have to do is we have to
make this function a one liner right so
there will be no difference now so this
is how the arrow function for this
traditional function looks like now both
the functions will return the sum of two
numbers the only difference is in syntax
let's check the output for the arrow
function as well so what we'll do here
is
we'll save this program and we'll
go to a console so let's do one thing
we'll call func one first and the
parameters let's say are
5 and 15
and then we'll call the arrow function
with the same parameters so we'll write
a arrow
comma 15.
now
we have the output as 20 in both the
cases right so these two functions are
working similarly these two functions
are same the only difference is in the
syntax
next up we have another simple function
here and what we want to do here is to
convert this traditional function into
an arrow function right now we are
talking about function function so let
me
comment this first function here what
we'll do is we'll command this and now
we are good to go
so we have function functo here now what
we'll do is we'll create an arrow
function for this function
so we'll write here
let's say we are writing here where
arrow two
and then we have no parameters so empty
parenthesis and then we have the arrow
operator so the body will remain the
same we'll copy the body from this
function
and we'll paste it here
now we have used empty parentheses here
because we don't have any arguments here
let's try to run this code we'll call
the function here only so
for this we have to write here
arrow two and we are good to so save it
and the output we are expecting is
welcome to simply code twice because we
are calling funct2 as well right so save
it
and here you can see the output is
welcome to simply code let's change
something here so what we'll do is for
arrow function we'll write here
simply learn
fine
so save it now and here you can see we
have the output as welcome to simply
code and welcome to simply learn let me
zoom it for you if it's not visible so
here you can see the first output for
func 2 it says welcome to simply code
and for arrow 2 it says welcome to
simply learn
that's working fine
now before we wrap up this video let me
tell you another benefit of using arrow
functions so we already discussed that
we don't need to use the return keyword
if we are writing a one liner function
similarly if we have a single parameter
we don't need any parenthesis we'll
create another function here so let's
say we are writing here
where
arrow 3
and let's say it has only a single
parameter as new name
fine
then we'll
use the arrow operator and then inside
the body of this we'll write here
console.log
and then we'll write here
here there
plus the name provided by us in the
argument so
now we are good to go this function here
will give us the output as hey there and
then whatever name will pass while
calling the function so let's check it
let's call this function as well so
let's say
we are writing here arrow 3 and
the name let's say will be
caution
save it and here you can see it says hey
there caution for arrow function 3 so
this is also working fine
and i hope you guys are now clear with
the arrow functions in javascript it's
not essential to use arrow functions
everywhere but now that we are clear
with promises and callback functions it
will be good to write minimum code and
the arrow function will help you with
that if you guys remember when we came
across callback functions in javascript
we use the function there that we said
will call the function after 2 seconds
or 3 seconds you might have guessed that
we are talking about the set timeout
method so this set timeout method is
actually a predefined function in
javascript that does some task after a
particular interval of time
if we say we want a function to be
called after 5 seconds when the user
presses a button so we'll use this
settimeout method and the function will
be called after five seconds of the user
pressing the button
so it will be more clear to you guys
when we go through the programming part
so let's move on to the programming part
directly and we'll create a simple
button first
and then on clicking that button a
pop-up will appear on the screen with
the message after some time so we'll
create a button first
so for that we'll write here in a html
file we'll use the button tag again
we'll write here button and let's say
the button name is click me
fine save it and here we have the button
on a browser
so we have created a button here this
was simple
next up we want this button to call a
function on clicking so what we'll do
next is we'll use the on click method
within this button tag and then we'll
define the function in javascript file
so let's do it
we'll write here
on click and
we want this button to call a function
let's say the function name is start
so what will happen is the function
start will be called on clicking this
button so let's move on to a javascript
file and we'll declare some functions
here
so we'll create a function here that
will print some message on a pop-up not
the start function but a different one
so we'll write here
where message
and then we'll use the syntax for arrow
functions so we'll write here
alert
and inside this will write
welcome to
simply code so this is a message
save it
we have created an arrow function here
just to remind you guys of the syntax
for arrow functions so this function
will print this message with a pop-up
we can check it we have to go to a
console
and we'll write here
message and call this function so here
we have a pop-up with message welcome to
simply good so this function is working
totally fine the real work starts now
what we'll do next is we'll define the
function start with the set timeout
method for that we'll write here
function
start
and then inside the body of this start
function we'll call the settimeout
method and we'll pass two arguments here
so the first one is
the function name and the other one is
the time interval
so this is how we basically use the
settimeout method in javascript this is
the syntax so let's check the output now
and then we'll see another syntax for
the same program
so save it
and we'll go to the browser click on
this button and the popup will appear
after two seconds so here's the pop-up
with the message welcome to simply code
so this is working fine
now this syntax here is for the
understanding purpose
the following syntax will go through
will let you know another concept of
anonymous functions in javascript
so for the newer syntax we'll write here
will comment this piece of code
and we'll write here
function and the function name is start
then inside the body of this function
we'll use the settimeout method
and we'll write here
function this function is an anonymous
function
then we have the body of this function
and the time
so here we have written 2000
and inside the body we'll write here
alert
and let's say the message it will print
is
welcome
back
if you see this function here you can
see that we have used the function
keyword instead of passing another
function this concept here is known as
anonymous functions in javascript
basically an anonymous function is a
function without a name
we often use this function as arguments
to other function and this syntax will
call the start function after two
seconds
so this function here will work as the
previous one these two functions are the
same
it will also print the same message
after two seconds it will print welcome
back after two seconds save it and click
on the button you can see here we have
the pop-up on the screen after two
seconds
so this function is working fine the
syntax are different but the working is
same
now let's go through another method the
next method is used to stop the timer in
between
so we'll use the first function we
created here for this purpose we'll
comment this piece of code and we'll use
this syntax only
now the next method we are going to
discuss about is the clear timeout
method
let's say we want to call this function
after five seconds and suddenly in
between we realize that we don't want to
call this function so what we want to do
is we want to stop this function before
it executes so the clear timeout method
comes into picture and this clear
timeout method works with a variable so
let's create another button for that
first and then we'll declare a variable
as well so let's say we
want a button here and this button will
call a function on clicking so let's say
the function name will be stop
and the button name will also be stop so
save it
and here you can see we have two buttons
one is the click me and the other one is
stop
next up we'll move back to a javascript
file
and we discussed earlier that this clear
timeout method works with the variable
so what we'll do next is we'll create a
variable and we'll assign the initial
value to that variable as 0.
let's say the variable name is id and
the initial value is 0. now why we
assign the value as 0 to this id
variable because
we want to update the value
of id variable with the value provided
by this settimeout method so we'll
assign the value of the settimeout
method to this id variable so we'll
write here id is equals to set timeout
and the rest will remain the same now
next up we'll define another function to
stop all this from happening
so for that we'll write here
function and the function name is top
and then inside the body of this
function
we'll
use the method clear timeout
and this method takes a variable as an
argument so we'll pass id here
and we are done with it so this function
will stop the set timeout method before
execution let's check it out
save it and what we'll do is we'll press
the stop button in between the two
seconds
after the function start will be called
so let's change the timing here from 2
seconds to 5 seconds
so we'll write here
save it now
and
we'll first check if the function start
is working fine or not so
press the click me button and we have to
wait for five seconds
and then the pop-up will appear on the
screen with the message welcome to
simply good so this function is working
totally fine now the next task is to
press the stop button in between those
five seconds
let's do it
click on this click me button and in
between these five seconds click the
stop button as well so here you can see
the message is not printing anymore on
clicking the stop button so this
function is also working fine because we
stopped the process in between before
the function start executes
right next up we have another method in
the timing functions that is the set
interval method
as the name suggests this method is used
to call the function repeatedly after a
specific interval of time like the set
timeout method this set interval method
also takes two parameters first is the
name of the function
and the other one is the time interval
so we'll change this program only
and instead of this
set time out here
we'll write
set interval
fine so
we are good to go now the only change we
did here is to use the set interval
method instead of the settimeout method
now what will happen is
on clicking this click me button the
function message will be called
repeatedly after 5 seconds
let's check it out first save it and
click here on this button
so we have to wait for five seconds
and then a pop-up will appear
so here you can see we have the pop-up
here now after pressing ok we'll wait
for five seconds again and we have the
pop-up again so what's happening here is
we are getting the pop-up constantly
after five seconds right so this is also
working fine and on clicking the stop
button
this function will also stop so we have
clicked on this stop button and we are
not getting the pop-up anymore
so that's how the timing functions in
javascript works a sync await works with
promises in javascript now async await
is just a syntactical sugar wrapped
around promises in javascript basically
it makes it easier to work with promises
in javascript
we already know that using promises
might be a bit tricky or we can say more
prolonged sometimes because we have to
create so many functions and promises in
javascript
so before we move on to async await let
me take you guys through this code which
has promises in it and then we'll see
how to use async await in javascript so
here is a code for promises in
javascript
here in this code we have two functions
make order and process order the make
order function returns a promise and it
will resolve it if the user enters black
coffee otherwise it will reject it on
any other type of coffee then we have
another function here for processing the
order and it will always resolve so this
function is quite simple and
it will add some extra information to
the order so here is the code for extra
information it will print this
on console so let's move ahead and we'll
look at how we call these functions
using promises and then we'll change the
same code using async await let me do it
guys first and then i'll explain it to
you so is the code now what we did here
is we called the make order function
and will pass here black coffee as an
argument to make it successful
then we have used the dot then because
we are using promises here and then we
have the order that will be returned by
a promise so which in this case is a
string that says here is your coffee
this is the string if i
show you so this is the string it will
return and then we have written here
console.log order has been received it
will be printed on the console
and then we have called the process
order function and we are going to
process the order that we received and
the reason we are returning this
is because so you can see here we are
returning this process order function
the reason behind it is because we are
using promises here
then we have changed the event here so
we have used the dot then operator again
we are going to receive the response
from the process order in this case we
have taken it as processed order and we
have logged whatever response we'll get
here the next thing we did here is to
use the catch block
to catch any type of error we get for
example if the user says he wants the
latte
not black coffee then it will give an
error and it will say that we serve
black coffee only so this is the code
for error
so that's all and we are calling these
functions so if we save this program
let's say we are saving it and if we go
back to our console
so here you can see the output says
making request for a black coffee and
then it says order has been processed
then it says processing order and then
at last it says extra information plus
here is your coffee have a nice day
that's how we wanted it to be right now
if the user says he wants a latte in
place of black coffee so let's check it
out and what we'll do is we'll pass the
argument here as
latte instead of black coffee
so save it now here you can see it says
making request for latte so
firstly it made a request for latte and
then it returned the error there it says
sorry we serve black coffee only so it's
working totally fine and this is how
promises actually work in javascript
all the different codes here are
executed and it is waiting for the
previous code to execute before moving
on to the next one
so that's what we exactly wanted here
now if you look at all this code here
which is obviously not too much
confusing but we have to use more dot
than here right
we have to go through a lot of nesting
here and it could be done easily with
async await in javascript and one more
issue with promises is if we want to use
the parameter inside this first dot then
so if we want to use a parameter here
what we have to do is we have to first
create a variable and we have to assign
something to that variable
which is not an easy task right but with
async and await we can do it more
efficiently and we don't have to worry
about all the dot dense and all so now
we'll do the same program with async end
of it and we'll do it here only below
this program
we'll write this piece of code with the
help of async await and we'll see how
easy it is to use async and await in
javascript so let me comment this first
guys now the first thing we need to keep
in mind with async and await is we need
a function to use these terms for
example let's create a simple function
here first so we'll write a function
let's say the function name is function
and then we have the body of this
function so this is a basic function
here and we'll put all our asynchronous
code inside here in this function
but we need to tell javascript that this
function will work asynchronously
for that we have to write a keyword here
before function so what we'll do is
we'll write here
async and this is the syntax now
javascript will know that this function
is an asynchronous function and it will
handle this function accordingly now
inside of this function what we'll do is
we'll call our different methods here so
we'll call the make order method here
and then we'll call the process order
method as well so
let's do it first let's call the make
order method first so we'll write here
make order and we'll pass the argument
here so the argument will be let's say
black coffee
fine
now we have called the function make
order here all we have to do is we have
to write a weight in front of this
function
which will make the code wait until this
make order function executes then only
the next part will be executed so we'll
write here
await and
this make order function now will return
the resolve section of the first promise
we made so we'll store this inside a
variable so we'll write here
let's create a variable here we'll write
where
order
fine
because we have all this code inside of
an asynchronous function what will
happen is as soon as javascript finds
that await keyword so as soon as
javascript find this await keyword
it will leave this function and start
doing other works inside of this program
remember it will leave this whole
function it's not something like the
settimeout method it is different from
that as soon as the make order function
is done executing it will come back to
this function and returns the result
into this order variable
next up what we'll do is we'll write
here console
dot log
and what we want to log here is order
has been
received
now
if we look at the promises example
previously and compare these two codes
so if you can see here we are done with
this part so this is what it looks like
while working with async of it in
javascript
now we'll see that we have received the
order with pretty easy syntax right next
up what we have to do is we have to
process this order this means that we
have to write the code for the second
then we used in the promises example
right the syntax will remain the same
for that we'll write here where
processed order
is equals to
a weight we'll use the await keyword
again
and then we'll write here
process
order fine
and then we'll pass the argument as
order so we are passing this variable as
an argument to this
process order function
the next line will write here
console.log
and we'll copy this this line is the
same so we'll copy it from here
we'll paste it here
fine now we have used the variable
processed order to process the order and
then we know that as soon as the
processing is done we want it to log it
in here
so we are done with this and all we need
to do now is call the asynchronous
function and we are good to go so let's
call this function first for that we'll
write here
funk one
and now save this program
so here you can see it says process
order is not defined
it's okay
we have to remove this e here now
save this and here you can see we have
the exact same output as we had in the
promises example and with this we can
say the sync await are working totally
fine
now
the question arising in your mind maybe
that we didn't do anything for the catch
block here right what if the user enters
latte in place of black coffee so let's
try to do it once so what we'll do is
we'll write here
latte and save it so you can see the
first function is working fine it says
making request for a latte and then it
says
sorry we serve black coffee only so this
is a error and caught error in promises
so we have to do something about this
error right
now the async and await in javascript
actually has two blocks one for
resolving and the other one for error or
reject
so we can say like the then and catch in
promises
we have try and catch in async await so
what we have to do here is we have to
put all this piece of code inside the
try block
so let's do it first what we'll do here
is we'll write here
try so what we are doing is we are
asking the computer to try this piece of
code if this is fine or not
and then we have another block
catch
fine
so
we'll write the code for rejection here
inside this catch block what we'll do is
we'll write here catch and we'll pass a
argument here
so we'll write here error
and then we'll log this error on a
console so we'll write here console.log
error
so we have passed a parameter here and
the moment it will find any error it
will leave the try block and moves on to
the catch block and the output will be
an error so save it and you can see it
here
on the console it says sorry we serve
black coffee only so this is how we can
use async await in javascript it's not
necessary to use with over promises but
the syntax is relatively clean and easy
to understand right as you can see
all we have to keep in mind while using
async await is we have to use a function
and wrap up all the data inside it
so keep this thing in mind that we have
to use a function always and we have to
wrap up all this data inside a single
function with the help of try and catch
block try and catch block are pretty
easy to use right we'll go through try
and catch block in the next video as
well when we'll go through error only
another important thing i want to
mention here before we end up this video
is guys it may happen that you might
don't use these topics quite frequently
while working on the front end of a
website
but if you get to answer these questions
during an interview and these topics are
pretty crucial if you are learning
javascript now errors are something that
we get at times while working on a
program generally there are different
types of errors present in almost every
programming language errors like syntax
error runtime errors and logical errors
so syntax errors are those errors a user
can't control we have to correct the
syntax for that that's the only option
with syntax errors
for example let's say we have a function
that will print something on the console
on calling so let's create a function
here
we'll go to a javascript file and we'll
create a function here so let's say the
function name is f1
fine
and this function will
print something
on the console
so let's say it prints this is
function 1. fine
now
this is a function that will print this
string on the console but let's say we
forgot to put the closing bracket of
this function by mistake
or let's say the closing part was
deleted and we are not aware of it so
this part was deleted or we forgot to
put it there
and what we'll do is we'll call this
function we try to call this function
let's call it first
we'll call function1 save it
and
go to the console so
here in console you can see that it
returns an error here it says syntax
error unexpected end of input and the
best part is we can't do anything for it
except for we can put that closing
bracket in its place again
so if we
put this closing bracket here again
now it will work fine save it and here
you can see we have the output as this
is function1
so these type of errors when occurred in
a program are known as syntax errors
another type of error that occurs in a
program is runtime error runtime errors
are those errors through which the
system comes across during the execution
of a program for example let's say
if we have another function here so
let's add another function here we'll
write here function f2
and the body
will
print something on the console again so
we'll copy this from here and instead of
function 1 we'll write your function 2.
save it and we haven't called this
function yet so let's imagine a scenario
that you created a function f2 and later
somewhere in the program you realize
that you
created a function and you need to call
that function but you are not sure of
the name of that function so let's say
you called another function but the
function name was wrong so let's say
instead of function2 we called another
function f4 let's call this let's try to
do it save it and here you can see a
first function is working fine but when
the system reaches function f2 it
encountered an error here although there
is nothing wrong with the syntax we are
trying to call a function that does not
exist so these type of errors are known
as reference error in a program we can
fix these type of error with the help of
try catch and throw block we'll see it
later these are the different types of
errors that might occur in a program but
sometimes there are situations in which
we want to print an error to the user it
might be for the data entered by the
user or for the data we are getting from
the server
basically we are talking about custom
errors that we create ourselves to make
the flow of program more smooth
we came across the try and catch block
in the previous video wherein we used
these keywords with the async await in
javascript
so there we saw how these blocks were
working to print an error when the user
asks for something other than black
coffee if you haven't watched that video
yet please go through it you can find it
in this playlist
so let's do one thing here and we'll
create a small prototype of the same
program wherein we will have a function
that will print a string on the console
so let me comment this out guys now
we'll create another function here so
let's say we are writing here
function
make order
fine
so this is the function we created in
the last video as well
so let's say inside the body of this
function we'll
write something on the console
we'll write a console.log
and
right here
here is your black coffee
enjoy your
day
fine
now we will go through the syntax of try
and catch block first
and we'll see why we use these
try and catch blocks in a program so
before we move on to the try and catch
block let me clear one thing guys it's
not only the try and catch blocks we use
for these purposes we have another block
in javascript that is always independent
of these two blocks and doesn't need any
condition to run
so the inclusion of the finally block in
error handling depends upon the user you
can either add it or leave it there will
be no effect on the program
so now let's move ahead and we'll go
through the syntax of try and catch
first and then we'll move on to the
final block because finally block is
different from try and catch so let's go
through the try and catch first so we'll
write here
try and press
so we'll write here
try and
you can see this is the syntax of try
and catch block
the catch contains an argument with it
and it will catch the error returned by
the try block
so let's write the code here and then
we'll go through it we want to run this
function inside the try block and if the
function exist
the try block will execute it otherwise
a customized error will be thrown to the
user so we'll call this function inside
the try block
so we'll write here make
order
and we have called this function
now if the function exists the try block
will execute it there will be no problem
in that we are asking the computer to
try executing this line and if this line
does not exist show the user the error
we want to show not the one set by
default so the customized error will
write inside the catch block
and inside the catch block we'll write
here
console.log
and let's say it says
sorry
so this is the error we want to show the
error says sorry an error occurred in
your program
now let's execute this once and then
we'll see it again thoroughly so
this code will not show an error save it
and it will execute the function make
order and the output will be here is
your black coffee enjoy your day
right
but if we execute here another function
that does not even exist like we did for
the run time errors so if we write here
let's say another function so let's say
the other function name is
process order fine so this function does
not exist in the entire program now the
system will go inside the try block and
it will execute the make order function
first the make order function will be
executed without any problem but the
moment it will come across the function
process order it will find it out that
no such function exists in the program
that's when it will move to the next
block and it will throw an error to the
user so save this program and you can
see here it says here is your black
coffee enjoy your day first and then it
says sorry an error occurred in your
program so this is how you can show an
error to the user a customized error we
can say if we call this process order
function outside of the try block the
scenario will change and the error will
be different so let me show you guys
what we'll do is we'll cut this process
order from here and we'll call this
process order function outside of the
try and catch block
now we have called this processor
function here and we know this function
does not exist in the program so let's
save it and here you can see it says
uncut reference error process order is
not defined so this is a runtime error
here now this is the default error you
get in javascript this is the default
way in which you can get an error in
javascript
so there are certain things we can do
with errors in javascript which are
let's say if you want to print the error
as well in the console so we just have
to write here console.log
error
and one more thing we have to do is we
have to move this process order function
from here
back again to its original position
so save it now and here you can see we
have a reference error now this
statement will print the whole error in
the form of text and the user will know
the type of error as well
apart from that we can also print only
the message or the name of them
so for that we have to write here
console.log
error dot
name for the name of error
and
console.log error dot
message for the error message so save it
and here you can see
we have reference error and as the name
of error and the message is process
order is not defined so this part of the
error is the message and this part is
the name now we are left with the
finally block only we have already
discussed that the final block is
independent of the two blocks and it
will be executed anyway if present in a
program
so the syntax for finally block goes
like this
what we'll do is we'll remove
these three statements from our program
and we'll
write here
finally
and inside the finally let's say we want
to print
something
on
the console so let's say
we'll write here this
block
will
execute
no matter what now this finally block
will be executed anyhow
save it
and here you can see we have the output
as this block will execute no matter
what
let's do one thing let's take this
process order function from here and
we'll paste it here save it now and here
you can see now none of the three blocks
is executing
right
so what we have to do is we have to put
it back in its place
one more thing we will discuss before
wrapping up this video is the throw
keyword in javascript with this keyword
we can throw an error anywhere in the
program
the message will be customizable and the
type will be uncaught error
fine
let's see an example of this type of
error handling with the help of basic if
else statement
so let's say we have a condition here in
which we have a variable so let me
comment this piece of code as well first
now let's say we have a condition here
in which we have a variable a
and the value of a is let's say 9 the
condition we have to check here is if a
is less than 10 then an error should be
thrown otherwise the system should print
something
right so let's move on to the
programming part and you will understand
it so what we'll do is we'll declare a
variable e and the value of variable a
will be 9
now
the
if statement will have a condition that
if a is less than 10
throw an error so what we have to do is
we have to write here throw
new error
right
and the message will be let's say
this is a
customizable
error
fine
this is the message and we have to
mention the else statement here as well
so inside the essence statement we'll
write here
console.log
working fine let's see
so
the if else block does not matter that
much in this case the only thing i want
you guys to see here is
the throw keyword save this program here
and we have the value as 9
and what we wanted to throw an error if
the value is less than 10
save it and here you can see
we have a familiar representation of
this error different from the try catch
block the message is customizable and it
says this is a customizable error
so this is how we can throw an error in
the program wherever we want to i hope
you guys got it
have you guys ever heard about
validation or pattern matching in
javascript we come across these terms
when we hear about passwords mostly
right
so we say that we can use the if else
statement to match if the user's
password matches with the one we already
have for that we write if password is
equal to is equals to some sort of
string or characters
and then we see if the password matches
will let the user enter otherwise the
entry will be denied so we are
discussing all that because regular
expressions are objects used to perform
pattern matching or if we want to search
for something in a string or even if we
want to replace something from a string
we can do it all with regular
expressions
so we'll go through the syntax for
regular expressions and some more
important things about regular
expressions in javascript so regular
expressions are present in almost every
programming language it's not limited to
javascript only and the concept remains
the same everywhere the syntax may
differ a bit between different languages
but the logic behind them will always be
the same the name might be a little bit
confusing but
the reality is entirely different they
are pretty easy to use and if you
understand the basics clearly you'll
face no problem while working on
advanced topics
so let's go through the regular
expressions before we move on to
validations using regular expressions in
javascript so let's understand the
concept entirely so that it will be easy
for you guys in further videos so
consider a scenario where we have a
string and we want to find a particular
word in that string or we can say we are
in a static website i hope you guys are
aware of the term static where we have
the search option to find some word in
the entire html document we have to
write the word in the search box and it
will return as the location of that word
in the html file or in the website
right what we'll do now is we'll use a
word and we'll find that word in a
string we'll make some changes to that
word with the help of several functions
used along with regular expressions in
javascript so the syntax for regular
expressions goes like this we'll move to
a javascript file and we'll take a
variable here so let's say the variable
is where
rejects
and we use two forward slashes for it
generally we use the double slash for
comments but it will be recognized as a
regular expression in javascript if we
write something inside these double
slashes so let's say we are writing
something here let's say we write here
hello
now this word hello is present inside
the variable rejects and this word needs
to be searched in a string
so let's use a string as well so for
that we'll write here
where let's say the string name is str1
let's say we are writing here
welcome
to our
youtube
channel
full stop
say hello
if
you are new here
fine so let's say this is the string we
have
now this string contains the word hello
in it all we have to keep in mind is to
add the main keyword in the string for
now
moving ahead what we want to do is we
want to find this word in the string
right we want to find this hello world
in this string
so next up we'll go through certain
essential functions which we use with
regular expressions and we'll see the
functioning of these essential functions
the first function is the exact function
so let me write here guys
this is the first function exec
function
now this function returns an array if
the word is present in this tree
otherwise it will return null if the
word is not present in the string the
syntax is pretty straightforward all we
have to do is to use the exact function
with the variable that contains the
regular expression now in this case the
word rejects contains the regular
expression we have to use it with the
function and the string name will be
passed as a parameter to this function
so
let's write the syntax here and it will
be easy for you guys so let's comment it
out
and we'll write here let's say we are
taking another variable where output
will write here the
variable name
dot function name will write here exec
and the string will be passed as a
parameter fine
so this is the syntax now this output
variable over here will have an array
and the array will return the index
number of the word hello industry
fine so let's print this array on the
console and we'll write here
console.log
output fine
save it and open the console so we will
move to a browser and we'll open console
here
see here we have an array and if we
click on this array we can see that we
have
the word hello at index 36 so if we
count from here and the counting should
start from zero because add index always
starts from 0 so at index 36 we can find
that hello is over here and so it will
return the index of this particular word
now
if we write here something else other
than hello let's say we are writing here
2 save it now and you can see here we
have 2 present at index 8 so if we count
from here we can see that 2 is present
at index 8 so this is working totally
fine now another scenario is if we write
here 2 with a capital t save it now and
you can see here the output is null
why so because regular expressions in
javascript are case sensitive case
sensitive means it differentiates
between the capital letters and small
letters fine
but the good part is we can make them in
case sensitive as well so all we have to
do is we have to use a modifier a
modifier is actually used to make
modifications in the search so what we
have to do is we have to write here in
the beginning we have to write a single
letter and in this case we'll write here
i because this modifier will tell the
system that there will be no problem
with the case sensitivity of the word
now
it will work fine and if we save this
program
we can see we have the output as index 8
now if we change this string and we'll
write here something other than this so
we'll write here h e
l o but
the three letters of this word are
capital letters
so save it now and you can see we have
the output as index 36 so this is
working fine now one last situation is
if we write here more than one hello in
a single string so if we write here
hello and welcome to our youtube channel
now there are two hello words present in
a single string save it and you can see
we have the word hello at index 0 so it
will return the first hello world in the
string now if we want to get access of
the second hello and for if we write
here this piece of code again what we
are expecting is we are expecting it
to give us the index of second hello as
well but it will not happen save it and
you can see it will give the index of
first hello twice you can see here we
have index as 0 in both the areas right
so it will not work
now the solution to this problem is
modifiers again what we have to do is we
have to use another modifier here now we
have to write here the letter g and save
it
now this is returning null because we
have
the string wrong here so we have to
write here hello because we have removed
the in case sensitive modifier save it
now and you can see we have both the
hello words with indexes as 0 and 46
respectively so this global modifier
tells the system that the word is now
global and if you find the word once and
the user tries the exact function again
then the second time you should return
the index value of the second word
so this is how it actually works now the
following function we are going to
discuss is a pretty simple one the test
function
now this function returns either true or
false nothing else
this function checks for a particular
word that if the word exists in a string
then it will return true otherwise false
it will not return the index value or
some sort of other things
it deals with the boolean value only
that is true or false so that's it for
the function let's see how this function
works actually so what we'll do is we'll
mention here this test function
and will
comment this piece of code
so that there will be no
confusion
we'll comment it out
now we'll go through the syntax of this
test function
the syntax is pretty easy we'll use the
output variable again
and we'll write here
variable name dot function name and the
string name will be passed as a
parameter
now the next thing we'll do is we'll
write here console.log
and will print this on a
console
fine so this is the syntax for test
function save it
and here you can see in the console that
for the word hello it returns true if we
change this word here to something else
like if we write here hi instead of
hello
save it and you can see the output is
changed to false because high is not
there inside of a string right because
high does not exist according to this
history so this is how the test function
actually work now one more thing i want
to mention here about the test function
is if we write here some part of a word
not the whole word but some part so
let's say if we write here
e l
now this is the part of hello world now
what if we save this you can see the
output here is true that's because the
test function checks for every letter
and if it finds these three letters in
any word it will return true in that
case as well fine next up we have
another function to use with the regular
expressions in javascript now the next
function's name is match function
i'll write it here
first i'll comment these two statements
and then i'll write here the name of
this function so the name is match
now this match function returns an array
of results otherwise null the syntax for
this function is exactly opposite from
the previous functions
because we'll pass the regular
expression as a parameter to this
function now and the function will be
used along with the string
so
it is completely opposite to
the syntax we used for the previous two
functions so we'll write here for this
we'll use the output variable again
we'll write here where output
and
instead of rejects we'll use it with the
string so we'll write here str1 dot
match
and
the variable name will be passed as a
parameter fine
so this is how the syntax for match
function looks like it's exactly
opposite to the syntax we used for
previous two functions the next line
will remain the same we'll write a
console.log and we'll print
output on a screen fine now we have to
do one more thing here what's that is we
have to remove this modifier from here
and we have to write here
hello so save it and you can see we have
an array over here now what if we want
to find both the words in a string if we
have if we want to check if there's more
than one word with the similar name so
what we have to do is we have to write
here g and if you save it now you can
see the output is completely changed and
now we have an array with two similar
words what if we add another hello here
so let's say we have another hello here
save it and you can see here the array
size is increased to 3 now now we are
left with one more method and the method
we are going to discuss now is pretty
important because we'll use this method
in future as well so the last method is
the replace method which is used to
replace something from a string we can
either replace the first matching word
or all the matching words from a string
if we are using the global modifier then
all the words will be replaced otherwise
the first matching word will be replaced
so the syntax for this method goes like
this
what we have to do is so let's comment
it out first and we'll go through the
syntax of final method so the final
method is
replace method
fine
so the syntax goes like this we'll use
the output variable again
and we'll write here
str1
dot replace because we want to replace
something in that particular string the
first parameter will be the
variable name we'll write here regex
comma and then we'll pass
the word we want to change so hello will
be changed with let's say in this case
hi
fine
now check over here that if we are using
any modifier so we are using global
modifier here
now if we print this on our console if
we write a console.log and
we are writing here output
if we save it now we'll get to know that
all the hello words in the string are
replaced with the word hi
save it and you can see over here that
hi and welcome to a youtube channel say
hi if you are new here and then we have
a hi you can see that all the hello
words are replaced with the word hi
now if we remove this global modifier
from here and if we save it now you can
see only the first hello world is
replaced the other hello worlds are here
and there will be no change in them
because we are not using the global
modifier now in the previous video where
we came across regular expressions in
javascript we saw different predefined
functions that we use for finding a
particular expression present inside a
string right
like the predefined functions we also
have some javascript characters that
make the searching part easy so these
characters are used within the
expressions and help us in different
ways for example let's consider a
scenario where we have a regular
expression and we want to find a
particular word within the string but we
don't remember the whole word let's say
we forgot the word with time
and now we remember only a part of that
word so let's do the same side by side
and what we'll do is we'll go to our
javascript file
and we'll take three variables
we'll write here let regex is equals to
then we'll write here let str1 is equals
to
and then finally we'll write
where output is equals to
fine
now here we have three variables the
variable rejects will store a regular
expression within it we haven't returned
the word yet next up we have a variable
str1 to store the string and a variable
output to store the output returned by a
function the function will use will be
any one of the ones we used in the
previous video so let's do it here the
word let's say the word will be
welcome fine
you can take any word you want now
moving on to the string let's write the
string as well we'll write here welcome
to our youtube
channel and then we'll write another
welcome here
fine
we'll discuss the reason why we wrote
welcome twice now if you guys remember
from the previous video where we have
used the test function to check the
availability of a word present in a
string or not we'll use the same
function again so we'll write here
variable name
dot
function name so the function name is
test and then we'll pass the string name
as the parameter so we'll write here
str1
that's fine
and finally what we'll do is we'll
print this on our console so we'll write
a console.log
output fine now we already know the
output for this piece of code right the
output will be true that's obvious
because we have the word welcome present
in our string not once but twice the
output will remain true if we remove the
first welcome from the string let's do
it here let's save the program first and
then we'll move to the console
and you can see here the output says
true for the word welcome present in the
string str1 that's true right
and now if we remove this welcome word
from here and if we save it you can see
the output still remains true because we
have another welcome word present in the
string right
so this is how the test function
actually works we will put the welcome
word here again we already know the
functioning of this test function the
main point of discussion here is the
meta characters so metacharacters are
characters with special meanings
like the dot character if we write this
regular expression like we can remove
any one character from this word and put
a dot in its place let's do it
we'll remove a random character and
write dot a so let's say
we are removing
l
fine and instead of l we are putting a
dot here
now the dot character here will replace
this character and the system will not
throw any error
it will still find the word we can also
use exact function here to check the
index number of the word so what we'll
do is we'll take another variable
and we'll do the same we'll write here
rejects dot
exec
and then we'll pass the string name as
parameters
fine
we'll copy this console.log from here
and will paste it here
the variable name is op
save it
and here you can see
we have the output as true for the test
function and for the exact function it
returns the index number 0 of the word
in the string now the system
automatically puts a l in place of the
dot character similarly if you want to
do the same thing for more than one
character we have another meta character
for that it's not that we can't use this
dot operator but we can use it for a
limited time like we can use it for a
single character but if we want to put
more than one character and we don't
know the number of the characters so
then we have another meta character for
that the meta character is asterisk
now this asterisk allows us to put
multiple characters within a particular
expression for example if we write here
let's remove all this
and we'll put star or asterisk in place
of all the characters in between so save
it and you can see the output returns
true
for
test function and for the exact function
the index is
0.
now if we write here something like that
and we don't know what it is but let's
assume it so if we save it now you can
still see the output returns true for
this as well
because
now we can put any number of characters
in between w and e the only thing that
matters is the first and the last
character of the word welcome
now
the next character we'll be looking at
does not work the same way as these
characters the carrot character works
upon a whole string let's go through the
syntax and what we'll do is
we'll remove this
unwanted piece of code and then we'll
come here we'll write here
welcome again
and now we'll put this carrot character
now the carrot character is this
character so
what this character returns is this
character returns true only if the whole
string starts with the word welcome the
second welcome word does not even exist
for this meta character if we save this
program now it will return true because
welcome is present at the start of this
string right so save it
and you can see the output is true now
if we remove this welcome from here
and if we save this program now we know
that we have another welcome present in
the string but this character does not
work
that way
and it will return false because the
string starts with
two now right
save it and here you can see the output
is false for test function and for exact
function the output is null it will not
return any index number of the second
welcome or some sort of thing so this is
how the caret character works in
javascript
the next meta character does the same
thing but for the end of the string the
symbol is dollar and it checks for the
end part of the string this meta
character is placed at the end of a
regular expression and it checks if the
string ends with characters present in
the expression the syntax goes like this
what we'll do is we'll remove this
carrot character and we'll put a dollar
sign you
now this statement now will check if the
string ends with the word welcome or not
in this case the last word of the string
is back right
not welcome so the output will be false
save it
save it and you can see here the output
is false and null
suppose we write here back in place of
welcome now what we'll do is we'll write
here
back in place of welcome and if we save
this program now the output will change
to true because back is the last word
present in a string right so this
character checks for the end of the
string
save it and you can see the output is
changed to true and the index number is
and the exact function will return the
index number of the word
back the last meta character we will
discuss in this video is the optional
meta character
the question mark symbol represents this
meta character and the functioning be
like
any character before the symbol is
treated as optional
this means that it doesn't matter if the
character is present in the string or
not for example
if we write here let's say
we'll
write here welcome again because welcome
has more characters than back and will
write here
welcome as well
fine
now let's make some changes in this
particular rejects expression so what
we'll do is we'll put a question mark
here
and let's say we'll put another question
mark here fine now if we remove c and e
from the string or any one of them then
also the function will work fine and the
output will be true let's do it and what
we'll do is we'll make some changes in
this particular string and we are going
to remove some characters from this
string so we have two welcome words
there and what we'll do is we'll remove
c from this one
and we have two optional characters
right both c and e are optional but for
now we are removing c only so the string
looks like this we have the word vellum
it doesn't mean anything but for
understanding purposes we have done it
so save it and you can see the output
remains true for vellum
now
what if we put any other word in place
of this character
let's say we are writing here b
fine
the output will change we have to put an
os
because o is not an optional character
now the output
will change
as we were discussing if we save this
program you can see it is true for now
but it is saying true because of this
welcome now if we remove this welcome
from here and if we save it now you can
see the output is changed to null
yes these characters are optional but we
can't put any character in place of them
we have two options only either we can
put c in its place or we can leave it
so there's no other option with the
optional characters so these are the few
meta characters present in regular
expressions which helps in validation a
lot we came across meta characters in
regex in the previous video where we saw
how to check the availability of a
particular word or expression within a
string we know about functions as well
so today we will combine all these
things to some extent and we'll see how
basic validation actually works in
javascript
we'll see an example wherein we'll go
through the character sets and ranges
and check for some specific type of
validation in this video
now the topic character sets and ranges
itself is a pretty explanatory topic and
we can get an idea of what's coming just
by going through the words characters in
layman term refers to alphabets and
numbers right we see a character on a
daily basis and we know a lot about them
now if i write here a
we can say that this is a character in
javascript now we can use one single
character or a group of characters at a
time with regular expressions in
javascript we have a particular syntax
for it we'll go through the syntax first
and the syntax is like we have to use
square brackets and we have to write
characters in between these brackets or
inside these brackets
here we have three characters a b and c
what we can do is we can give
instructions to the system to use any
one of them in a regular expression
so let's take a small example of how
this actually works with regular
expressions and what we'll do is we'll
do the same thing we have been doing
till now we'll search a word within a
string we'll check that if a word exists
within a string or not so we'll do it
like we'll take a variable rejects
that will contain the regular expression
so this is
the syntax for regular expression and
this is a regular expression which says
d e f so in actual this is not a word
but assume it as a word for now and what
we have to do is we have to include
character sets with this regular
expression right so we'll write here
inside square brackets abc
now the next thing is we'll define the
string let's say the string name is tr1
and the string says
this string contains adef
so def
or we can say adef is what matters the
most for now so anything else you can
write on the string the next thing we
are going to do is we are going to
use the test function to check if this
particular regular expression
is available in the string or not so
we'll write here regex dot
test and inside this will pass the
string as a parameter
now the last thing we'll do is we'll
write here console.log and
we'll print this on our console fine
we are done with it so what we are doing
here is we want to search the string for
a word which contains the letter d e f
compulsory but before def we can have a
character that character can either be a
b or c no other character will be taken
in front of def because we have defined
a character set as well right and that
character set contains only three
characters a b and c
so
here you can see we have adef present in
the string and we have a along with def
so
what we are expecting is this test
function should return true right so
save it and check for the output in the
console so we will go to a console
and here you can see the output says
true because we have adef only
now if we write here anything else like
if we replace this a with the character
r
save it and you can see the output is
false because r is not present inside
this character set now
what if we write here something like
let's say we are writing here
caution def now this will check for this
letter only for this l only other
letters don't actually matters in this
case in the case of character sets the
only character that matters is the
character right before the regular
expression
so if we save it you can see the output
is changed to false and if we write here
let's say
caution adef save it and you can see the
output is true because it checks for
this character only fine
talking about ranges let's say we want
to add any character in the string
between a to z now we have two options
to do so first one is we can write abc
till z here like we'll write here d e f
g h i and so on and so forth tills it
but this task is a little bit lengthy
right and we have to spend a lot of time
in that process so the alternate to this
process is to define a range of
characters to define a range of
characters it's quite an easy task all
you have to do is write a
hyphen z so this is how you can define a
range of characters now this range will
consist every character from a till z a
and z will also be included keep this
thing in mind if we write here caution
df again so we have seen in in the
previous example that it returned false
for this right save it now and you can
see the output is still true
that's because now we have a range from
a till z
if we write here 5 now now it will
return false because 5 does not lies in
between this range in between a to z so
it will return true for any character
between a till z fine
now let's say we want to exclude some
particular characters from this range
like we don't want the user to include
def again no character from d e or f so
the syntax for that is also pretty easy
we have to use the carrot operator and
we have to write here but we don't want
to include so let's say in this case we
don't want to include def fine so if we
write here d d e f now and save it you
can see
it will return false because we have
included ddef and if we write here adef
save it and you can see the output is
true
now we can't include
characters
d e and f in front of this regular
expression because we have defined this
character set to not include these
characters in the regular expression
so these are characters and ranges in
regular expressions so the next thing
we'll be doing is we'll be going through
a basic validation example and we'll see
how actually basic validation works in
javascript what we'll do is we'll create
a small html form that will take the
employee id from the user and it will
check if the employee belongs to the
organization or not
so let's say the employee id of the
organization has some unique characters
present in it and the character remains
there in each employee id
the idea is simple we'll take the id
from the user and we'll use if else
control statement to check if it belongs
to the organization or not
so let's move on to the html file and
we'll create a placeholder and a button
so
let's do it
we'll write here
form
and inside this form tag
let input
id is equals to
eid
and
placeholder is equals to
employee id
and type is equals to
text fine
the next thing we are going to do is we
are going to include a button as well
button and we are going to call a
function on clicking so we will use the
on click event so we will write your own
click and lets say the function name is
employee
and the button name is let's say submit
save it and you can see over the browser
that we have a placeholder along with
the button so let me give a space here
save it now and you can see we have a
placeholder and a button so that's all
what we have to do in html part now the
rest of the thing we'll be doing in the
javascript file so let's move to a
javascript file
and comment
this piece of code first
now what we want is we want to call a
function employee on clicking the submit
button fine so what we'll do is we'll
define a function employee
and inside the body of this function the
first thing we will be doing is we will
be taking
the user's id right so we need a
variable for that so let's say the
variable is
mpid and we'll write here
document dot
get element by id the id is
eid
dot
value
fine now this empid variable will hold
the value entered by the user right so
like if we write here something like
d2386 so let's say this is the id this
will be stored the value for this id
will be stored inside this empidi
variable fine
now we'll use the regular expression to
check for some special characters so
we'll write here
inside the function we'll write here
where
check is equals to
inside the regular expression we'll
write something so let's say we want to
start the employee id for the
development team with the alphabets dnd
and each id will have a similar numeric
code like 253 which represents the code
for a particular team fine
so we'll write here inside the character
sets
we want de to be there before a similar
numeric code right so
253 is the numeric code and we want to
include either d or e
before that right
and
after 253 let's say we have a range of
numbers that each employee id has a
unique two digit number the id should
look like
either
d
2 5 3
1 1 or either
e
2 5 3
6 1
something like that right
now so for that what we have to do is we
have to include here another range and
this range will be from 11
oh so this range will be from 10 till 99
fine
this looks a bit complex now but if you
try to do it by yourself believe me guys
you'll find it out that this is an easy
task but a little lengthy we can say now
the next part is we have to validate the
id entered for that we have to use the
if else control statement along with the
test function
so we have to write here
if
check
dot test and inside this will write
amp id because empid is the variable
which is holding the value entered by
the user right so if it's true then it
will return
an alert box with the message that says
valid
employee id fine
else
it will
return a message in the pop-up
which will say
invalid
id fine
so this if else statement will check the
value returned by the test function if
the value returned is true it will
return a message valid employee id
otherwise the else statement will run
and the user will get a pop-up with the
message invalid email id fine
let's check the output and in the
browser here we'll write the employee id
in the
given placeholder so let's say the
employee id is d
one nine
submit it and you can see it says valid
employee id we can do it for some mode
like if we write here e
two five three
nine eight
submit it and you can see it still says
valid employee id now what if we want to
include any character between this range
and the unique number right so let's try
to do it we'll write here d
k
fine so let's say this is the id we want
to enter submit it and you can see it
says invalid employee id
now one more thing we want to do here is
like if we write here
d253
okay eight nine
in this case it will return false or
invalid employee id why because we
haven't included any modifier here and
it will differentiate between uppercase
and lowercase character so to overcome
this problem what we can do is we can
include the in case sensitive modifier
and we are clearly good to go now if we
write here d25398
and save it if we write here now d
2 5 3
9 8
submit it
and you can see here the output says
valid employee id
so this is how we can use validation
along with regular expressions
in the last video we came across
character sets and ranges we saw how we
could use them with regular expressions
and we also saw how to validate a user's
input with the help of character sets
and ranges along with regular
expressions now in this video we'll look
at the shorthand character classes
present within regular expressions and
we'll see how they are helpful in
javascript
if you guys remember the regular
expression we used became a bit
confusing and lengthy because we have
used so many ranges and character sets
all in one right a character class can
be used to overcome this particular
problem and we have several character
classes present in javascript so today
we will go through them in this
particular video now the syntax is not
too much complicated all we have to do
is to write a single character with the
backslash and we are good too
for example if we go to a javascript
file and if we write here
backslash d
now if we write this character before
any regular expression in javascript it
means that we have added a character
class to a regular expression this
backslash d is a character class used
for finding a digit within a string
let's go through an example for this
character class
and we'll do the same thing we'll take a
string and try to find a regular
expression within that string so what
we'll do is
we'll write here
where
regex is equals to
and here we'll write a regular
expression first we'll take up a string
and use some functions to check the
output so let's do it here what we'll do
is we'll take another variable let's say
the variable name is str1 and
the string says
users
phone number
is
nine eight seven six five four three two
one zero now let's say this is the
string we are using for today's program
the next thing we'll do is we'll use the
exact function to find the regular
expression within the string
so we have already gone through this
exact function in javascript today we'll
use that function only
now we'll write here where
output is equals to
regex dot exec
and inside this will pass a string as a
parameter
the next thing we'll do is we'll write
here console.log
and we'll print this output on a console
now we are good to go so we are done
with it and the next thing we want to do
is to find a particular pattern along
with the number present before that
pattern in the string so let's suppose
if we write here inside these slashes if
we write here let's say 3 to 1
now
this statement here asks the computer to
find a pattern 3 to 1 in the string
save it
and go to the console so we'll move to a
browser and we'll press control plus
shift plus i and here you can see we
have a console here and here we have an
array as well so here you can see it
says
let me zoom it out a bit here you can
see it says
321 is present at index 28.
now
the system finds out that this
particular string or this particular
regular expression is present here in
the string at index number 28 obviously
the indexes will start from 0 and the
moment it will find this
3 to 1 regular expression it will show
the index number in an array in a
console
now if we add
backslash d here let's say we are adding
here backslash d
in front of this expression and check
the output here save it you'll notice
that we have a number present here right
before that expression
right we have 4 3 2 1 here instead of
just 3 2 1. the output here gives us the
number 4. this means that this backslash
d represents this number
4 in this string now what if we put an
alphabet before this expression now
let's do it what we'll do is we'll write
here a
and let's say we are adding only a
single alphabet here let's say we are
adding a before three two one now the
expected output is a three two one but
the moment will save it you can see it
says null that's because this particular
character class works for digits only if
it finds anything other than a numeric
digit it will return an error or it will
return null in that case now if we want
to find all the numbers before this
pattern then we have to add a plus
operator in the regular expression all
we have to do is we have to write here
plus and we are good to now it will
return everything
until it finds a space or any character
other than a digit now let's suppose if
you are writing here a after 987
now this particular statement will
return all the numbers till 6 the moment
it will encounter a here it will return
all the numbers after a it will stop at
a and it will not go further now save it
and you can see it says 654321
that's because
this backslash d works for digits only
now if we write here nothing
like we have a number nine eight seven
six five four three two one zero save it
and it will return the whole number nine
eight seven six five four three two one
not 0 because we haven't included any
number here
now if we write here again
backslash d after this as well save it
and here you can see we have the output
as
0 as well we have the whole number here
fine
so this is how this backslash d actually
works in javascript so this is a
character class
now
the next thing is what if we want to
find a non-digit character before a
particular pattern
if we write here
before three two one let's say we are
writing here a
and we want the system to return the
non-digit character before three two one
in that case we use capital d instead of
small d always remember guys every
shorthand character class in rejects
have an inverse that does
precisely the opposite of that
particular class like if we have small d
here that works for digits only we also
have an inverse which is denoted by
backslash capital d and it does exactly
opposite of this small d here
now if we write here
capital d in place of small d
what will happen is it will return the
character here it will return true for
everything other than a digit
now if we remove this small d from here
and save it
here you can see it says null because we
haven't included the backslash sign here
save it
and here you can see it says
a321
it will return true for anything except
for a digit even if we put a symbol over
here then also it will return the output
as true for example if we write here
let's say we are including dollar sign
here let's say we are including two
dollar sign here save it and it will
return two dollar signs that's because
we are using the plus operator here
obviously let's include as many signs as
we can
save it and here you can see we have all
the symbols present over here on our
output
so this is how capital d character class
works or we can say inverse character
class of small d this is how it works
now the next class we'll be going
through is the wordly character denoted
by the letter w small w and is used in
place of any character that can be an
alphabet a number or an underscore sign
we can use this character over d if we
are unsure about the character present
before the pattern for example if we
write here
let's say backslash w
ber
now here we have used the ber pattern
which is present at the end of
number right here ber is present at the
end of number now this statement will
return m only because we are not using
any plus operator here if we use any
plus operator then it will return the
whole number because it will return
everything until it encounters a space
or something like that so for now we are
not using any plus operator so we'll be
writing here this only now here it will
return m because it can take up a number
an alphabet or an underscore sign it
will return false if it finds any space
or something other than these three
these three means a number an alphabet
or an underscore sign fine
now save it and you can see on the
console that the output says mber let me
zoom it a bit so here you can see the
output says mber right present at index
it will return null if we put a space
before the pattern like if we write here
num space b er save it you can see it
says null for this now we can use the
plus operator as well here for this
particular character class now what will
happen is it will return every character
present before the pattern until it
encounters a space or something like a
symbol or any sort of thing so let's try
it what we'll do is we'll write here w
plus b er and we'll remove this space
from here
save it and here you can see it says
number what if we remove this space from
here remove it save it and here you can
see it says phone number it will return
every character before the pattern until
it finds any space or any other let's
say
symbol so let's say we are including
here dollar percentage
and carrot sign
save it and here you can see it says an
e number so it's returning it from here
because it will not return true for any
of the symbols here
save it and here you can see we have the
output as phone number again so that's
working totally fine
like the inverse character class for
digits we have the inverse character
class for this also and it returns true
for everything other than an alphabet
number or any underscore sign now if we
write here
instead of small w let's say we are
writing here capital w
and let's do something with the string
as well so let's put a space here again
and we are good to go we are not doing
anything more than that so it will
return null because before ber we have m
here right if we remove this m with us
sign let's say if we are removing this
with the dollar sign or with an empty
one like we are writing here space
nothing then it will return the index
number and the pattern
so let's do it save it
and here you can see it says dollar then
it says ber and index number is 14 you
can count the index number so 0 for u
and then similarly 1 for s 2 for e 3 4 r
4 for s up to 14 for dollar so dollar is
present at index 14 it will return the
index number here now the plus operator
also works for this inverse character
class as well right here plus b ber and
we can insert as many characters or as
many symbols as we want so like here we
have inserted so many symbols this
doesn't mean anything but we are
inserting them for
example purposes or for practical
purpose
so save it and here you can see we have
all the symbols present over here in a
array and the index number is still 14.
if we remove
these and and u from here now save it
the index number will change to 11
that's quite easy
now
the next class we have is the simplest
of all this class works for white spaces
only it means that it will return true
or give us the index number of the
expression from the string only if a
white space exists before the pattern
it is denoted by small s and works for
spaces only now if we write here
let's say
backslash s
okay we have made a mistake we'll write
a backslashes
and we'll write your phone so
this is the pattern and this is the
character class backslash s is the
character class now what we'll do is
we'll
remove it from here and we'll
write the string
as this again we'll write a user's phone
number is this and this
now for this regular expression it will
return the index number of this space
the space is present at index 5
0 for u
1 for s 2 for e 3 for r 4 for s and this
space is present at index number five so
it will return index as 5 for this
particular space now don't get confused
guys for this index number s5 the index
number is for the space present in the
screen before the pattern phone
right now if we try to do the same for
users as well
let's suppose if we write here
users it will return null in this case
because there's no space present before
users in the string right save it and
here you can see the output says null in
this case
fine
now we can also use the plus operator
here for more than one spaces present in
the string it will return all the spaces
until it finds a character or something
other than the spaces like if it finds
any symbol or any character then only it
will return false otherwise for spaces
it will return true so if we write here
too many spaces if we put too many
spaces before the word
phone or let's say we are changing this
word to
phone
save it and here you can see we have all
the spaces here it's denoted by a single
space but the index numbers is changed
to 19. now we have so many spaces
present here before the
pattern phone or before the word phone
so this is how we can use
space character class in javascript
now we have also the inverse class for
this character class as well it returns
true for everything other than empty
spaces if we write here
let's say we are removing this and let's
say we are right okay and let's say we
are
writing here users
and we are
giving so many spaces here before the
word users now it will return null in
this case because there are spaces
present in front of the word users
if we include a character or something
in front of this word then only the
output will change and return the index
number along with the string so save it
first and here you can see
okay we have used the smallest in place
of smallest we'll write here capital s
save it and you can see here the output
says null for capital s because this
capital s will return true for
everything other than spaces only now if
we put here any symbol let's say we have
these symbols here
save it and here you can see now we have
a hash symbol present before the word
users that's because we have used
capital s only now if we use a plus
operator save it and here you can see we
have all the symbols present in a array
we have the index number as 11 we have
dollar percentage carrot and hash
present over here right so this is how
the inverse of character spaces in
javascript actually work so these are
the character classes we have in
javascript if you guys see we have two
text boxes over here one is for the
username and other one is for the
password
creating such text boxes in html is
quite an easy task we have to use the
input tag which we discussed a few
sessions back
and we are using some more properties
here
so you can see we have type as text for
username and for password the type is
password
so before we move on to validation with
javascript let me tell you guys that we
can do certain things with html as well
like if we want that none of the two
text boxes over here remains blank
we can write here inside these input
tags so if we write here
required
save it and now if you try to click on
this submit button you can see it says
please fill out this field it will not
allow the user to submit the form until
there is any value present for the name
so if we write here any random name and
submit it now you can see the form is
getting refreshed that's because we have
used the form tag over here now if we
try to submit without writing anything
we'll get the popup as please fill out
this field and we can do the same for
password as well like if we write here
required and save it
now if you write any name over here for
the username and if we leave this
password field blank submit it you can
see it says please fill out this field
for password as well
so html can let you do all this stuff
but when it comes to actual validation
like if you want the user to enter only
if the name or password matches the one
present in the back end or maybe we can
say in the server
we have to use something more than html
now the case with javascript is a bit
different
if we talk about validation in
javascript we can use javascript for
client-side verification
the scenario here will be the one we'll
discuss in today's video what we'll do
today is we'll create a basic signup
form with three text boxes one is for
the username the other one is for the
password and we'll add one more box for
each
half of the work is already done and we
have to add one more box now for the h
so edge is just a number right so we can
add a text box over here what we have to
do is we have to write here
before the submit button will write here
input
type is equals to number
and will provided the id as well so
let's say the id is each we'll use the
id attribute later
and inside this placeholder will write
here h
save it and here you can see we have
three text boxes over here
inside the h we can't write any
character or alphabet because we have
defined the type as number for this so
we can write numbers here only now the
next part is to link this page to
another web page such that if the
credentials are correct the user will
enter the home page of our website for
that we have to use the action attribute
in html now the question here is when do
we want the user to enter the home page
only if the credentials are correct
right
we have to use the action attribute with
the form tag so you can see over here we
have already mentioned the form type now
what we'll do is we'll write here action
and what we want is we wanted to
redirect the user to another page or
another web page the home page of our
website after checking the credentials
and if the credentials are correct the
user will move on to the home page so we
have already a file named homepage.html
so we'll write here homepage.html
and save it now on clicking the submit
button okay we have to fill something
for
name and for password as well so we'll
write random values over here submit it
and you can see we have been redirected
to another page and this is the home
page of our website
however it doesn't look like a home page
still we can assume it right so now we
know what should be done if the user has
correct credentials to enter the home
page we are almost done with the html
part we will make some more changes to
this file later the next thing we have
to do is to validate the credentials
entered by the user right for validation
purposes we'll use the if else control
statements in a javascript file we'll
create a function in a javascript file
and call that function when the user
clicks the submit button but there is a
difference will not call the function on
clicking the submit button instead we'll
call the function on
submission of the form so instead of
writing here on click and then calling
that function what we'll do is
we'll write here inside the form tag
we'll write on submit so this is an
event and on submit what will happen is
it will call a function named validate
will create this validate function in
our javascript file now
so you can see here we have already used
the id attribute with all the input tags
in order to get the values entered by
the user so let's move on to the
javascript file
and what we'll do here is we'll first
declare a function named validate so
we'll write here function
and the function name is
validate
and then we have the body of this
function
now we'll take three variables to get
all the values entered by the user
because we need to check for all the
values right so we need to check if the
user's name and password match the one
we want and the user should be aged
above 13 to enter our website
for all these we need the values entered
by the user so we'll use the get element
by id method to get all the values
now for that we'll take three variables
so let's say the first variable is
unnamed it will hold the value entered
in the username text box let me go to
the form again
and here you can see we have three text
boxes username password h so we'll take
three variables
for username we'll write here document
dot
get element by id and the id is unname
let me confirm it once so you can see
here
the id for user name is
uni
for password it is pass and for h it's h
so
we'll write here dot
value
the next thing we'll do is we'll create
another variable for password
we'll write here again document dot
get element by id and the id is pass
will again write here dot value
and the third variable will be where age
it will hold the age of the user
so we'll again write here
document.getelementbyid
and id for ages h
we'll again use the dot value property
now we are done with the values
we have three variables holding all the
values entered by the user next up we'll
use these values to validate the data
entered by the user
now the first condition we can have here
is that we don't want the user to leave
any of the text boxes empty right if we
click on this submit button you can see
it says please fill out this field now
we can do it with the help of html as
well but for now we are using javascript
so we will remove these
required keywords
so that we can do it with javascript
only
save it
and submit it now you can see it is
redirecting us to the home page of our
website so it's working totally fine now
what we'll do is we'll write a condition
if the user leaves any of these fields
empty so we'll write here if
u name
is equals to is equals to blank
or
pass is equals to is equals to blank
okay
or
age
is equals to is equals to
blank
now what will happen is it will give the
user a pop-up with the message
let's say
the message is
missing
credentials fine
save it
and if we leave any of these fields
empty now a pop-up will appear with the
message missing credentials so the first
condition is done but there's a loophole
in this condition so let's check it out
first we'll leave username and password
empty submit it you can see it says
missing credentials right
now the next thing is if we write here
let's say a random name and password as
well but we are leaving this age text
box empty submit it it still says
missing credentials because we haven't
entered the age
and it's working totally fine
now there's a loophole in this condition
the exciting part is it will work fine
if the user enters more than one space
in all the fields like
if you are giving here spaces for more
than once and similarly for password as
well submit it
and you can see it says missing
credentials because we haven't filled
the h
so let's
do one thing we'll
write some spaces for username and
password and for h we'll say the age is
4 submit it and you can see we have no
error over here now to overcome this
problem we have a predefined javascript
method that treats all the spaces the
same
no matter the number of spaces whether
it be one or more than one it will treat
all the same we have to include the trim
method within the if else statement so
what we'll do is we'll write here dot
trim
for username and similarly for password
as well we'll write here trim
and for age as well let's say
dot trim
and save it now
move back to a sign up form and if we
try to give more than one spaces here
and let's say the age is 4 submit it you
can see it says missing credentials for
more than one species as well so this is
working totally fine now the following
condition will be for validating the
name let's say the required name is
caution or anything else
the required password is let's say one
two three four five and the age should
be more than 13.
then only the user can enter the website
so for that we have to use the else if
statement and what we'll do is we'll
write here
elsif and inside this will give our
conditions so let's say the conditions
are you name
is equals to is equals to
caution
and
pass
is equals to is equals to
1 2 3 4 5
and
h
should
be greater than or is equals to
then
it will give the user a pop-up and
which states that we'll write here alert
we'll write here
sign up
successful
fine
save it
now the user can enter the website with
these credentials only otherwise a
pop-up will appear
so let's give the else condition as well
what we'll do is we'll write here else
and we'll use another alert
inside this we'll write
wrong id and
password
fine
now we have all the conditions here save
it and now we'll check for different
inputs
so let's move back to a form
and what we'll do is we'll write the
username is let's say ravi
and the password is let's say any random
numbers and age is let's say 6 submit it
and you can see it says wrong id and
password now what we'll do is we'll give
it the correct credentials we'll write
here
caution and the password will be one two
three four five
and age is let's say 21 mind the age
should be greater than or equals to 13
so submit it and you can see it says
sign up successful
now we have different conditions over
here
like if we write here any random name
and
if we write here any random password now
it will return wrong id and password but
if we write here correct id and password
and
correct username as well let's say we
are writing here caution and let's say
the age will be changed to
11 submit it and you can see it still
says wrong id and password we can add
one more condition over here like we'll
write here elsif age is less than 12 it
will give an alert that
you are underage or some sort of that so
we'll write here elsif
h
is less than 13.
an
alert which states under each fine
save it
and what we'll do is we'll move back to
our form and we'll write here caution
password is one two three four five and
age is let's say
11 submit it and you can see it says
underaged now so it is working totally
fine now one thing that seems a bit
irritating as well is it redirects us to
the home page every time right it
doesn't matter if the credentials are
correct or not it redirects to overcome
this issue we have
to make some minor changes in the html
file and include the return keyword in a
if else conditional statements so let's
go back to our html file and what we'll
do is
we'll write here inside the form tag now
we have on submit over here so what
we'll do is we'll write return
before validate
so save it and we'll move back to a
javascript file
now this return keyword will let the
form perform any action only if the
value returned by the function validate
is true otherwise it will not allow the
form tag
to perform any action the action here is
redirecting the user to the home page
right so
let's do it here we know that the
function should return true only if all
the credentials are valid so we'll write
here
for all other
conditions we'll write
return
false
fine
for this one we'll write
return true because this is the
condition when all the credentials are
correct and for all other conditions
we'll write return
false
similarly for else as well we'll write
here
return false
now save it and we'll move back to
sign up form
save the html file as well once
and what we'll do is we'll write your
caution password is one two three
and age is let's say four submit it you
can see it says underaged click on ok
and now it is not redirecting us to the
home page right
now if the credentials are correct what
we'll do is we'll write here the
password as one two three four five
and the age is let's say
submit it
now you can see it says sign up
successful click on ok and you can see
we are in the home page it is working
totally fine
so if all the credentials are valid then
it is redirecting us to the home page
exactly what we wanted so these are the
basics of validation in javascript
obviously we can't validate a form with
javascript in the real world because we
don't have to deal with one user only we
need the backend to do all the
validation and all but simple validation
can be done with the help of javascript
we did it just now
so we'll use regular expressions again
to validate the email id entered by the
user so let's move on to the programming
part directly and will create a text box
here to take the user's input so what
we'll do is we'll create a text box
we'll write here
input
type is equals to
email id here as let's say mail
fine the next thing will be a
placeholder and
the placeholder will say
enter
email id here
fine we'll close this input tag and the
next thing we'll be doing is we'll be
creating a submit button we'll write
here type is equals to
button value will be
submit
and we'll use the on click event
so we'll write here on click so we'll
call a function on clicking this button
we'll write here validate we'll create
this validate function in a javascript
file
now save this piece of code and you can
see we have a text box and submit button
here now if you write here something
you can see nothing is happening over
here
now the next task we have to do is the
one we already know we will move on to
the javascript file we will create a
function there and use the if else
control statements to check if the email
id entered by the user is in accordance
with the pattern or not
quite a simple task because we have been
doing it for quite some time right so
let's do it quickly what we'll do is
we'll move to a javascript file i forgot
to create one here so let me create one
and the name will be
email.js so this is a javascript file
we'll create a function here so we'll
write here
function validate
the next thing is the body of this
function
so we'll write here everything other
than the regular expression because the
rest will remain the same as mobile
number validation so we'll try it here
we'll create a variable here we'll write
here where
email is equals to
we'll write here
document.getelementbyid and the id is
mail
now we'll use the dot value attribute
the next thing is we'll again take a
variable for regular expression and
we'll
leave it for now we'll move on to the
next part
what we'll do here is we'll use the if
else control statement again so the
first condition will remain the same
we'll write here if email dot
trim
is equals to is equals to null
then what it will do is it will give a
pop-up so we'll use the alert keyword
and inside this will write
please enter a valid
email id fine the next thing we'll do is
we'll use the test function in regular
expressions so we'll write here else if
regex dot
test
and will pass this email variable as a
parameter
here it will check if the
input given by the user matches the
pattern of the regular expression we'll
check for it so we'll
write here alert and inside this will
write email submitted successfully
fine
and at the last we'll use the else
statement
and we'll write here alert
wrong
email id
fine
save it
now we are almost done with everything
apart from the regular expression we
didn't define the rejects until now
because we'll discuss it first because
you know guys using a regular expression
for email validation is slightly
different from other things like we have
several parts for a regular expression
let's discuss it first
so let's take an email id first so let
me write here
let's say we have an email id
as caution
at the rate simply learn
dot
com
fine we can't write here two dots so
this is what a primary email id looks
like an email id consists of four parts
the first part is the name that can be
anything it can have alphabets digits or
sometimes dot and underscore as well so
we can have the name as like if we write
here
let's say caution
one one or if we write here caution dot
one one or we can say we can write here
caution
underscore zero one one
right so these names are allowed in an
email id the next part is the at the
rate symbol it's mandatory to add the
symbol in each email id as you know so
the third part is the domain name that
can be the name of any particular
organization like here simply learn is
the domain name
or it can be gmail or yahoo or hotmail
or any of these so that depends on the
user where they have their email id
now the last part is the extension which
comes after a dot so after this dot we
have an extension over here this com is
an extension
fine
an extension can be dot com it can be
dot in or dot net or it can be dot co
dot in
so now that we have an idea about how an
email id looks like the next thing we'll
be doing is working here on the regular
expression to create a particular format
of this type
right so we have four parts but we have
to compulsorily add and add the rate
symbol and
dot before the extension
so what we'll do is we'll take three
pairs of parentheses or round brackets
we can say for defining the rest three
parts so what we'll do is we'll write
here
so we need
three parentheses right now we have to
mention at the rate and dot compulsory
here fine the rest will define but we
have to add these two symbols
compulsorily in each email id
the carrot and the dollar signs are meta
characters used to define the regular
expressions starting and the end points
right so i hope you guys are clear with
regular expressions till now as this is
the last video on this topic and still
if you have any doubts about rejects
feel free to comment your doubts and
we'll get back to you so let's define
the first part here the first part is
the name consisting of alphabets digits
or some specific symbols like dot and
underscore right we'll define a range
here so we'll use square brackets to
define the range so what we'll do is
we'll write here
a to z
or
or 0 to
9. fine here we have defined three
ranges arrange for small letter
alphabets capital letter alphabets and a
range of numbers from 0 to 9. now we
could have used the global modifier at
the end of this regular expression
instead of defining a range of capital
letter alphabets we have already
discussed the concept of modifiers a few
sessions back
now the next thing is to add specific
symbols like dot and underscore we can't
write them simply because if we write
here dot or underscore the meaning will
change
and it will return true for any
character in place of dot
the concept of meta characters remember
so we have to put a backslash before
writing the symbols what we'll do is
we'll put a backslash over here
now we have added the special symbols as
well the next part is the length of this
name
now it can be either 10 or maybe 20 or
we can say in some cases let's suppose
it can go more than 20. now what we can
do is we can either define the length
inside curly braces like this we can
write here
2 comma 20 so this is the range for
length but we can't do it here because
we are keeping this thing in mind that
the username might go above 20
characters so what we'll do is we'll use
the plus operator the plus operator will
let the user enter the name as long as
they want instead of using these curly
braces over here what we'll do is we'll
use the plus operator here
fine
now the next part is for the domain name
after this add the rate symbol over here
what we'll do is we'll write the domain
name
that has to be there in each email id
right the domain name can be the name of
any organization as we have already
discussed we don't need digits in the
domain name right so what we'll do is
we'll simply write here
a to z and
a to z so we have defined two ranges for
domain name one for the small letters
and the other one is for the capital
letter alphabets
fine we did it almost the same as name
now again the domain name can be of any
length so we have to use the plus
operator here what we'll do is
we'll first put them inside square
brackets i forgot to mention them here
and then we'll use the plus operator now
the regular expression looks a bit
complicated right but we don't have to
worry about it because these all are
easy things just a little bit lengthy we
can say
so the next thing we'll be doing here is
we'll be going through the last part of
a email id after this dot symbol what we
have to do is we have to define another
range for the extension
right the extension can be any alphabet
with a length not more than 6 to 7
right so what we'll do is we'll write
here
a to z only consist of small letters
or we can include capital letters as
well so what we'll do is we'll write
here
a to z as well
now the next thing we'll do is we'll
define the
length of this extension
so we don't need the plus operator here
because the length of any extension
can't be more than four five or six
maybe right so what we'll do is we'll
define a range of
length we'll write here two
and six so two is the minimum length of
extension and six is the maximum length
now save it
and let's check the output so we'll
check for several email ids now what
we'll do is we'll write here
abc at the rate
gmail.com fine
submit it you can see it says email
submitted successfully
let me zoom it out a bit the next thing
we'll do here is we'll write here
abc
underscore
1 1 at the rate gmail.com
so one thing we have forgotten here
is
to include the carat character and the
dollar character so we have to specify
the starting and end point here so what
we did is we have included the carrot
character and the dollar sign here
now we'll write here abc underscore one
one at the rate
gmail.com
submit it and you can see it says email
submitted successfully so this is a
valid email id now the next thing we'll
be doing here is we'll be using any
random symbol so let's say we are using
here abc star at the rate gmail.com
submit it and you can see it says wrong
email id
now the next thing we'll be doing here
is
we'll write any number here let's say
and we'll write here caution 112.3
fine so
this will return wrong email id because
we have included numbers in domain name
and we haven't defined any range of
numbers for the domain name submit it
and you can see it says wrong email id
now remove these numbers from here
and submit it you can see it says email
submitted successfully so this is
working totally fine
now the last thing is what if we have an
email like
caution112.3 at the rate gmail dot
co dot in
submit it and you can see it says wrong
email id in this case we have to define
another range in the regular expression
that can be optional so we have the
question mark symbol that acts as an
optional character it means that any
range or anything return before this
meta character will be optional
so we'll use this symbol
and we'll write here
before this dollar sign
will again use parenthesis and we'll
write here
dot
a to z
and then we'll define the range as 2
comma 6
and we'll use the question mark sign
here or we can say this optional meta
character here save it
and now what if we write here
caution at the rate
gmail dot co dot in
now submit it and you can see it says
email submitted successfully and this is
totally optional if we write here
caution
gmail.com submit it and you can see it
still works fine so this is how we can
validate a user's email id in javascript
we have been using the console for a
long time now we have seen how we can
use it to print the output of our
program in the console
that's quite simple now debugging refers
to finding and fixing errors in a
program
now to remove those errors we need to
identify them and analyze the solution
for them as well so in this video we
will see how to identify an error in a
program with chrome developer tools and
what we'll do today is we'll create a
simple html program and we'll try to
understand the concept of debugging in
javascript with the help of that program
so let's do something here
now we'll create two text boxes over
here so
what we'll do is we'll take the user's
input to add two values entered by the
user in those text boxes so what we'll
do is we'll write here input
type is equals to
number because we want to perform
addition of two numbers
and then we'll write here id as let's
say the id for number one is n1 and then
we'll write your placeholder
right here let's say
number one fine
now we'll do the same for
second number as well we'll write here
number
id is equals to n2
placeholder is equals to
number two fine the last thing we have
to do is we have to insert a submit
button so we'll write here input type is
equals to button
and we'll write the value as
submit
and
we'll use an event over here so we'll
write here
on double click we'll call the function
add on clicking
fine
now save it and you can see we have
two text boxes over here and a submit
button fine
we tried a new on click event here
instead of using the regular on click
event we have used the double click
event now the functioning will remain
the same the only change is that we have
to double click on the submit button to
call the add function
now we are done with the html part the
next task is to create a function that
can perform addition over the values
entered by the user so let's move on to
the javascript file and we'll create a
function here
so we'll write here
function the function name is at and
then we have the body of this function
we'll take three variables we'll write
here where number one
will use the document
dot
get element by id
and id for number one is n1 we'll write
here dot
value and we'll do the same for number
two as well so we'll copy it from here
and we'll paste it here
instead of number one we'll write here
number two
and id will be number
two
and then we'll take
another variable where number three
that will hold the value after addition
so we'll write here
number one plus
number two fine
let's give some space between them
and the last thing we'll be doing here
is we'll be using the alert keyword and
we'll be printing the output on a
browser so
we'll write here the sum is
plus
number
three fine
now save it
and here we have created a simple
function to add two numbers the value of
the first number will be stored inside
variable number 1 and the second value
will be held inside variable number 2.
for instance if the user enters 10 in
box 1 and 20 in box 2 the expected
output will be 30 right
let's check it out so save it again and
we'll write here 10 in box 1
and 20 in box 2 and we'll double click
on the submit button
and here you can see the output is
different from what we have expected the
output is 1 0 2 0 instead of 30.
now what's happening here is the system
is taking the numbers as strings and
then the plus operator is used to append
those values so the solution is simple
what we have to do is we have to use the
parseint method and it will take care of
the rest we have already discussed this
parseint method in the previous sessions
right so we'll write here
before this
document.getelementbyid
we'll write here parseint
and we'll keep this inside
brackets fine we'll do the same for
number two as well
we'll write here percent and we are good
to save it now and we'll write here 10
and 20 again we'll write 10 inside the
first box and 20 inside the second one
and double click on this submit button
and you can see the output is 30 now it
says the sum is 30.
now we have used the alert keyword here
to print the output but we could have
used the console.log to print the same
right
so let me just take you through the
developer tools first and then we'll
discuss about it
so we'll maximize this chrome we'll go
to the chrome browser
and we will press f12 here so on
clicking the f12 key from our keyboard
we have this over here so we have the
elements tab the elements tab consists
of the structure of the document if you
hover on anything over the elements page
you will see that we are getting the
output of what that particular statement
did on the web page
you can see if we hover on the body tag
we are getting the whole area occupied
by the body tag inside the web page now
the next part is the console we already
know what the console can do for us
we know that we can print the output
over our console and perform some
temporary logic building here the
benefit of using a console is that it
can get you all the errors that the vs
code can't for example if we move back
to our vs code and let's say when we
were writing our program we made a small
typing mistake and we wrote here var b
instead of where you can see vs code
will let us know that there is something
wrong in this statement there is a red
line over here so we have to fix this
problem and the console will also let us
know about it but there are some errors
which the vs code can't detect
what we'll do is we'll comment these two
lines for now
so we'll
correct it first and then we'll comment
these two lines
fine
what we'll do is
we'll write here
console.log
and
inside this will write here
the sum is and we'll write here
number one
plus
number two fine
now this is also the same thing we just
did instead of using the alert box to
print the output we have used the
console for it so let's check the
outcome first we'll save it first and
then we'll
open the console here
so here you can see on writing the
numbers inside these text boxes and on
double clicking this submit button you
can see we have the output as
one zero two zero now
one thing we have to keep in mind is we
have to write here parseint
so we'll write here percent again and
we'll put these two numbers inside
brackets save it now and we'll go back
to our chrome browser we'll write here
10 and 20 again now double click on the
submit button and you can see it says
sum is 30. it's working totally fine
now imagine a situation where we forgot
to put the plus sign here
right what i'm saying is imagine a
scenario so let me just do one thing let
me put this console
here and
what we'll do is let's say we forgot to
put this plus sign over here
fine the vs code is not giving us any
hint about the mistake we just made we
have no idea about it and we came to
know about it during execution save it
and write here
10 and
20 fine
now we are expecting the output as 30
but we don't have any idea about the
mistake double click on the submit
button and you can see we have an error
message over here in the console so the
console helps us in finding those hidden
errors in our program you can see we
have the information about the mistake
we made in the console here
so we have the exact location of the
error the error is present on line 5 of
this file so here is the error
it will let us know everything about the
error
now another way to find the error in a
program is by going through the sources
tab
so
what we'll do is we'll move this console
to the side again
and we'll go to the sources tab and you
will notice that this particular line is
highlighted in red color we can change
it here but the change will not be
visible in our main javascript file so
we have to change it there in our main
javascript file
let's correct the error over there
what we'll do is we'll zoom this vs code
as well so we'll put the plus sign here
again now save it
and we are good to go now the sources
tab is used to find the errors as well
as we can go through the execution of
the program step by step now we have the
navigator here on the left hand side so
this is the navigation part
and on the right hand side we have the
debugger
here you can see we have so many options
over here we have certain breakpoints we
have breakpoints we have scope call
stack
dom breakpoints global listeners event
listener breakpoints so breakpoint
refers to the point of place where we
intentionally stop the program so that
we can review the further execution
process for example we have an event
listener in our program right the on
double click event what we can do is we
can stop the execution process when the
system reaches there
now what we have to do is we have to go
to the event listener breakpoints
and we have to select the mouse option
over here now inside this mouse option
we have certain events right you can see
we have click double click mouse down
mouse up and we'll click on this double
click event
now write any numbers over here inside
the text boxes so let's say we are
writing here 20
and 30 double click on the submit button
and you can see the screen turned grey
now this code looks a little bit long
because we are using the live server so
let me just pause the live server and
then i'll come back to you guys
now we'll open this page and inside here
what we'll do is
we'll
choose the mouse option we'll choose the
double click option inside
mouse so here's the mouse and we'll
choose the double click option
so we are doing the same thing
let me just increase the size a bit
now we'll write here 20 and 30 inside
number two double click on the submit
button and you can see the rest of the
browser screen turning gray and
execution is stopped at this particular
line
because we have a double click event
over here now what we can do is we can
go further step by step in our program
we have four options over here you can
see we have one two three and four
options
now the first option is
the resume script execution the resume
script execution will execute the entire
script and give us the output the next
option is the step or next function call
and it will take us to the next function
call present in the program then we have
the step into the next function call and
it will do the same as the step over
next function call
and then we have step out of the current
function
it will take us back to the initial
function from wherever we are
now the last option is the step option
and it takes us a step forward in the
program
fine now click on this step function
again and again so when you click it
once you can see we are in the next part
so this is the next line which will be
executed in the program click on the
step again and you can see we are going
further step by step
right and then you can see
the javascript file is executed and it
will move back to this double click
event and the final step it will print
the output on the console so if we go
here on the console you can see we have
the output is 50. fine so this is how we
can review our program step by step
and one more thing is it will show us
the error as well now let's try to
create an error in our program what
we'll do is we'll move to a javascript
file and we'll remove this
i from here fine so save it now
and move back to
chrome and what we'll do is we'll
refresh this file and we'll write here
two numbers we'll write here 20
and 30.
double click on the submit button you
can see the program is stopped at this
particular breakpoint now click on the
step button
and you can see we are going for the
step by step
the moment it will execute this line it
will give us an error and you can see
the moment it executed this particular
line the line turned red fine if we go
to a console you can see here we have
the error over here it says parseint is
not defined or percent is not defined so
this is a reference error and this is
how the chrome developer tools help us
in finding those errors and fixing them
now a big question here is why we are
using the developer tools the program is
small and we can find the error by
ourselves so guys this was just an
example to illustrate how we can find
those minor hidden errors in a program
the scenario can be different at times
suppose we have a program that has over
1000 lines of code
and in that case we simply can't go
through each line to find that
particular error we need something with
which we can see the error quickly and
more efficiently
so that's where the developer tools come
into picture and help us
almost all the browsers these days
support developer tools so there's no
such problem that you can't use the
developer tool with any particular
browser so try it in the browser you are
using and let us know about your
experience in the comment box
in this particular video we'll first go
through iterators in javascript and then
we'll move on to generators and we'll
see the differences between iterators
and generators in javascript before we
dig deeper into this topic let's create
an array here
so we know that an array is basically a
single variable used to store multiple
elements right so let's create one array
here we'll move to a javascript file and
we'll create an array over here so we'll
write here where arr is equals to so
this is the syntax for array let's add
some elements as well we'll write here
bmw
then we'll write here let's say
audi
then we have mercedes and then finally
let's say we have a company named
honda fine so this is a simple array
with four elements they all are car
manufacturers so let's print this array
on the console we are doing some basic
tasks as of now so we'll write here
console.log and we'll print this array
in a console
let's also print the length of this
array so we'll write here console.log
and we'll write here arr dot
length fine we know that arr.length is
the array property and it is used to
determine the length of a particular
array right so let's save this program
we'll open a console inside a browser
so here you can see we have array and
this is a array we have four array
elements bmw od mercedes and honda
present at index 0 1 2 and 3
respectively right and then we have the
length of the array as well which is 4
so 4 is the length of the array
now this was the primary task we haven't
done anything extra yet
so let's talk about iterators in
javascript now iterator itself defines
the meaning of the term it means to
traverse something till now we have been
using the traditional method or we can
say we are using the for loop for
traversing any array right
the syntax was easy what we have to do
is we have to write here let's traverse
this array once we'll write here 4 will
write here let
i is equals to 0 i is a variable which
will be used to traverse this array and
then we have the condition if i is less
than
array dot
length and then what we'll do we'll
increment the value of i by 1 right so
this is a for loop inside this will
write here console.log
and will print arr of i
fine so we are done with it let me just
comment these two statements
we are good to go
now the variable i will go through each
element present in the array and print
them in sequence until it reaches the
end of the array so let's check the
output
save it and here you can see we have all
the elements of our array present in the
console
so we have bmw audi mercedes and honda
we have all the elements here now let me
tell you guys an alternative to this
existing for loop
the alternative is for of loop in
javascript
the syntax is so simple that we have to
write only few words
and we are good to so let's go through
the syntax of for of loop what we'll do
is we'll write here for
we have a variable
i
of
array so arr is a error name and then we
have the body of this for off loop now
what we'll do inside here is we'll write
here
console.log and we'll write i only
so we are good to go let me comment this
for loop as well or it might create a
confusion for you guys so we are good to
go save it now and you can see the
output remains same we have bmw od
mercedes and honda
now this variable i over here will
traverse through the array and print all
the values in the console now you guys
might be wondering why we are discussing
this concept of four off loop in
javascript as the syntax of for loop is
also pretty straightforward right
but there is a problem with the for loop
that if we try to nest a loop inside any
loop the complexity grows also the
chances of any error increases if we
have several variables inside the loop
now that's why i told you this
alternative to for loops in javascript
so let's move ahead and we'll move on to
iterators in javascript now
now an iterator is an object that uses a
method to return an object with two
properties the two properties are value
and we'll discuss these two properties
later on in this video
now talking about traversing an array we
can do it with for loop or the for off
loop we can say but you know guys we can
do the same thing with iterators in
javascript we can traverse each element
present in the array one by one we are
not going to traverse all the elements
present in the array at once we are
going to do it one by one we'll traverse
a single element then we'll print it and
then we'll move on further now the
concept of iterators is a little bit
tricky but you will get it if you go
through it keenly what we have to do is
we have to create a function first so
let's create a function
we'll comment all this piece of code
and
here is our array we'll be working on
this array only now let's create a
function over here we'll create a
function let's say
cars
and then we have the body of this
function now this function cars over
here will have arrays passed to it as
parameters
let's create a variable that will
traverse the array just like we had the
variable i in for loop so let's create a
similar variable here what we'll do is
we'll write here let
index
is equals to 0
so this is a variable this index
variable will go through each element
present in the array and this car's
function will return an object
by the definition of iterators we know
that an iterator is an object that
returns an object with two properties
right so what we'll do here is we'll
return an object what we'll do is we'll
write here return
and we'll use curly braces over here now
this function cars will return an object
and this object will use a function next
that will return the two properties we
are discussing about
it might sounds a bit tricky but let's
do it here and you'll understand it much
better
what we'll do is we'll write here inside
this
next so this next will be a
function
and then we have the body of this
function now next is a function here
which will be called to print the
current elements value and it will take
the index variable to the next error
element it will return the properties as
well the two properties are value ended
now the traversing of the array starts
here actually what we want is we want
the index variable to traverse the array
until it reaches the end
so we'll use the if else statement to do
this task we have the arraylength
property now we'll write here
if
index
is
less than
values dot length
but we'll print over here
we'll write here
value
is equals to values and we'll make an
increment in the value of index we'll
write here index plus plus
then we'll use comma and we'll write
here done
and the value of done will be false fine
now the if condition will be checked and
this object will return the value and
done properties we can write here
anything other than done as well the
program will work totally fine it's not
that we have to follow specific rules in
iterators we can also write here and or
reached and in the place of done
that's up to you guys so let's include
the else part as well
we'll write here else
and then we'll write here
return
and we'll write here
done
as
true this error over here is because we
haven't included anything here so we
have to write here
return
fine now the error is gone you can see
now the value of done is true means that
the variable index has reached the end
of the array and there are no more
elements present in the array so save
this program and let's check the output
now you can see we have no error over
here what we have to do is we have to
create a variable to use this object or
iterator we can say
what we'll do is
we'll move over here and we'll create a
variable here so we'll write here where
new cars is equals to
cars and will pass
array to this variable fine
now we have been using this for quite a
long time we already have enough
knowledge about objects in javascript so
what we'll do next is we'll write here
new cars
and we'll write here dot next we'll call
the next function
so this new cars variable will pass our
array to the function cars in the form
of a parameter
the next thing is we are calling the
next function along with this new car
variable so let's check the output
quickly
save it
and you can see we have an error over
here right so you can see it says index
is not defined okay we have made some
you can see here we have right here i n
d e we have forgot to put an x over here
so save it now and you can see here we
have an object with the value as bmw and
the done is marked as false
it is an object with two properties we
discussed earlier you can see it has two
properties done and value right done is
false and value is bmw
now the benefit of using iterators is if
we execute this statement again the
output will be the value present in the
following index of the array so what if
we write here console.log again we'll
copy this line over here and we'll paste
it again save it now and you can see we
have another value as od and the value
of done is still false
so
the good thing is it prints all the
elements if we try executing the same
statement again and again until it
reaches the end of the array so let's
try it what we'll do is we'll write here
console.log four times or we can say
let's do it five times save it and you
can see here it says
true at last right we have all the
values we have bmw first followed by
audi mercedes and honda and at the last
it says the value of done is true now
it means that the variable index has
reached the end of the array the value
of done is true means it has reached the
end of the array of course we can access
the values as well what we have to do is
we have to write here
dot value after this
so if we write here dot value and save
it you can see we have bmw only let's do
the same for all
we'll write here dot value
again
and save it now you can see it says bmw
or d mercedes honda and then undefined
it means that
the array ends at honda there is no
element present in the array after honda
so we have all the values present in the
array in a sequence it is working
totally fine
now let me tell you guys the practical
use of iterators in javascript
there is no practical use of this topic
but you may find it helpful from an
interview point of view you may get
questions from such topics because these
topics are pretty tricky and time
consuming as well so this is an
excellent topic though if you want to
access the elements of an array or maps
in a sequence then you can use iterators
for such tasks we used iterators
previously and we know that an iterator
is an object that uses a method to
return an object with two properties
value and done right
now the code was easy so let's go
through it once quickly and then we'll
move on to generators
so guys here's the code for iterators in
javascript you can see we have created
an object that was giving us two
properties and every time the next
function will be called the next element
of the array will be printed until the
value of done is false now once the done
is changed to true this means that this
is the end of the array and there are no
more elements present in that same array
now this was easy but the method was a
little lengthy and we have to be more
careful while writing the code for
iterators this code was more prone to
errors as well and we had to loop so
many things inside a single function
quite a tricky task right
now guys what if i tell you that we can
do such tasks so easily in javascript
without giving so much effort and just
by writing few lines of code
yes we can do it with generators in
javascript a generator function allows
us to define an iterative algorithm by
writing a single non-continuous function
the syntax is also not tricky all we
have to do is to create a function
with a asterisk sign and we are good to
go so let's go through the syntax and
you will understand it much better so we
we'll move to a javascript file and
we'll write here
function
asterisk
let's say the function name is
generate fine and then we have the body
of this function
now this asterisk over here tells the
system that this is not a regular
function this is a generator function
that has some specific task to do
that is to generate the value on the go
now inside here of this function we have
to write that part which we want to
access
like if we write here
let's say we are writing here let
i is equals to 0
so let's say i is the variable that
we'll be using for traversing purpose
and then we'll write here
yield
bmw
will copy this statement and we'll paste
it
four times let's say and we'll change
the values so first we have bmw then we
have audi
third we have
mercedes
and fourth we have
let's say honda
fine
so let's assume that these are the array
elements it means that these are the
elements present inside an array let's
assume it only now the yield keyword is
used to stop the generator function
and it returns the value following it
think of it as a return that is
generator based it returns the value to
the user upon calling the generator
function so let's call it first
and the calling part will remain the
same we'll use a variable to call the
generate function and then call the next
function in the console
so what we'll do is
we'll write here
let let's say gen is a variable and
we'll
write here generate so we'll call this
function here and we'll write here
console.log
inside this we'll write gen dot
next fine
now save it
and go to the console so here's the
console and you can see we have an
object as output click on this object
and you can see we have done as false
and value as
bmw now the good thing with generators
is that we don't have to specify this
next method anywhere in the code
it has the next method predefined that
makes the task sort of easy for us right
now if we write this statement here
again and save it so we'll what we'll be
doing is we'll be copying this
particular statement and we'll paste it
here save it and here you can see we
have the value as od and done is still
false
now
we have audi here with done as false
because this is not the last element
present right it will return done as
false until the values are printed once
it reaches the end then we'll change to
true and the value will be undefined
easy task right we have been through it
already copy it
and
we'll paste it several times now save it
and here you can see we have value as
bmw for first gen dot next then we have
audi mercedes honda and finally we have
the value as undefined and done is true
it means that honda was the last element
present in the array now the next thing
is to use it with a loop if you want to
do this task with a loop we can do it
what we have to do is we have to write
here
inside this function we have to create
an array over here so we'll remove these
elements and we'll write here
where ar is equals to so let's say this
is a array
we'll write here bmw
or d
fine this is our array now what we'll do
is we'll
take a loop let's say we are using while
loop will write here while i is less
than
ar dot length
so this is an array property and inside
this will write
yield yield keyword we have already
discussed and will yield ar of i
fine
and then we'll increment the value of i
by 1 we are good to go
so what we'll do is
we'll remove
this piece of code
now save it and you can see we have the
first value as bmw and then is false
now
use console.log again here
for the second element which is od and
then we'll use it again
for mercedes and finally if we paste it
here again you can see we have honda
over here right so honda is the last
element present in the array if we do it
once again
press enter save it and you can see the
value is changed to undefined and done
is true now now we can also write here
gen dot next dot value
so if we write here dot value the output
will be bmw only of course the value
only
so we can do it for each console.log
save it now and you can see we have the
values here bmw audi mercedes honda and
undefined now we did the same thing with
iterators as well so we concluded that
the concept of generators is easy and
more reliable than the concept of
iterators in javascript both can do the
same task but generators can do it more
easily right creating an object in
javascript is what we have been doing
for a long time now we'll not go deep
into that topic but let's create an
object here with some properties just to
brush up some things
so the syntax was simple what we have to
do is we have to write here
where let's say my object name is
my car
will write here new
object
and then we have the body of this object
now we will add some properties to this
object we'll write here
my car dot
manufacturer equals to let's say ford
fine
and then we'll write here my car
dot name
is equals to let's say
raptor
fine and then we have
my car dot
color so let's say the car color is
black fine
so this is our object now we have
created an object here named mycar and
we have three car properties car
manufacturer name and color so we can
access the whole object now to access
the whole object what we have to do is
we have to write here
console.log
and we'll write here the object name
fine
so this is our object
save it and go to console
so here you can see we have an object
over here
now on clicking this object you can see
we have all the properties of our object
we have
color as black manufacturer as ford and
name is raptor quite an easy and helpful
task right we can also access particular
properties for example let's say we want
to know the car's color and nothing else
so we have to do a simple task for that
we have to write here my car dot color
fine save it and you can see we have the
value as black on a console
and apart from this we can also add
properties to an existing object from
the outside we have already done it
now what we'll do here is we'll write
here
my card dot
let's say make so this is the
manufacturing year let's say so let's
say 2012 is the manufacturing year of my
car
and
we'll
remove this color property from here and
we'll print the whole object on our
console save it and you can see we have
an object with color make manufacturer
and name
we have all the properties in fact the
make property is also added to the
object's properties
now the question here is why are we
discussing objects before maps there is
a specific reason for this guys because
maps in javascript are similar to
objects and one can use objects in place
of maps or maps in place of objects we
can say
but still there are some differences
between objects and maps although both
of them use key value pairs and give us
the required output but there are still
some minor differences between them so
let's understand the difference between
them with a simple example what we'll do
is we'll create an empty object so
here's our object what we'll do is we'll
remove all the properties of this object
so this is an empty object
now what we'll do is
we'll create an empty map as well
right so the syntax for maps is quite
similar to that of objects we'll write
here where
my car is equals to
new
map
and then we have the body of this map
fine
and we'll write here
console.log
my car
fine now we have two different objects
here one is a simple object and the
other one is a map object there is a
slight change in the object name you can
see over here the map object here is
with 2r so let's check the output on the
console
now save it you can see here the
difference between a regular object and
a map object
click on this empty object you can see
the prototype is object and the
prototype for map
object is a map fine
now let's move on to vs code again and
we'll go through maps now so this is a
minor difference between maps and
objects so let's discuss maps now what
we'll do is
we'll add key value pairs to our map now
so like objects we have several methods
for maps as well values can be added to
a map with the help of set method
now the syntax is simple we'll see it so
what we'll do is we'll write here
my car dot set so set here is a method
and inside this bracket we will provide
a key and a value
now let's say we are writing here one
comma
bmw
will add
another
property we'll write here my car dot set
write here 2 and let's say we'll write
here od
fine and then we'll write here my car
again dot set
3 comma
mercedes
fine
now the set method has keys and values
for each map property
unlike objects where we can assign only
string and specific symbol as property
name we can use anything here in maps
for doing the same task a key can be a
number a key can be an object function
or in fact anything
it can be a string as well so that's the
benefit of using maps in javascript this
is also a difference between objects and
maps now that we have added values to
our maps so let's check the output now
save it and you can see here we have
three entries on our map keys and values
for each entry separated by an arrow you
can see one is the key bmw is the value
2 is the key od is the value
separated by arrows fine
we can access any of these entries with
the help of the get method just like the
set method we have another method in
maps we'll write here my car dot
get and we'll pass the key
so let's say we are passing here 3 3 is
the key for mercedes save it and here
you can see we have the value as
mercedes over here on our console this
get method will give us the value
present at key 3.
we can get any value here just by
passing the key number to this get
method we can also determine the size of
this map
now to determine the size of this map we
have another method here
so what we have to do is we have to
write here my card dot
size so
this will determine the size of our map
save it and here you can see the size is
3. fine
so as i mentioned previously that a key
can be a number a string a function or
in fact an object so let's try to use
them as keys and see if it works or not
so this is our map what we'll do is
we'll remove these
three properties from here
and we'll print this map only fine
now inside here we'll write
my card dot set
so let's say the key is
string
for value one so we'll write here
my car
name is
and then we'll pass the value here
we'll write here bmw fine so we have a
string as key now
next up we'll write here my card dot
set
will pass an object as a key
and the value is let's say
honda
fine
lastly we'll pass a function as a key
we'll write here
my car dot set and will pass a function
away
and the value is let's say
mercedes fine
of course we can define these functions
or objects somewhere in the program
but for now we'll keep it simple so that
you guys can have an idea of what we are
trying to do here
so save it
and you can see here there is no error
or any sort of problem in the console
it's working fine
we can access any particular value by
passing the key to the get method you
can see here we have
my car name is bmw present at 0 and then
we have an object at 1 and a function at
2. so we can pass any function or object
as key as well
now we simply cannot pass this curly
braces to the get function to get the
value or even the function we cannot
pass so it will return undefined to get
a particular output what we have to do
is we have to use
variables first we have to define these
functions and objects using variables
and then we can use those variables so
that's a different task so what we'll do
here is we'll write here
my card dot
get
and we'll pass
object here save it and here you can see
the output is undefined
now this isn't what we were looking for
right so the solution is simple what we
have to do is we have to
write here
let
obj
is equals to
an object
and let
func is equals to a
function
fine
now we can use these variables so
instead of
writing here curly braces what we'll do
is we'll write here
obj and instead of using the whole
function here we'll write here
func
fine now the next thing we'll do here is
we'll write here the variable name
so we'll write here
funk
save it and here you can see we have the
value as mercedes present for function
here right we can also do the same for
object as well if we write here obj and
save it you can see we have the output
as honda
what we did here was an easy task we
just used separate values for the object
and function and then use the variables
as keys
now the next thing is maps can be used
with arrays as well all we have to do is
to define an array with key value pairs
and pass the array to map as a parameter
and the rest is the same so let's do it
as well
what we'll do is
we'll
remove this
we'll remove this as well fine
we'll write here
where
my arr is equals to
we'll write an array over here we'll
write here
one comma
bmw
then we'll write here
2 comma
od
and
finally we have
3 comma
honda let's say so this is our array
this is our key value pairs one is the
key bmw is the value 2 is the key or d
is the value
now what we have to do is we have to
pass this array to the map
fine we'll cut this from here and we'll
paste it over here
now this is a map
where my car is a map now we have to
pass this array we'll write here my arr
fine
we can remove these curly braces
now
if we write here my car dot get or let's
say if we write here console.log my car
fine
save it and you can see we have a map
with keys and values
we have the same map over here but this
time we have used arrays
and we can access any particular element
as well we'll write here dot get
and we'll pass the key here let's say we
are passing 2
save it and here you can see we have the
output as od good to go with it right
now we can also use the for off loop to
traverse this array and get the keys and
values it's a simple task i hope you
guys are getting all this so
for the far off loop what we have to do
is we have to write here for
let
and we'll write here key comma
value
of
my car
and then we have the body of this for
off loop we'll write here
console.log
and we'll print the keys and the values
fine so we'll write here key
then space and then we'll write here
value
save it and here you can see we have
keys and values here we have
one bmw two audi and three honda
fine
we can also print keys and values
separately as well what we have to do is
we have to make some changes here
we have to write here
only key and
instead of my car we have to write here
my car dot keys so this is a method so
we have to put brackets over here and we
have to remove this from here
save it and here you can see we have all
the keys one two and three
similarly we can access all the values
as well by writing values in place of
keys so we have another method here
as my car dot values we have to use that
for values
now the last thing before we wrap up
this video is we can also clone maps in
javascript
now cloning refers to creating a copy of
something right
so let's say we want to clone this
particular
map
we have an array over here we'll remove
this statement
and then we have used the for loop so
let's remove the for off loop as well
now we have an arrow over here
array contains
three key value pairs bmw od and honda
now we want to clone this map so this is
our map my car is our map and we want to
clone this right
so let's say we have another map over
here
we'll name it as where yoka
and then we'll write here is equals to
new
map and we'll pass my car as an argument
here
fine
now we have a clone of our map here
and we'll write here
console.log instead of my car we'll
write here
yoka
fine
save it and you can see we have a new
map over here with the exact same key
value pairs right we have one bmw 2 or
dn3 honda
but the fun part is these two maps are
not equal it means that if we write here
console.log and if we compare these two
maps if we write here my car is equals
to
your car
save it and you can see the output says
false
they are not equal
set in javascript is an object that lets
us store unique values inside it we have
seen the difference between maps and
objects in javascript previously
so we know that maps are another type of
object present in javascript and
different from traditional objects
now sets are similar to maps in
javascript it means that they are also
objects but they perform various
activities other than maps
so the syntax is almost the same and
even the properties are also the same to
some extent so let's take a look at sets
in javascript as we mentioned earlier
sets let us store unique values it means
that if we create a set and try to keep
a single value inside the set more than
once it will not allow us to do so
so let's see an example of it first
what we'll do
we'll go to a javascript file and we'll
write here
where
my set
is equals to new so here we'll write set
and this is the
syntax of sets in javascript next up
we'll write here console
dot log
and we'll print my set
fine
now save it
and here we have created a new set and
we don't have any values until now we'll
add values in a moment so open the
console on the browser you will go to a
browser and will open console here so
here you can see we have an empty set
over here with no entries if we click on
it you can see we have no entries we
have no properties and the size is zero
now let's add some values to this set
what we'll do is we'll write here
my set dot add and we'll add a value
value so
we'll do it for three or four values
we'll write here my set dot add will
write here two
will copy this paste it here for two
more times and we'll write here three
and
four fine
now we have added these four values to
our set a basic task right the same add
method we used for maps is what we did
for sets as well now save it
and you can see here on the console
that we have the size as four
now you can see here we have values one
two three and four and the size is also
four and we can add as many values as we
want to our set but we can't add any
value to our set again for example
if we write here let's say if you are
writing here
my set dot add and then we'll write here
fine what we are doing is we are trying
to add 3 again to this set our set has a
value 3 already so this is the value 3.
now it will not allow us to add 3 again
save it
and you can see we still have 4 values
present in our set the new value we
added to our set is not present inside
the set you can see here we have 1 two
three and four this three is not added
to our set
so this is the benefit of using sets in
javascript so let's take an example of
an array as well let's say we have an
array of some numbers and several
elements in the array are repeating
themselves so let's create a new array
here
what we'll do is we'll comment out this
piece of code so that there will be no
confusion for you guys and we'll create
an array over here so let's say this is
our array with name arr
and we'll add elements to this array now
we'll write here 1 2 3 4 2
3 and any values any random values we
are adding to this array so you can see
we have
so many elements here which are
repeating themselves like 2 3 and 1
and so many elements right
now we have an array here and the
elements inside the array are repeating
right
so we have 2 3 4 so many times now what
we want is we want unique elements from
this array traditionally we had to
follow a particular pattern to achieve
this task wherein we had to iterate
through each element in the array using
nested for loop and we have to check if
the element present inside the array are
repeating or not quite a lengthy task
right or a hectic task to do but with
sets in javascript we do not have to
follow this method anymore all we have
to do is to pass that array as an
argument to the set and we'll get the
unique elements of the array
so to do so
we have to write here
so let's say we have a set named
my set 2 so this is a different set from
the previous one we used we'll write
here new set
and we'll pass this array as an argument
so we'll write here console.log
and we'll write here
my set 2
now save it and you can see we have all
the distinct elements of our array
you can see here we have 1 2 3 4 45 5
and six the size of the array is or we
can say the size of the set is seven
fine
we can also print this set again in the
form of an array we just have to write
here
let's my arr so this is a new array and
we'll write here
array dot
from
and now what we'll do is we'll pass this
my set 2 as an argument to this array
now we'll write here
console.log
and we'll print here
my arr so this is our array save it and
here you can see we have an array over
here with all the unique elements we
have one two three four forty five five
and six the length is seven
and here you can see we have the set in
the form of an array fine
we can also traverse all the elements
present inside the set or array just by
using the for off loop in javascript
so we have to write here
let's say
for
we'll take a variable let item
off we'll use set this time we'll write
here my set
and will print this item on
console
we'll write here console.log and will
print
item fine
all of this is easy right you must have
got it we have all the methods present
for sets as well just like we had for
maps in javascript
now save it and here you can see we have
all the elements of this particular my
set so my set 2 consists of all the
elements of this array all the unique
elements we can say so here you can see
we have one two three four and all the
unique elements of my set
now if we comment out this or we can say
if we are using an array in this for of
loop if we write here my arr
and save it here you can see the output
still remains the same we have all the
elements of array now we have all the
elements of my arr
and all the elements are unique
now we can also delete a particular
entry from the set by using the delete
method the delete method is same for
maps as well what we have to do is
we have to write here
my set to dot
delete
and we have to pass that particular
element so let's say we want to delete
45 from this set
now save it and
what we'll do next is we'll print
this set again
and we'll write here my set
fine save it and here you can see we
have
the size as 6 now you can see we have
the elements 1 2 3 4 5 6 45 is not
present here and here you can see
initially we had the elements as 1 2 3 4
45 as well
so you can do it with the help of delete
function in javascript now same thing we
did for maps as well and if we want to
delete all the entries from the set we
can use the clear method
what we'll do here is we'll write here
my set 2 dot
clear and we'll run this statement and
we'll print
set again fine
we'll write here my set to save it and
here you can see the size of this set is
zero now
if we comment out this piece of code as
well now save it and here you can see we
have the size of set as
this was initially showing the size of
our set which was 7 and if we click on
this as well you can see we have no
entries because it will not print any
values once the clear method is executed
by the system so this is working totally
fine
now that we have covered almost every
property of sets in javascript i think
you guys will be able to use sets now as
per your requirements we have come
across almost every important topic in
javascript
whether it is an important one like
regular expressions in javascript or the
one mainly asked in interviews like
promises in javascript each topic has
its own value in javascript and every
topic is important
so in today's video we'll come across
two different types of games the first
one will be the one wherein we'll
recreate flappy words using javascript
now many of you guys must have heard
about this game already if not we have
to take a bird through a space between
two walls in this particular game so let
me just take you through the game once
and
here we are so this is our game you can
see we have a bird over here and we have
to take this bird through this yellow
hole present in between the blue color
right the yellow holes are random and if
the bird strikes the blue wall or maybe
at the bottom of the screen
then the game will over fine so i hope
you guys understood what we have to do
in this particular game now we have to
press a key from the keyboard to make
the bird jump repeatedly and we have to
make the bird jump so that the bird will
go through the hole between the walls
without touching the boundaries of the
hole
so i hope you guys must have understood
the task here
now
let's try to recreate this game again
from scratch and we'll do everything by
ourselves we'll go through the html part
we'll go through the javascript and
we'll go through the css as well both
html and css will play a vital role in
making this game along with the
javascript part obviously
so let's start with the code now we'll
go back to vs code and here you can see
we have a html file named flappy bird
dot html so we'll change the title of
this as well we'll write here
instead of document we'll write here
flappy bird fine save it
now first of all we'll take a container
for the game to run so
as you can see here we have a container
over here fine so this is our container
now we have to create this whole
container
now what we'll do for that is we'll go
to the body tag and we'll write here
div
id is let's say
game
and we'll close this day now inside this
particular div we'll create three more
div tags so we'll write here div
id is equals to
block or we can write here pipe as well
for the wall or for the pipe we can say
the next will write here div
id is equals to hole that
is for the whole
and the last one is for the
bird fine so we'll write it div
id is equals to
bird
we'll close this div and a fundamental
task is done here now we have a
container for the game we'll put the
game inside one single container
the next thing we need in a game is a
block which we'll use to create the
walls in the game followed by the hole
in the block for the bird to go through
it right and the last thing is the bird
itself so we'll add an image here for
the bird so let's do some styling for
all this that we have written over here
so what we'll do is we'll move to a css
file so this is a css file
and we'll write here
for the whole document the margin will
be
zero by default
okay so we'll write it as 0
and
the padding will be
0 as well fine
we're good to go that's a common thing
the margin and the padding will remain 0
for the whole html document
the next thing is to create the
background of whole document
so we'll do something creative here
something different from what we did
till now
so what we'll do is we'll create the
background with two different colors
now you might be thinking of what these
two different colors are so what we'll
do is we'll write here body
and then we'll write here
background color we'll take any
background color
let's say we are taking cadet blue
fine
now save it
save this part as well and open this on
live server
so here you can see we have a background
we have the background of html document
as credit blue color
now the next thing we'll do is we'll use
two different colors over this
background right so we'll write here
background
image and we'll write here
webkit linear gradient and we'll write
here
rgb
comma 75 comma 75
then we'll write here
rgb so these are three particular colors
we'll write here
31 comma 31 comma 31
and the last one will be
rgb
59 comma
153 comma
1 4 8
fine
so here we are
and the next thing we'll do is we'll
write here
min height
will be
800 pixels
now save it
and you can see here we have three
different colors over here we'll go to
our css file
and you can see this webkit linear
gradient over here is unknown to us
right so css gradients let us display
smooth transitions between two or more
specified colors
so we can do it radially or linearly
now let's see the difference
and you can spot the difference here in
the output
we have three different colors over here
we have red black and a little bit of
gray in between
right so let's move on to the first
container and we'll create the game area
now now what we have to do is we have to
create the game area
so what we'll do is we'll access the div
tag with ids game
and let's start working on this div tag
and we'll understand it much better
so we'll write here
game
and we'll write here next up
height of this container will be let's
say 500 pixels
width
is let's say 400 pixels so guys remember
this height and width will need them
later
now the next thing we'll do is we'll
write here
border and the border will be one pixel
solid
black in color fine
and we'll add a background image as well
we'll write a background image
or we'll write a background only
we'll write a url and inside this will
write
fine save it now and
you can see here we have a container
over here
now it's not working it says there's no
such image present in a folder so what
we'll do is we'll check it from here
here we are
we have bg2 over here not bg1
so we'll write here bg2.jpg save it now
and move back to the browser and here
you can see we have an image over here
so it's not quite visible till now so
what we'll do is
we'll write here
background size as
cover fine save it now
and here you can see we have an image
over here now the image looks fine
the next thing we'll do is we'll write
margin
and we'll write here
margin and the margin will be
one ram
and
auto fine save it now
you can see we have the block in between
now the next thing we'll do is we'll use
the overflow property here and it will
not show the bird going out of the box
so we'll see it in a moment but this
overflow property will do so what we'll
do is we'll write here overflow
is equals
to hidden
save it now
you can see it's not making any
difference as of now but we'll
understand it later
now we have a box over here on the
browser and the game will be played
inside this particular box now we have
to work on the div for the block
so we have to create a block
and that block will move again and again
through the screen with holes present at
a random place every time
fine i hope you guys got it so let's
style the block now what we'll do is
we'll go to a css file and we'll write
here
hash
block fine so this is the id for the
block
now inside this will use
width
as
50 pixels
then we have
height
so the height will be
500 pixels equal to the height of the
whole container
the next thing we'll write here is
background
color and the background color will be
let's say
blue
fine
we will write here
position as
relative
and
then we'll write here
left
400 pixels
fine
now we know that after saving this piece
of code the block will not be visible
anymore so why is it not visible it's a
question right
it arises in every person's mind save it
and here you can see the block is yet
not visible
now what we have to do is we have to set
the left property as 200 let's try to do
it 200 once so what we'll do is we'll
write here
200 pixels save it now and here you can
see we have a block over a screen now
the value of left property is 200 means
the block is present
to 200 pixels from the right most corner
of the container
if we write here 400
and save it
you can see we don't have any block here
it means that the block is present right
after this entire container the block
starts here and goes still here it's a
50 pixels wide block
and it's not visible because we have set
the left property as 400
so
now the next thing we have to do is we
need some animation over this box right
or we can say we need some animation
over this block right so what we'll do
is
we'll write here
animation and we'll
write here block we have
to perform it on a block and the
animation time will be two seconds we'll
write here
linear and
it will go to infinite fine
now this animation property will help us
in moving the box again and again
after every two seconds
and the moving points we have to define
here
so for that what we have to do is we
have to write here
at the rate
keyframes
this we'll write here block
and inside this will write zero percent
left will be
pixels
and at 100 animation
what we'll do is we'll set the left
property as
minus
50 pixels fine
now you guys might be wondering what we
are doing here but
this keyframe here is a rule that
specifies the animation code and it will
help the block move again and again from
400 pixel in the right to minus 50
pixels in the left
fine save it
and we'll go to the browser
you can see the box is moving again and
again after every two seconds or two
milliseconds now the next thing we have
to do is with the hole in the block so
we have to put a hole here in the block
and for that we have to access another
div with ids whole
fine so we'll move to a css file and
we'll access that particular
element with ids
whole so we'll write here hash
hole
and inside this we'll write
height of the hole will be
150 pixels less than that of the block
width will be
50 pixels same as the block
and then we'll write here
background
color
and so let's say the background color is
yellow
this is for
practical purpose you can change it by
yourself
the next thing we'll write here is
position position will be
relative
left will be
400 pixels
and
top will be
minus five double zero pixels fine
then we'll write a animation
again we'll write a block
we'll write here two seconds we'll write
a linear
and we'll write here
infinite fine
now this hole will also go with the same
animations as the block
save it
and
open the
browser and here you can see the hole is
not properly over the block and they are
both at different locations so we can
try to refresh this code and here you
can see
the hole is now present at the top of
the block so here is the hole this
yellow part represents the hole for this
particular game
now it is working totally fine
and this is an empty space to make this
hole randomly come anywhere in the block
we have to do some magic with javascript
for that so we'll do it later in this
video
now if the hole is not placed over the
block in your code don't worry just
refresh the code or we can say just
refresh the home page it will be fine or
if not it will get fine once we go
through the javascript part that's not a
major deal
so let's move on to the bird now what
we'll do is we'll add an image to html
file for the bird
so we'll write here
inside the html file we'll write here
where the ids board will write here
img
okay we have
we'll write here src is equals to
bird
one dot
png
so let me check if this file exists in a
system or not
so here we are we have bird dot png not
bird one dot png
save it and what we'll do is we'll write
here
alt is
but we'll close this img tag save it
open the browser and you can see the
bird is not visible as of now to make
this image visible we have to work on
the styling so we'll access this image
with the id board
what we'll do is we'll go to the css
file again
and we'll write here
hash board
the next thing we'll write here is
position
so position will be
fixed
and
top of bird will be 100 pixels
then we have
height
as
50 pixels and
width will also be
50 pixels fine we'll do the same for
image tag as well so we'll write here
bird
img
and inside this will write
height
is 50 pixels and we'll write a width
fine
is
50 pixels
right
now save it
and if we open the browser now
you can see we have a bird in our game
now we are halfway done in making our
game and we haven't used any javascript
until now right that's quite funny so
we'll use javascript now let's move on
to the javascript part
we'll go to the javascript file first
now first of all we'll access every
element of a javascript file that we can
access
so we'll use the get element by id
method to access every element of html
file
what we'll do is we'll write here where
whole so
whole
is the id of whole present in the block
so we can access that div tag here we'll
write here
document dot
get element by id and we'll write here
whole
fine
the next thing is we'll write here where
game
is equal to document dot
get element by id the id will be
the id will be game fine
so for now we need to access these two
elements only we'll add some more
elements later and then we'll access
them so for now let's focus on these two
only
next up we need the hole to be placed in
random places in the block every time
for that we need an event listener so
we'll create a function that will change
the location of this hole every time
it will change the location on every
iteration of the block
fine
so
we'll write here whole dot
add event listener
and we'll write here
animation iteration so this is a event
listener and we'll write here a function
name so let's say we are writing here
ran whole fine so this is a function
it's random hole so we'll write here
rain hole now we'll declare this
function as well we'll write here
function reinhold and
inside of this function we'll take a
variable
random let's say so this is a variable
we'll write here
minus
math dot
random
so this is a function and will
multiply this value by
so this means that it will take any
random value between 0 and 350. fine and
then what we'll do is we'll add 150 to
that particular value and the whole
value will be changed to minus
we'll see it in a moment why we are
doing so so the next thing we'll write
here is
whole dot style
dot left
now whole dot style dot
top
is equals
to random
plus
pixels fine i hope you guys got it till
now
so this math dot random function will
pick any random value between 0 to 350
and 150 will be added to that particular
value because we don't want the value to
go down as low as 10 and the hole will
go out of the containers borders so the
initial value of the hole was let's
check it out
so here we are in a css file so you can
see the initial value of whole
was
minus 500 pixels for top fine
so the new value will be random plus
pixels
the value was 500 because we wanted the
hole at the top of the block and now it
will take any random value and the whole
will be placed according to that
particular random value
so let's save it
open the browser and here you can see
the hole is moving randomly now you can
see it was initially present at the top
now it is at the bottom here
so it will change the location randomly
according to the random number picked up
by the math.random function so let's get
back to the javascript part now
before we move on to the fall and game
over function let's discuss the game
over scenario first and we'll finish out
all the necessary html and css tasks for
the game over
so the game will be over when the bird
strikes the pole or either the bird
falls down to the ground
on game over the score will be shown on
the screen with a restart button right
so the score will be counted on the
basis of blocks passed by the birds now
the number of blocks passed will be the
final score
so we'll take a variable score and
increase the value of this score
variable with each random block coming
through
so we'll take a variable score and we'll
write here
where score
is equals to 0 the initial value will be
0. so let's do the html part wherein
we'll use a div tag to print the result
on the screen
what we'll do is we'll go to the html
file
and here what we'll do is we'll write
here after this particular div tag
we'll write
diff
id is equals
to result
and here we have another div tag present
over here
now inside this div tag
we'll use
h1 tag and we'll write here game over
fine
next thing we'll do here is we'll use
p tag with ids
let's say text fine
we'll close the p tag here or the
paragraph tag we can say now we need a
button
so we'll write here button
id is equals to btn
we'll write here on click
is equals to location
dot
reload
and we'll write here
restart
fine now the html part is done the
paragraph tag with ids text will be used
to print the score on the scoreboard
now this
location.reload method is used to reload
the whole webpage
on clicking the start button
the entire page will be reloaded and the
game will start again
fine we'll use css to style all of this
game over part
so we'll go to the css file and here's
the css file
now we'll write here
hash
result we are accessing the div tag with
id as a result
so the height will be
let's say 200 pixels for result
and the width
is let's say
500 pixels fine
so
if i show you once again so here is the
block for game over scenario so the
height is 200 pixels and the width is
500 pixels basically we need to create a
card right or we can say a rectangle
so we'll move back to the css file and
will write here
background color is
let's say
down
margin will be five frame or two
so
margin top will be five rip and then it
will do it automatically
then we'll write here
border
so border will be two pixels solid
and the color will be white fine
we'll write here
border radius
so the border radius
will be let's say 20 pixels we want
rounded borders
and the display will be
none
fine
the last thing we'll do is we'll write
here text
align
as center it will align the text in the
center
and the next thing we are left with is
the button fine so we'll write here
hash btn
because the id of button element is btn
so we'll write here
padding
0.5
frame
and 1 ram
fine
the border
will be
none
because we don't need any border for
this button
we of course want the button to be round
from the corners so we'll write your
border radius as 11 pixels
background color is
green
color is
white
font size is
1.5 ram
we'll write it text
transform
upper case
we'll write here margin top
one rim
so guys you can see we are using this
ram again and again so i might wonder
that if any one of you knows the exact
definition of this word ram if yes then
do let us know in the comments below and
let's see how many of you guys know the
actual definition of this term
so the last thing we'll do is we'll
write here cursor is equals to pointer
and we are good too fine the next thing
is
we'll write here
hash text
margin
top will be
one ram
and
font size will be
2 ram fine
we'll do one more thing
we'll write here
color is
c shell so
this will be the color of our text
so we are now totally done with the html
and css part
the only thing remaining now is the
javascript part and we have to work on
that only
so just a few more files statements and
all and we are done with the game
now moving back to the javascript part
but before we go there let me just
show you how this works
save it and go to the browser so this is
our game
and you can't see any game over scenario
here right so for that what we have to
do is we have
to go here in result and we have to
comment this
particular statement fine
display has done we have to comment out
this statement save it now
and it's not working
now as well okay here's a mistake in
this div tag
what we did wrong here is
so this was a mistake save it now
and now here you can see we have a card
for game over over here and if you click
on this restart button you can see the
page is reloading again and again so
it's working totally fine we'll move
back to the css file
and we'll
remove this fine
save it now
and let's go back to the javascript part
now we'll access two more html elements
that we just created so what we'll do is
we'll
write here where
a result is equals
document dot get element by id and the
id is
a result fine
and then finally we'll write here where
text is equals to
document dot
get element by id
and id is
text fine
so the next thing we'll do is we'll
write here where
jumping
is equals to 0 we